HAVE THIRTEEN BILLS ON OUR
AGENDA WE HAVEONE ITEM CONFINED
CONSENT THAT'S ITEM NUMBER --
SIX THAT'S SB. THREE EIGHTY NINE
BY CENTER HERTZBERG I ALSO
SHOULD.
NOW SO SHOULD MENTION THAT ITEM
NUMBER.
SEVEN SB FOUR TWENTY FOUR BY SIR
JACKSON WILL BE PRESENTED BY SIR
DRAWS SO -- SO WITH THAT --
EVERYONE HERE I SEE CENTER HUESO
HERE.
AND I THINK YOU ARE THE FIRST
ONE UP WHO'S ON MEMORY TO
WELCOME SIR HUESO.
WILK THAT'S ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB
THREE OH FIVE SO.
AND HOW DO WE HAVE OKAY WHAT'S
THE ONE SHORT OKAY TO WILL BEGIN
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR OR GOOD
SENATOR DR THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL
TODAY THAT WILL.
EXTEND COMPASSION TO TOO MANY
CALIFORNIANS.
ON ON THEIR FACING TERMINAL
ILLNESS.
BEFORE I BEGIN THOUGH I'D LIKE
TO ACCEPT THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS THAT RESTRICT THE
NUMBER OF MEDICAL FACILITIES.
THIS BILL WOULD APPLY -- TO YOU
KNOW THE THE HOPE IS THAT WE
GIVE.
RELIEF AND AND HELP TO THE
PEOPLE OF OUR COMMUNITY WITHOUT.
RESTRICTING WHERE THEY CAN GO I
MEAN ONE OF THE REASONS WE SELL
SELECTED -- MISTER RYAN BARTEL
IS GOOD YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO TO
THE STATE OF WASHIGTON. TO BE --
TO GET ACCESS -- TO THESE --
THESE.
THESE RIGHTS I THINK THAT ARE
ARE A RIGHT RIGHTS OF EVERY
PATIENT BUT HE COULDN'T GET A
MINUTES OWN STATE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE IN OUR STATE CAN STAY
CLOSE TO THEIR FAMILIES.
AND AND STAY CONSCIOUS TO STAY
LUCID SO WERE ACCEPTING -- THE
NUMBER THAT RESTRICTS MEDICAL
FACILITIES WHICH WOULD ALSO
ENSURE THAT ALL THESE PEOPLE CAN
STAY IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
WITHOUT HAVING.
TO INCLUDE ALL MEDICAL
FACILITIES IT MIGHT NOT BE.
SUITABLE TO THIS.
I'M ALSO AGREED IN CONCEPT AND
AND I AM FULLY COMMITTED TO WORK
WITH YOU MISTER CHAIR -- TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND AND YOUR
WONDERFUL STAFF -- TO FUTURE
AMENDMENT THAT WILL ALLOW
FACILITIES TO SUSPEND COMPLIANCE
WITH THE BILL.
IF THE ENFORCEMENT POSITION OF
FEDERAL AGENCIES CHANGE.
IN THE FUTURE ON THE MEDICAL
CRACKED ON A MARIJUANA AS WE
KNOW IT'S STILL A FEDERALLY
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE AND THERE
ARE MANY CONCERNS AND WE HAVE A
GOOD RESPONSE TO WHY.
WERE ALLOWING THIS. TO TO TAKE
TAKE THE FACT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE VERY STRONG ARGUMENTS ON
GOVERNMENT -- GIVE IT THERE'S A
RIVER REVERSAL IN THERE FOR
SPENT.
I THINK OUR STATE -- WILL HAVE
THE ABILITY TO RESPOND TO THAT
AND I WANNA MAKE THE BILL --
RESPONSIVE TO THAT BECAUSE I I I
I THINK IT SHOULD BE.
I ALSO I'D LIKE TO THANK --
SENATORS STEVE TONE AND HILL FOR
ALL THEIR WORK AND SUPPORTING US --
NOT ONLY CRAFT THIS LANGUAGE
CRAFT THIS BILL BUT ALL THE
SUPPORT OF THEIR STAFF AND AND
THEIR EXPERTISE IN ON THESE
MATTERS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE A WONDERFUL BILL.
AND OF COURSE I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU AND YOUR WONDERFUL STAFF.
FOR WORKING ME FOR WORKING WITH
ME ON THIS BILL.
THE THE AT THE END OF THE DAY --
WE HAVE TO GET THE LANGUAGE RIDE
BUT AND HOUSE TO ACHIEVE WHAT
WE'RE HOPING TO ACHIEVE AND AT
THE END OF THE DAY WE WANT TO
SERVE THE PEOPLE OF OUR STATE --
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN -- AN
ENORMOUS PIONEER A NUMBER OF
ADVANCEMENTS UNFORTUNATELY IN
THIS DEEPLY OPENS MINDED STATE
AN ENTREPRENEURIAL STATE MANY
CALIFORNIANS.
ARE STILL EXPERIENCE
EXPERIENCING SHORTCOMINGS IN AND
HELP.
OUR MEDICAL SYSTEM AND OBTAINING --
ACCESS TO VERY IMPORTANT
TREATMENTS I RUN NUMEROUS BILLS
ON THAT OVER THE YEARS TO REALLY --
EXPANDABILITY TREAT PATIENTS IN
CALIFORNIA AND I REALLY BELIEVE
THAT WE CAN DO MORE. TO TO TREAT
AND TO CARE FOR THE PEOPLE OF
OUR STATE.
IN THIS CASE TERMINALLY ILL
PATIENTS AND DEEP SUFFERING WHO
ARE RECEIVING CARE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES.
SOLUTIONS THE KERRY THE
POTENTIAL TO OFFER THEM RELIEF
IN THIS CASE -- IN IN IN RYAN'S
CASE BATTLING CANCER THE ONLY
CHOICE HE HAD WORK OR WOULD BE --
AIDS AND AND DOPING DRUGS THAT
MADE HIM ON CONSCIENCE AND MADE
HIM AND THAT.
AND THAT -- BUT KEPT THE MOSTLY
ASLEEP.
IN YOUR FINAL DAYS YOU WANT TO
BE LUCID YOU WANT TO BE
CONSCIENCE YOU WANT.
TO BE BE COMMUNICATIVE YOU WANT
TO BE ABLE -- TO INTERACT WITH
YOUR FAMILY AND ENJOY THOSE
THINGS THAT YOU.
FEEL YOU STILL HAVEN'T ENJOYED
ANYTHING THAT WE CAN GIVE IN
TERMS OF IMPROVING THE QUALITY
OF LIFE OF TERMINALLY ILL
PATIENTS.
WE SHOULD BEND OVER BACKWARDS TO
GIVE TO THEM AND AND THIS BILL
WOULD MAKE MEDICAL CANNABIS
AVAILABLE TO THEM. TO HELP THEM
REDUCE NAUSEA VOMITING AND PAIN.
AND OTHER -- AND BAND ON FOR
THEM -- TO BENEFIT FROM A
GROWING BODY OF EVIDENCE THAT
SHOWS SAID -- MEDICAL MARIJUANA
IS EFFECTIVE IN TREATING UNDER
WE ARE A LOGICAL DISORDERS --
DEMENTIA EPILEPSY AND AND OTHER --
ILLNESSES THAT BODY OF ADAM
EVIDENCE IS GROWING AS A GROWS.
I THINK WE WERE GOING TO ME
INSTEAD OF ANTICIPATING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT A REDUCING I
SEE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT --
CHANGE IN THEIR POSITION ON
MARIJUANA OF TERE ALREADY ARE --
THIRTY THREE STATES THAT ARE
OFFERING MEDICAL MARIJUANA OR
IMMIGRATION POLICIES THAT
INCLUDE MARIJUANA AS A TREATMENT
TO PEOPLE WITH.
MEDICAL ISSUES I THINK.
WE'RE HEADED IN THAT DIRECTION
AND I THINK IT'S TIME THAT WE
MOVE.
EXPEDITIOUSLY TO OFFER THIS TO
PEOPLE OF OUR STATE SO -- I
THINK OF MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE UNDERSTAND THIS BILL --
I WILL KEEP I WILL TRY TO LIMIT
MY COMMENTS FOR THE PURPOSES OF
ALLOWING YOU TO GET TO A VERY
FULL AGENDA TODAY BUT I WOULD
LIKE.
A MISTER CHAIR AT YOUR
DISCRETION TO ALLOW.
A JIM BARTEL THE FIRE FATHER
RYAN BARTEL TO MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS AS FAR INCLUDING DOCTOR
DONE ALIGNMENT.
A HIGHLY REGARDED TRUSTED
MEDICAL EXPERT WHO HAS DEDICATED
HIS LIFE TO SERVING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH.
WITH ROLES ROLES SUCH AS THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION EXPERT
CONSULTANT CHIEF OF THE DIVISION
OF CHRONIC DISEASE AND INJURY
CONTROL WHAT THE CD PH.
AND HE HAS WRITTEN AND BEEN
PUBLISHED IN MANY MEDICAL A
SCHOLARLY JOURNALS WE ALSO HAVE
DOCTOR LORI BUT DARDEN WHAT THAT
SERVICE WITH.
ON THE MARINE HEALTH MARIN
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR HUESO --
THE INTER MINER WITNESSES SO WE
ALLOW SIX MINUTES TOTAL SO I
KNOW THERE'S THREE OF YOU SO --
SO JUST KEEP IN MIND THE PERSON
FOLLOWING YOU IF YOU TAKE A MORE
YOUR TO SHARE IS GOING TO GET
LESS SO -- JUST WITH THAT -- MY
WELCOME YOU AND AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR AND PLEASED -- LOOKING FORTY
PLEASE SIR TESTIMONY THANK YOU.
I WILL CHAIRMAN.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS JIM
BARTEL.
I AM THE FATHER RYAN BARTEL IN
CLOSE AND SPONSOR OF RANTS LAW.
SB -- THREE ZERO FIVE THREE
COMPASSION ACCESS TO MEDICAL
CANNABIS AND HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES ACT.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY SPEAK TO YOU TODAY
ABOUT THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION.
BEFORE I CONTINUE I WANT -- TO
TWO THINGS ONE TO POINT OUT A
LETTER WE DISTRIBUTED FROM MY
WIFE WHO JUST WASN'T UP.
TO COMING HERE TO SPEAK BUT SHE
DID HER THOUGHTS IN WRITING.
AND THEN -- TO ALSO THANK
SENATOR HUESO.
FOR UTTERING A BILL.
WHICH MEANS SO MUCH TO ME
PERSONALLY.
THANK YOU CENTER -- I WANT TO
TALK BRIEFLY ABOUT RYAN'S WE CAN
HAVE SOME UNDERSTANDING OF WHO
HE WAS AND WHY THIS LEGISLATION
IS.
SO IMPORTANT TO BE NAMED IN HIS
MEMORY -- RYAN WAS ALWAYS A VERY
ACTIVE AND COMPASSIONATE PERSON
GROWING UP IN SANTEE CALIFORNIA.
IN HIGH SCHOOL HE WAS AN
EXCELLENT STUDENT GRADUATING A
FOUR POINT ONE GPA ACTIVE IN
SCHOOL ACTIVITIES.
AND SEVERAL SPORTS INCLUDING ALL
STATE HONORS FOR CROSS COUNTRY A
JUNIOR AND SENIOR YEARS.
HE IS RECRUITED BY SEVERAL
COLLEGES AND ATTENDED THE
NURSING MEXICO AND RAN TRACK
ACROSS ME THERE FOR FOUR YEARS.
HE THEN UNLESS IN THE UNITED
STATES COAST GUARD ANSWERED HER
FOR YEARS.
HE'S VERY KATIE AND THEY HAVE A
pSON CONNOR WILL BE TEN YEARS OLD
ON APRIL.
TWENTY SIX IN KATY BOTH WORKED
IN SPECIAL EDUCATION WITH MOSTLY
AUTISTIC CHILDREN.
AND YOU KNOW TO DO THAT JOB
TAKES ONLY NALLEY SPECIAL SKILLS.
BUT ALSO PATIENTS AND GREAT
COMPASSION.
BRIAN HAD ALL THOSE THINGS.
AND LOVES HIS JOB.
JACKIE TECH TALK ME WITH.
LAST COUPLE WEEKS ABOUT HOW MUCH
SHE WAS GOING TO MISS WORKING
WITH THE KIDS.
HE'S ALSO A LOVING HUSBAND AND
FATHER WHO HAD A FASCINATION
WITH STAR WARS AND LEGOS WHICH
HE ACTIVELY SHARED WITH HIS SON
CONNOR.
THEY WOULD SPEND HOURS TOGETHER
BUILDING STAR WARS MODELS IN
COLLECTING ALL THE CHARACTERS.
RYAN CONOR ALSO LOVE GOING TO
MOVIES TOGETHER A WEEKEND IN
FACT FOR SEVERAL MONTHS AFTER
RIGHT PASSED AWAY.
CONNOR WOULD NOT GO TO MOVIES
ANYMORE WITH ANYONE.
BECAUSE IN HIS WORDS THAT WAS MY
SPECIAL THING I DID WITH DAD.
AND MARCH FIRST OF LAST YEAR.
RYAN CALLED ME AND MY WIFE TO
TELL US THAT HE HAD BEEN
DIAGNOSED WITH STAGE FOUR
PANCREATIC CANCER.
IN HAILING A FEW WEEKS TO LIVE.
I COULDN'T BELIEVE WHAT I WAS
HEARING.
MY HEART SANK INTO SWELLED.
HE TURNED FORTY TWO ON MARCH
NINTH A DAYS LATER HE DIED ON
APRIL TWENTY FIRST SEVEN WEEKS
AFTER BEING DIAGNOSED.
ENSIGN CARTER NINE YEARS OLD
FIVE DAYS LATER.
NOT A GOOD TIME FOR US.
WHAT HAPPENED BETWEEN MARCH
TWENTY MARCH FIRST APRIL TWENTY
FIRST IS WHY WE ARE HERE TODAY?
RYAN WAS GIVEN SEVERAL OPIATES
FOR PAIN RELIEF BUT THOSE WERE
ENOUGH SO THE ADDED FENTANYL.
ONE OF THE WORST DRUGS OPIOIDS
AVAILABLE.
THE RESULT WAS HE WAS ASLEEP
MOST OF THE TIME.
DURING ONE OF HIS RARE WAKING
MOMENTS HE SAID HE DIDN'T WANT
TO SPEND THE LAST FEW WEEKS
SLEEPING.
WE SUGGESTED MEDICAL CANNABIS AS
AN ALTERNATIVE WHICH AGREE.
TO HE TOLD ME HE WANTED TO BE
ABLE TO SPEND QUALITY TIME WITH
KATIE AND A SON CONNOR.
IS PERRANCE BROTHER AND SISTER.
AND MANY FRIENDS WHO ARE TEXTING
CALLING AND VISITING HIM.
WE HAD A MEDICAL CANNABIS CAMAS
CREATE CAMPUS MEDICINES WHICH
WOULD SLOW DOWN THE GROWTH OF
THE CANCER.
AND GIVE HIM MORE TIME.
AND CANNABIS MEDICINES FOR PAIN
RELIEF THAT WOULD ALLOW HIM TO
BE AWAKE AND PAIN FREE
THROUGHOUT THE DAY.
BUT WERE BUT WE WERE INFORMED BY
THE HOSPITAL THAT IT WAS THEIR
POLICY NOT TO ALLOW CANNABIS IN
THE HOSPITAL.
THE IRONY THAT POLICY IS THAT
THE AT THE PHËN N<c.cyan> AND OTHER</c>
OPIATES TO KILL SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE A YEAR IN THE U.
S..
WE'RE OKAY TO HAVE IN THE
HOSPITAL.
BUT NOT MEDICAL CANNABIS HAS
EVER KILLED ANYONE.
AFTER SHORT FORTY EIGHT HOUR
STAY AT HOME IT IS REQUEST YOU
REALLY WANT TO BE HOME.
WHICH IT JUST DIDN'T WORK OUT HI
HE WAS.
ADMITTED TO A DIFFERENT HOSPITAL
THAT ALLOWED MEDICAL CANNABIS.
THEY TOLD TO BRING IN THE
MEDICINES THAT THEY WOULD
REFRIGERATE THEM WITH HIS NAME
ON THEM.
IN ASSIST WITH ADMINISTERING THE
DOSAGE.
COMPLETE TURNAROUND FROM WHERE
HE WAS ORIGINALLY.
BECAUSE HE COULDN'T SWALLOW
ANYTHING NOT EVEN WATER.
THE CHEMISTRY THEY MEDICAL
CAMPUS SUPPOSITORY SLOW THE
GROWTH OF THE CANCER.
AND TO MEDICAL CANNABIS SPRAYS.
UNDER THE TONGUE.
THEY WERE USED TO PROVIDE PAIN
RELIEF.
HE ALSO USED A MEDICAL CANNABIS
PATCHES FOR ANXIETY RELIEF WHICH
USE EXPERIENCING YOUR THE END.
THE RESULT WAS AMAZING.
AWAKE AND ALERT DURING THE DAY
HE WAS ABLE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH KATIE AND
CONNOR.
MY WIFE AND ME.
THE BROTHER AND SISTER.
ANOTHER FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
ALL WITHOUT PAIN.
NURSING STAFF AND DOCTORS WERE
CRYING.
INSTEAD OF SLEEPING ALL THE TIME
FROM THE FENTANYL HE HAD A
QUALITY OF LIFE THAT ALLOWED HIM
TO HAVE MUCH NEEDED
CONVERSATIONS.
WITH HIS FAMILY AND TIME TO
REMINISCE AND LAUGH WITH HIS
MANY FRIENDS WHO CAME TO VISIT.
THANKS TO THE MEDICAL CANNABIS
HE VALLEY HAD A QUALITY TIME
WITH HIS LOVED ONES I THE FINAL
DAYS AND HOURS OF HIS LIFE.
VERY TERMINALLY ILL PATIENTS
SHOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY AS RYAN. TO SPEND
THE FINAL DAYS.
WITH AS MUCH QUALITY IN DIGNITY
AS POSSIBLE [inaudible]
THEY'RE DYING.
WHY WOULD WE WANT THAT FOR THEM?
OPTIONS OTHER THAN SEVERE AND
DEBILITATING OPIOIDS LIKE
MORPHINE AND FENTANYL SHOULD BE
ALLOWED.
AND HEALTH CARE FACILITY SHOULD
BE REQUIRED. TO ALLOW TO ALLOW
THEM MIDDLE CAM IS A PROVEN
EFFECTIVE ALTERNATIVE OPIOIDS.
IF SOMEONE IS TERMINALLY ILL AND
DYING IN HEALTH CARE FACILITY.
WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO PROVIDE
THEM WITH.
ADDITIONAL OPTIONS ALMOND IS TO
OPTIONS THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
THEM. TO ENHANCE AND MAXIMIZE
THE QUALITY OF LIFE.
AT THE END OF THEIR LIFE.
RYAN SAID AN EXAMPLE FORCE.
BRANCH LAW WILL ENABLE OTHER
TERMINALLY ILL PATIENTS TO
FOLLOW HIS EXAMPLE. FOR THE PAST
FEW WEEKS AND DAYS WE HAVE MADE
AS THE BILL WHICH WOULD.
BETTER DEFINE THE SCOPE OF
ELIGIBLE PATIENTS.
PALLIATIVE CARE EXEMPTS HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES CERTAIN
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES.
IF THERE ARE ADDITIONAL CONCERNS
THEY CAN BE DISCUSSED AS WE MOVE
FORWARD SO PLEASE VOTE TODAY TO
KEEP SB THREE OH FIVE ALIVE AND
MOVED FORWARD.
ON BEHALF OF MILLIONS OF
TERMINALLY ILL PATIENTS WHO
BENEFIT FROM IT [inaudible]
RYAN'S LAW.
IS HIS LEGACY.
AND IS MY THERAPY. FOR
EXPERIENCING WHEN NO PARENT
SHOULD INDOOR.
WATCHING A CHILD TAKE A LAST
BREATH.
THANK YOU -- THAT TEST MADE TO
TAKE UP ALL OF THE TIME -- SO
ASK YOU TO JUST VERY VERY
BRIEFLY -- I'D I SHOULD EXPRESS
YOUR SUPPORT.
WELL DOCTOR GERMAN I'M DOCTOR
DONALD LYMAN I'M HERE TO SPEAK
AS AN INDIVIDUAL NOT A
REPRESENTATIVE OF AND THE
OUTSIDE AGENCY -- I WAS ONE OF
THE CO PROPONENTS FOR PROP SIXTY
FOUR AND HAVE BEEN PART OF THE
EFFORT TO SET UP -- WHAT IS NOW
A NEW A NEW CONTROL --
GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE DESIGNED PROP SIXTY FOUR TO
BE A NEW INDUSTRY.
BUT YOU CAN'T DO THAT IN A
PROPOSITION.
EVEN A SIXTY FOUR PAGE
PROPOSITION WILL NOT SET UP A
NEW INDUSTRY.
WE ARE NOW BUILDING POLICY ON
TOP OF THAT STRUCTURE TO MAKE
CONTROL OF CANNABIS WORK.
THIS EFFORT TODAY IS ONE OF THE
POLICY OPTIONS THAT YOU HAVE IN
IN FLUSHING OUT THE NEW INDUSTRY.
AND THE CONTROL STRUCTURE THAT
IT REPRESENTS.
SO I AM IN FAVOR OF THIS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION I THINK IT IS AN
APPROPRIATE ADDITION TO IT.
AND I'D ASK YOU TO VOTE IN FAVOR
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AGAIN VERY BRIEFLY.
I'M DOCTOR LORI BUT DARDEN
RETIRED EMERGENCY PHYSICIAN.
I THINK THERE'S TWO AMA COHEN OF
ETHICS THAT ARE RELEVANTAND
GERMANE. TO THIS ISSUE AND TO
THIS BILL THE FIRST ONE SAYS IN
GENERAL WITH A PHYSICIAN BELIEVE
SO LAWS ON JOSH THEY SHOULD WORK
TO CHANGE IT.
IN EXCEPT IN EXCEPTIONAL
CIRCUMSTANCES OF ON JUST LAWS
ETHICAL RESPONSIBILITY SHOULD.
SUPERSEDE LEGAL OBLIGATION I
KNOW HOSPITALS ARE APPREHENSIVE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS GOING
TO WITHDRAW THEIR BUT I THINK IT
IS -- EXCEPTIONAL CIRCUMSTANCE
WHERE A PATIENT IS DYING AND
FINALLY THE PRACTICE OF MEDICINE
IS FUNDAMENTALLY A MORAL
ACTIVITY THAT ARISES FROM THE
IMPERATIVE OF POSITIONS TO CARE
FOR PATIENTS AND ALLEVIATE THEIR
SUFFERING WE NEED TO ALLEVIATE
THEIR SUFFERING.
THE PEOPLE ARE DYING BY ALLOWING
THEM TO USE MEDICAL CANNABIS
THANK YOU THANK YOU -- SINCE I
NOTE THE PRESENCE OF A QUORUM
AMASS TAKE A PAUSE AND THAT
SECRETIVE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HAND HERE AND HERE STONE.
STONE HERE THE RAZA.
DRAWS -- HERE GROWTH.
GROWTH HERE THE TACO.
LEYVA LEYVA HERE MITCHELL
MONNING RUBIO.
OKAY WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM AND THAT IS WHAT THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND
THANKS SER FOR SHARING -- STRIP
YOUR SON AT THE END -- CAN BE
VERY DIFFICULT APPRECIATE YOUR
COURAGE IN DOING THAT.
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES AFFORD A BILL --
PLEASE NAME -- ORGANIZATION AND
HOPEFULLY POSITION WOULD BE IN
FAVOR AT THISPOINT TIME AT AT
THE BACK TO BACK LIKE A FUN.
ALICIA PRIEGO ON BEHALF OF EASE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE OH
FIVE AND COMPASSIONATE ACCESS TO
CANNABIS.
THANK YOU -- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION -- ACTUALLY I'M GONNA
ASK YOU IF YOU CAN EITHER MOVE
OVER ARE YOU CAN.
POOR EXCUSE ME MAKE ROOM FOR THE
ALSO YES SUPPORT VALERIE NOBLE
WITH CALIFORNIA HEALTH COLLISION
ADVOCACY AND SUPPORT OKAY THANK
YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
OKAY.
THANK YOU I JIM WHEN BURKE ON
BEHALFOF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION TO CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I SEE NO OTHERS AND SUPPORT --
AS CAN.
IF HE CAN SORT OF MOVES TO THE
SITES WHICH NEED TO TEARS FOR
THE OPPOSITION NOW.
OKAY THERE WE GO MAYBE CAN SIT
IN THAT CORNER THERE
[inaudible]
NOW THE PROPONENTS DID USE TEN
MINUTES OVER CONSERVE THE OVER
THE LIMIT -- SO I WILL FOR DO
THAT TIME BUT ASKS THAT UNLESS
YOU REALLY NEED TO USE THAT. TO
PLEASE STOP.
NOT.
USE IT ALL BUT IT'S UP TO YOU
BUT TO BE FAIR YES THAT YOU WILL
HAVE THAT TIME IF YOU WISH TO
SELL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I CHAIR MEMBERS TEN THAT
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS AND WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. TO SB
THREE OH FIVE FOR EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IS NOT UNCOMMON FOR
PATIENTS TO COME IN THE MERCY
DEPARTMENT ALREADY ON CERTAIN
MEDICATIONS WE ARE PROCESSES IN
PLACE WITHIN THE HOSPITAL TO
MANAGE THOSE MEDICATIONS WE
ACTUALLY TAKE THEM FROM THE
PATIENT.
WHEN IT COMES TO TRYING TO
TREATING IN DIAGNOSING A MERCY
CONDITION THOSE MEDICATIONS CAN
CAUSE CHALLENGES FOR US GETTING
TO A BETTER SENDING WHAT EXACTLY
IS GOING ON WITH THE PATIENT AND
WE VIEW?
MEDICAL CANNABIS IS FALLING INTO
THE SAME CATEGORY SO WE WE ARE
OPPOSE BECAUSE WE THINK IT WOULD --
INHIBIT OUR ABILITY TO TREAT OUR
PATIENTS AND I TAKE WITH SOME
FLEXIBILITY THAT THE HOSPITALS
MAY HAVE A CURRENTLY IN TERMS OF
MANAGING THOSE MEDICATIONS AND
FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE OPPOSED
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ALICE
HAWTHORNE THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION.
AND ONLY BE REALLY CLEAR THAT
WE'RE NOT HERE TO OPPOSE THE USE
OF MEDICAL CANNABIS THE ISSUE MY
MEMBERS HAVE IS TO PUT THE THE
SAFETY OF PATIENTS EMPLOYEES
FIRST AND TO MANAGE THE RISK FOR
FOR EMPLOYEES. FOR THEIR
PATIENTS -- TO THE EXTENT THAT
THIS BILL CREATES RISKS --
BECAUSE OF FEDERAL CONFLICTS WE
HAVE THOSE CONCERNS WE HAD
REPRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR I'M WITH THE STAFF
MEMBERS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING THIS RIGHT.
AND DOING THE BEST THING FOR THE
PATIENTS SO THIS TIME WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE MUST AMENDED TO LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION.
JENNIFER SNYDER BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
FACILITIES WAS REPRESENTS ABOUT
NINE HUNDRED SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES HERE IN CALIFORNIA --
WITH THE ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
ALEX HAWTHORN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WE SUPPORT THE USE OF MEDICAL
CANNABIS FOR OUR PATIENTS WHEN
IT'S APPROPRIATE.
I'M IN WHEN IT CAN ALLEVIATE
PAIN AND SUFFERING I THINK THE
OVERALL CONCERN FOR SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES AS THEY ARE --
ALMOST A 100% GOVERNMENT FUNDED
SO MEDICAID AND MEDICARE FUNDING
IS IS AN IMPORTANT -- ASPECT OF
WHETHER OR NOT THE FACILITY
STAYS OPEN OR IT DOESN'T -- SO
WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S THE RISKS ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT CAN BE MITIGATED --
WAS VERY -- PLEASED TO HEAR THAT
THE AUTHOR'S COMMENTS ABOUT
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE MAKE
SURE THAT THAT'S PROTECTED IN
CASES WHERE IT MIGHT.
COULD POSSIBLY HAPPEN AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR ON THAT THANK YOU.
PETER CALLOUS NON BEHALF OF
LEADING AIDS CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTS NOT FOR PROFIT
SKILLED NURSING PROVIDERS
SIMILAR COMMENTS -- SIMILAR
CONCERNS AS PREVIOUSLY EXPRESSED
AND LOOK FOR THE WORKING WITH-THE AUTHOR.
OKAY THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY SEEN NO AT THE MICROPHONE
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
A CENTER STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MISTER BARTEL IT'S WAS VERY NICE
TO MEET YOU YESTERDAY I'M SORRY
MADE INTO THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
WE DID -- BUT I APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE AND CHAMPIONING THIS
ISSUE -- WITH THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM SAN DIEGO MY FRIEND SENATOR
HUESO -- APPRECIATE SAYING THEY
THE IMAGE OF YOUR SON HERE TODAY
TO AND I DID READ THE LETTER
FROM -- YOUR YOUR WIFE.
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT HERE I
TALKED ABOUT IT OVER THE PAST
FOUR YEARS IS THE FOR THE OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO GET
THEIR ACT TOGETHER.
BECAUSE THEY'RE VERY
HYPOCRITICAL YOU KNOW ON ONE ONE
SIDE OF THE EQUATION YOU GOT THE
D. E. A. THIS AS ATTACK ANY
CALIFORNIANS ARE -- OF NO BUT
THIS IS A VALUE AND THEY CAN BE
ABUSED ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
COIN YOU GOT THE FTA THIS IS AT
THAT.
CERTAIN DERIVATIVES MARINOL
INSTITUTE AN EXAMPLE NOW CBT ARE
ARE FDA APPROVED SO ON ONE SIDE
OF THE CREATION SAYS THAT
THEY'RE NOT USEFUL OR OR DUE TO
THE OTHER SIDE IT SAYS THAT THEY
THEY DO HAVE THERAPEUTIC VALUE
WE CERTAINLY KNOW THAT MERRILL'S
MENUS FOR WASTING AND AIDS
PATIENTS.
AND PATIENTS WITH -- CAM THERAPY
AND NOW CBT FOR CERTAIN THE
PEDIATRIC A SEIZURE DISORDERS.
SO -- ALSO WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT -- WE'VE IT WILL ENACTED
SOME VERY.
GOOD LEGISLATION TO HEAR I SHALL
TRY YOU KNOW FOR THINGS AND NOTEVEN FTA PROVED. TO TO GIVE
PEOPLE THAT ARE DYING SOME HOPE.
AND IN SOME CASES QUALITY OF
LIFE AND THIS IS REALLY A
QUALITY OF LIFE ISSUE -- WE KNOW
THAT PHËN N<c.cyan>WHICH IS -- A</c>
VERY POTENT OPIATE -- MY HUNDRED
TIMES STRONGER THAN MORPHINE AND
MISTER BARTEL IN IS -- LATE
SOMBER CONCERNED THAT HE BE
SLEEPING ALL THE WAY THROUGH --
HIS DEMISE IN THE HEALTH THAT.
HE WANTED TO BE AWAKENED HIS
FINAL HOURS AND WAS ABLE TO
BENEFIT FROM FROM CANNABIS TO
ALLEVIATE HIS PAIN AND TO ALLOW
HIM TO HAVE -- CONSCIOUS --
RELATIONS WITH IS IS.
WITH HIS FAMILY IN IN AND THOSE
FINAL HOURS.
AND I THINK THAT.
IT'S AN APPROPRIATE USE OF OF
CANNABIS -- IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE HAVEN'T STUDY TOO MUCH IN
THIS COUNTRY BECAUSE IT'S BEEN
YOU KNOW -- ILLEGAL FOR SO MANY
YEARS AND WOULD READ BY THINK
SENATOR HUESO MENTION THIRTY
THREE STATES NOW I EMBRACE THE
MEDICINAL MARIJUANA.
AND AND THAT'S BECAUSE OF STUDY
THAT WOULD BEEN DONE A LOT IN
ISRAEL THAT SHOW THAT THERE IS
MEDICAL EFFICACY FOR IT.
SO WE'RE TALKING HERE ABOUT
TERMINALLY ILL PATIENTS THAT.
NEED TO BE GIVEN A CHOICE -- IF
CANNABIS HELP SOME AND
ALLEVIATES ARE SUFFERING -- THEN
WE SHOULD GIVE IT -- I DO
UNDERSTAND -- THAT YOU KNOW
PHYSICIANS TO HAVE A THE A
LICENSE.
THEY NEED TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT
AND I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT --
HOSPITAL'S SURGERY CENTERS THAT
TAKE MEDICAID ALL MEDICARE --
THAT HAVE SOME FEDERAL COMPONENT.
I THINK THE CHURCH CONCERNS ARE
ARE JUST I THINK THAT.
THE SENATOR HAS MADE IT VERY
CLEAR THROUGH -- SOME AMENDMENTS
SAID IF THERE IS GOING TO BE
SOME -- RATTLING BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT THERE IS GOING
TO BE SOME AVENUES -- TO TO
BACKTRACK IF IT IS IF CERTAIN
NECESSARY BUT I DON'T FORESEE.
THAT HAPPENING I THINK THAT THE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ALBEIT --
MAYBE THE THE PRESIDENT IS NOT
THE MOST POPULAR PERSON IN THIS
BUILDING THESE DAYS BUT I WILL
SAY THIS THAT I THINK THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS A WHOLE IS
A VERY COMPASSIONATE -- GROUP
ESPECIALLY AT THE AT THE FDA --
I THINK PHYSICIANS -- ONE OF
ALLEVIATE SUFFERING AS A ONE OF
THE PHYSICIANS HAD HAD MENTIONED.
AND YOU KNOW IF IF IF CANNABIS
IS IS IS THE BETTER CATION THAT --
ALLOWS.
ONE TO BETTER -- COPE WITH THEIR
THEIR PAIN AND THEIR SUFFERING
IN THEIR FINAL HOURS AND WE
SHOULD BE STANDING BEHIND THEM
AND LEVY THAT SUFFERING SO --
GOT THE APPROPRIATE TIME I WOULD
LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL AND AGAIN
I WANT TO THANK OF MISTER BARTEL
FOR FOR MAKING THIS IS PASSION --
SIR NOBODY SHOULD -- INDOOR THE
NIGHTMARE THAT YOU HAD TO INDOOR
WAS SUCH SHORT NOTICE YOUR SON.
COMING DOWN AFTER GOING TO
EMERGENCY ROOM WITH THEM.
WHAT OF WHAT HE THOUGHT WAS A
SIMPLE ELEMENT INTRODUCTORY SUCH
A SERIOUS ELEMENT -- THE LEAST
WE CAN DO IS TRY TO EASE HIS
SUFFERING AND THROUGH YOUR WORK
AND YOUR BEING HERE TODAY YOU'RE
GONNA BE FURTHERING THE MEMORY
OF YOUR SON.
SO THAT OTHERS DON'T HAVE TO
SUFFER AND GOD BLESS YOU FOR
DOING THAT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
YES CENTER GROVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AGAIN I I
DID READ TO THE LETTER THAT YOUR
WIFE ROAD AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE MISTER
BARTEL IN TELLING THE STORY OF
YOUR SENSIBLE ECHO THOSE
COMMENTS THAT MY COLLEAGUE --
SENATOR STONE -- JUST COMMENTED
ON I DO SYMPATHIZE -- VERY MUCH
THAT -- THE SITUATION THAT YOU
FOUND YOURSELF IN AND THAT YOU
KNOW I FOUND MYSELF AND MY MOM
NEVER CHOOSING SHE DIDN'T USE
MEDICAL CANNABIS BUT I GET YOU
KNOW THAT.
YOU KNOW THE LAST FEW WEEKS SHE
WANTED CERTAIN THINGS AND THE
DOCTORS ARE LIKE NO AND I'M LIKE
CLICK YOU KNOW JUST GIVE HER
WHAT SHE NEEDS OR WHAT SHE WANTS.
SO -- I GET IT AND I DO
SYMPATHIZE VERY MUCH BUT I AM
VERY EMPATHETIC WITH THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY AND BECAUSE
AS A BUSINESS CENTER WE DO FIND
YOURSELF IN CONFLICT WITH
CALIFORNIA LAW AND FEDERAL LAW --
CONSTANTLY REDEFINE TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS -- FOR BEING CALIFORNIA
LAW BUT OPPOSING FEDERAL LAW OR
YOU'RE FINED TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS FIRST YOU KNOW
SUPPORTING CALIFORNIA LINE
OPPOSING FEDERAL LAW OR VICE
VERSA.
SO -- I A I A I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO ASK DOCTOR IF HE IS GOING TO
ON I KNOW YOU SAID THAT YOU WERE
WORKING ON AMENDMENTS IS THEM
CAN YOU TELL ME THAT YOU ARE
GOING TO ACCEPT THE MINUTES TO
PROTECT.
LIKE THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES THAT DO YOU HAVE.
YOU KNOW ALMOST A 100% OF THEIR
FUNDING COMES FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND IF THEY COME IN.
AND THEY SHOULD HIM DOWN BECAUSE
THEY'RE A LOT THEY'RE COMPLYING
WITH CALIFORNIA ON YOUR BILL
THERE'S SOME TYPE OF REMEDY THAT
WOULD BE ABLE TO BE.
UP AT FOUR THING CAN I HAVE YOUR
WORD ON THAT BECAUSE I REALLY DO
WANT TO SUPPORT THE BILL.
BUT I CAN'T DO IT NOT KNOWING
THAT AND IT PUTS THEM IN
JEOPARDY OF LOSING THEIR ENTIRE
FACILITY AND NOT ONLY THAT BUT
THE SERVICES IN THE THE SERVICES
THAT THEY PROVIDE TO SKILLED
NURSING.
WHERE A LOT OF OUR ELDERLY ARE
AT AND -- WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE TAKING CARE OF AS WELL
ABSOLUTELY AND THAT'S BEEN OUR
INTENT FROM THE BEGINNING AND
LIKE I SAID THE LIVE THE THE THE
DETAILS OF THE LAWS ALWAYS.
THE LANGUAGE I MEAN IT'S ALWAYS
VERY -- TECHNICAL SO WE'LL WANT
ONE MAKE SURE THAT THAT THE
LANGUAGE CONFORMS TO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH AND THAT'S
THAT AND OF COURSE SO WHY WOULD
WE ENACT A BILL THAT IS COUNTRY --
THAT WILL ONLY PUT PEOPLE IN OUR
STATE IN JEOPARDY.
BUT I DO WANT TO MAKE YOUR A FOR
A YET ANOTHER YEAR -- IN EVERY
YEAR THE THE LEGISLATURE -- IN
IN THE FEDERAL [inaudible]
GOVERNMENT.
UNDER THE A BOMB IN AN
ADMINISTRATION UNDER UNDER TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION THEY'VE COME OUT
AND THEY BASICALLY SAID WE'RE
NOT ENFORCING ANY RULES --
REGARDING -- MEDICAL MARIJUANA
REMEMBER WATCHING THE STATE'S
LAWS ON ON MARIJUANA USE.
AND WE HAVE A COPY OF THIS
YEAR'S AGAIN THAT SPECIFICALLY
LISTS CALIFORNIA.
AS ONE OF THE STATES IN WHICH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SHALL NOT
APPLY A SINGLE PENNY.
OF FEDERAL FUNDS TO THE
ENFORCEMENT OF LAWS.
THAT -- PREVENT -- THE STATE'S
FROM IMPLEMENTING THEIR OWN
STATE LAWS ARE AUTHORIZED TO USE
DISTRIBUTION POSITION POSSESSION.
OR CULTIVATION OF MEDICAL
MARIJUANA SO WE HAVE KIND OF
IT'S LIKE A A PROMISE FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THE STATE'S YOU DO WHICH ONES
BUT SHOULD SHOULD THAT CHANGE.
IT IT IT EXPOSES ALL OUR LAWS.
AND AND EVERY SINGLE ONE OF OUR
LAWS WOULD PRETTY MUCH BE BE PUT
IN JEOPARDY AND JUST LIKE.
THE WAY WE HAVE LEGISLATED ON
THOSE LAWS -- WE WILL WE WILL DO
THE SAME FOR THIS BILL NOTHING
DIFFERENT NOTHING UNIQUE -- SAME
WAY.
BUT IT IT IT JUST IN MY OPINION
AND WHATEVER MY OPINIONS WORTH
IN THE OPINION OF MANY OTHER
PEOPLE IN IN THIS INDUSTRY RIGHT
PROBABLY SHARE WE SHARE MY
OPINION.
THAT THERE IS A TREND TO TOWARD
THE OPPOSITE MORE -- EVIDENCES
SHOW WE NEED THAT MARIJUANA HAS
BENEFICIAL USES AND AND DOESN'T
THAN IT DOES NOT HAVE
DETRIMENTAL USES.
AND AND MORE STATES ARE ADOPTING
LAWS I MEAN CALIFORNIA WAS FIRST
THE FIRST TWENTY YEARS AGO NOW
WE HAVE THIRTY THREE STATES.
NOW WE HAVE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SAYING WE'RE NOT
GOING TO FORCE LAWS.
AND TO THAT AFFECT I THINK WE'RE
HEADED IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
BUT SHOULD ANYTHING CHANGE OF MY
WORDS OF THE THE PRINT WILL BE
THERE.
AND AND I WILL I WOULD NOT SEND
A BILL TO THE GOVERNOR THAT IS
NOT ON SOLID FOOTING.
I DON'T AND I DON'T DOUBT THAT I
DON'T DOUBT THAT -- THAT THE
LETTER THAT YOU HAVE IS VALID I
DON'T DOUBT THAT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION IN PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION HAS SAID THAT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO ENFORCE IT.
IT DOESN'T MEAN THE
ADMINISTRATION CHANGES EVERY
FOUR YEARS OR EVERY YEARS.
AND SO AGAIN -- JUST THE
QUESTION I I THINK IT'S VERY
BENEFICIAL I THINK THAT -- THESE
CANNABIS ESPECIALLY IN THIS
PARTICULAR SITUATION ARE ONLY
REALLY IN THIS PARTICULAR
SITUATION -- I THINK IS VERY
BENEFICIAL TO THE PATIENT AND SO
LIKE I SAID I AM VERY
SYMPATHETIC AND I DO WANT TO
SUPPORT THE BILL BUT I NEED TO
MAKE SURE.
AND HAVE YOUR WORD THAT THAT
LANGUAGE WILL BE INSERTED TO BE
ABLE TO PROTECT THESE FACILITIES
THAT GET FEDERAL FUNDING SO IF
SOMETHING DOES CHANGE.
WE DON'T HAVE A THREE HUNDRED
BED FACILITY OF SKILLED NURSING
INDIVIDUALS THAT NEED END OF
LIFE CARE.
AT THAT ARE ON THE STREETS OR
WHATEVER I MEAN I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
LAW THAT CONTRADICTS OF FEDERAL
LAW THAT'S ALL I WANT TO DO YOU
AND I BOTH WANT TO MAKE SURE.
GREAT THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU
AND MAY BE OUT TO SISTER AGAIN I
CENTER HUESO PERSONAL THANK YOU
FOR TAKING THE AMENDMENTS AND
ALSO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT. TO THIS ISSUE I
THINK JUST.
IN TERMS OF SIR GROW FIVE AND
JUST WEST EIGHT PUBLICLY WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT IS ESSENTIALLY
LANGUAGE IT SAYS.
IF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT --
PASSES ARE ARE EXPRESS -- PASSES
BUT TOPS -- EXPLICIT REGULATION
THAT FOR BIDS THIS ORDER TAKES
ENFORCEMENT ACTION AGAINST
CALIFORNIA FACILITY.
THE AND WHICH CASE -- IN THOSE
EITHER ONE OF THOSE SITUATIONS
VAN -- THE THIS THIS BILL OF
THAT IT BECOMES A LAW WITH THE
BUT NOT THEN BE -- SOMETHING
THAT COULD TAKE PLACE RIGHT AND
AND I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT THAT
TECHNICALLY THIS.
LAW WOULD NOT TRULY BE
ENFORCEABLE WE WOULDN'T DO THE
STATE'S WE COULDN'T REALLY DO A
STATE SANCTIONED ANYWAY GIVEN
THE CURRENT CIRCUMSTANCES -- BUT
I APPRECIATE THAT YOU HAD THAT
MADE THE COMMITMENT. TO TO TO
WORK ON ON THAT PARTICULAR
LANGUAGE CORRECT.
DATA SO HOPEFULLY THAT --
ADDRESSES -- AND I AM NOW A
MAYBE ALSO SAY AND APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMITMENT THAT CERTAINLY
IS THE CHAIR.
OF GIVEN YOUR COMMITMENT THAT
WAS CERTAINLY ONE OF MY CONCERNS
THAT IF IT'S NOT THERE WE MAY
PULL IT BACK TO THIS COMMITTEE
AS WELL.
AND BUT I I I KNOW YOUR MANAGER
WORD I DON'T EXPECT THERE'S AND
YEAH I DON'T EXPECT THAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN SO MAYBE IF THAT GIVES
SOME COMFORT TO CENTER GROVE
YOU'VE GOT -- AND IN TERMS OF
THAT ISSUE SO BY INTO BITE KNOW
YOUR MANUAL WORD AND THAT
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
THAT.
AND OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
OKAY AND THEN JUST ONE OTHER TO
THAT POINT YEAH I'D APPRECIATE
THAT I HAVEN'T HEARD FROM BIRDS
FROM PHYSICIANS -- I THINK --
HOPEFULLY THERE SOME
CONVERSATIONS YOU ALSO HAVE WITH
THEM ABOUT THESE PRIME MORE
ROUND -- BEING SURE THAT THE
PHYSICIANS THAT SOMEONE'S USING
SOMETHING IN A FACILITY
DECISIONS NEED TO KNOW THAT IT'S
THERE BUT THEY'RE USING AND AND
AND HAVE SOME SORT OF SAY IN
TERMS OF HOW IT INTERACTS WITH
THEIR OTHER TREATMENT RATE WE'RE
NOT LOOKING TO BAND CANNABIS.
IN THE FACILITY WERE LOOKING TO
BE SURE THAT IT'S NOT
INTERFERING OR THAT THE
CERTAINLY THE POSITION NO SO
THAT WHEN THEY'RE CRAFTING THEIR
TREATMENTS THAT THERE ISN'T SOME.
INTERFERENCE OUR OUR SITE A
FACTOR -- ADVERSE EVENT
ATTRACTED ME HAPPEN AS A RESULT
OF THAT A KNOWINGLY SELL YES
OKAY SAW FIGURE YOU CAN WORK
THAT OUT OKAY.
WITH THAT.
THERE'S NO OTHER COMMENTS --
THEM THIS BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SIR STONE'S THERE HUESO WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THE SIMPLY
THANK YOU.
FOR THIS THIS DISCUSSIONS -- AND
THIS -- ABILITY TO WORK WITH ME
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED SPEND
SECOND ADVICE -- CENTER STONE
SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AN HI HI STONE.
STONE AYE DORADO DRAWS -- I GROW.
GROVE I HER TADO.
LEYVA LEYVA AYE MITCHELL MONNING
RUBIO.
THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTES THAT'S
ENOUGH TO GET IT OUT TO HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THINKS MIGHT CENTER HUESO.
SENATOR HILL I SEE THERE OKAY SO
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SB THREE TWENTY FIVE
BY CENTER HELLO WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND GOOD
AFTERNOON AND COLLEAGUES.
I LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS
IN COMMENTS NINE AND TEN AND WE
WILL BE PASSING AROUND A MOCK OF
THAT OF THOSE AMENDMENTS IN THE
BILL.
IN IT AND THE MEMBERS ENSURE
THAT ALL LICENSE PROGRAMS MEET
THE SAME HIGH QUALITY STANDARDS.
I ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT THIS BILL
WAS PROPOSED FOR CONSENT AND
THEN WE RECEIVE SOME LATE
OPPOSITION -- I'M HAPPY TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION AND
HOPEFULLY WE WILL BE ABLE TO
COME TO SOME SOME CONSENSUS ON
THE BILL AND I THINK WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO DO THAT -- SUBSTANCE
ABUSE COSTS OUR NATION OVER FIVE
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
BUT EFFECTIVE EVIDENCE BASED
TREATMENT HELPED REDUCE THESE
COSTS TREATMENT IS ALSO LESS IS
LESS EXPENSIVE THAN COMMON
ALTERNATIVE OUTCOME SUCH AS
INCARCERATING ADDICTED PERSONS.
CURRENTLY RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
PROGRAMS ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE A
LICENSE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
LAST YEAR I AUTHORED SB EIGHT
TWENTY THREE WHICH FURTHER
REQUIRED RESIDENTIAL PROGRAMS TO
UTILIZE EVIDENCE BASED TREATMENT
STANDARDS.
OUTPATIENT PROGRAMS HOWEVER DO
NOT CURRENTLY REQUIRE ANY
LICENSING ORDER THEY NEED TO
PROVIDE EVIDENCE BASED TREATMENT.
THE H. C. S. OFFERS ASSERTIVE
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM BUT IS
ENTIRELY VOLUNTARY.
TODAY IF YOU WANTED OPEN YOUR
OWN OUTPATIENT TREATMENT
FACILITY YOU COULD DO SO
IMMEDIATELY NO LICENSE TRAINING
OR PRIOR EXPERIENCE REQUIRED.
SB THREE TWENTY FIVE REQUIRES
OUTPATIENT TREATMENT PROGRAMS TO
BE LICENSED WITH DH CS IT ALSO
REQUIRES RELATIONS PROVIDERS TO
KEEP RECORDS OF ADMISSIONS
WITHDRAWALS TRANSFERS AND
DISCHARGES.
AND THE REASON FOR EACH
ADDITIONALLY THIS MEASURE WOULD
PROHIBIT LICENSED PROVIDERS FROM
ENGAGING IN PATIENTS SELLING AND
RECRUITING FOR MONETARY GAIN.
THOSE SEEKING TREATMENT NEED TO
KNOW THAT ANY PROVIDER THEY
SELECT MEETS AN EVIDENCE BASED
TREATMENT STANDARD.
IN THAT THOSE STANDARDS ARE
BEING ENFORCED BY THE STATE.
I HAVE WITNESSED MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER HELL WITNESSES
REPORT.
SHATTERPROOF FOR NATIONWIDE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION DEDICATED --
TO DRUG ABUSE -- AND REDUCING IT --
WE'RE THIS ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL AND WE
WERE A CO SPONSOR THE
LEGISLATION FROM LAST YEAR.
WE THINK ONE OF THE BEST WAYS --
TO ONE OF THE BEST WAYS WE CAN
ADDRESS THE ADDICTION A PROBLEM
RIGHT NOW IS A BY IMPLEMENTING
EVIDENCE BASED TREATMENT.
THIS BILL BUILDS ON LAST YEAR'S
BILL -- TO DO THAT -- IT ALSO
ALLOWS US -- TO GATHER SOME
INFORMATION THAT CURRENTLY.
FRANKLY RIGHT NOW JUST IS NOT
AVAILABLE -- IT IS -- QUITE
SURPRISING TO MOST OF THE FOLKS
WE SPEAK TO NATIONALLY
SHATTERPROOF HIS BASE BACK IN
CONNECTICUT I KNOW THEY WERE
SHOCKED WHEN THEY FOUND OUT THAT
IT PATIENT TREATMENT -- PROGRAMS
WERE NOT LICENSED OR REGULATED
IN THIS STATE -- I THINK THIS IS
A CUP OF FANTASTIC MOVE IT IS
BENEFICIAL NOT ONLY TO THE THOSE
WHO STRUGGLE WITH ADDICTION BUT
ALSO TO THEIR TO THEIR FAMILIES
AS WELL AS THOSE WHO ARE PAYING
FOR IT WHETHER IT'S PRIVATE PAY --
PUBLIC PAY OR OR INSURANCE
COMPANIES -- AND I TO ONE OF THE
WORDS IN THE MOUTHS OF THE FOLKS
THAT THE PRODUCT THE OPPOSITION
I BELIEVE THEY'RE HERE TO SAY
THAT BUT I KNOW THAT WE DID MEET
WITH THEM.
I HAD A TIME WE CAME -- TO
RESOLUTION ON THAT I THINK
THEY'LL BE HERE TO SAY THAT AND
I DO WANT.
TO MENTION -- IT'S MINOR SAYING
THAT WE'RE NOT OPPOSED TO THE
BILL THEY WERE JUST HAD SOME
CONCERNS WITH.
A SECTION OF THE OF THE LANGUAGE --
WE'VE COME TO RESOLUTION WITH
THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS ROBERT HARRIS ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ADDICTION MEDICINE CALIFORNIA'S
PAGE POSITION SPECIAL ASCENDED
TREATMENT OF ADDICTION WE'RE CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL WERE HAPPY
TO BE A CO SPONSOR WE'RE EXCITED.
TO CENTER HILL AGREED TO BRING
THE BILL FORWARD -- FOR FOR
YEARS EVERYBODY IS SAID WE
SHOULD HAVE LICENSING AND
OVERSIGHT OF OF THIS MEDICAL
SERVICE THAT'S PROVIDED TO
PEOPLE.
THE THE EVEN THE SOCIAL MODEL
PART OF IT IF THERE IS EVIDENCE
THAT WORKS.
IT SHOULD BE DONE BUT THERE
SHOULD BE STANDARDS.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT THIS BILLS
THANKS TO DO IT GIVES THE STATE
CONTROL OVER THOSE PROGRAM SO
SAVE MONEY ISN'T WASTED.
AND IT ALSO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE PRIVATE
INSURANCE ACTUALLY GET THE
INSURANCE COMPANIES GET WHAT
THEY'RE PAYING.
FOR SO IT'S A SIMPLE BILL IT'S
NOT QUITE FULLY.
DONE BECAUSE WE'RE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH OTHER PEOPLE
BUT MOVING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
AND CREATING THE STANDARDS AND
HAVING THE STATE AND FOR SOME
THE REALLY AN IMPORTANT THING
FOR CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL NAME
WORKSTATION POSITION VERY DALY
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CONNIE DEL
GOT ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE A SUPPORT
AND CONCEPT WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS FOR
WORKING WITH US WILL CONTINUE TO
DO SO.
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK WINDOWS
WITH THAT CA YOU CALIFORNIA WE
ALSO ARE SUPPORTING CONCEPT AND
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS WILLINGNESS TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH US THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES SUPPORT.
BUT WELL I'M IMPORTANT SUPPORT
BUT OKAY WELL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ACTUALLY GONNA COME
UP TO THE TABLE.
OUR RESOLVE THE OPPOSITION.
THAT'S ON HEARING THAT PLEASE
COME OF THE TABLE SHARE YOUR
CONCERNS.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS HAULING
MISSION ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES WE ARE STATEWIDE
ASSOCIATION OF COMMUNITY BASED
NONPROFIT.
OF FREESTANDING SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT PROGRAMS --
FIRST FLOOD LIKE TO THANK YOU
BOTH YOU AND YOUR STAFF AS WELL
AS SENATOR HILL AND HIS OFFICE
IN THE CO SPONSORS FOR WORKING
WITH US ON OUR CONCERNS -- WE
SPECIFICALLY HAD CONCERNED ABOUT
SECTION ONE ONE EIGHT THREE OH
POINT FIVE WHICH DEALT WITH --
KEEPING THE STANDARDS UP FOR
BOTH THE AS A TREATMENT PROGRAMS
AND THE STAFFING FOR THE
TREATMENT PROGRAMS WE'VE BEEN.
WORKING WITH BOTH AUTHORS OFFICE
AND THE THE SPONSORS AND I THINK
WE'VE COME TO RESOLUTION AND WE
WILL CONTINUE WORKING WITH --
WITH -- THE AUTHORS OFFICE AS A
BILL MOVES THROUGH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ASPECT MICHAEL ANGELA
WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA BLACKOUT THE
WORK NOT IN OPPOSITION BUT
WORKING WITH THE OFFICE OFFICE
IN THE SPONSORS JUST AROUND
ISSUES ROUND EQUITY IN THOSE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION I WOULD
LIKE TO PARTICIPATE.
BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENS THE
LICENSING AND WHATEVER SO AGAIN
OUR BORDERS AND TAKING A
POSITION BUT WE'RE GONNA WORK
WITH YOU ALL TO GET SOMETHING
ELSE GOOD LANGUAGE ON EQUITY.
OKAY THANK YOU EQUITY IS A GOOD
THING ALL RIGHT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN FAVOR IN BETWEEN
OKAY SAYING I WANT TO MAKE PHONE
QUESTIONS FOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY THERE'S A MOTION ON THE
BILL US CENTER HILL WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE YEAH SURE I WILL
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU OKAY THANKS
VERY MUCH.
THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING WITH
EVERYONE ON THE BILL THE MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER STONE SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
AND I AND I STONE STONE AYE
DORADO.
DRAWS -- I'D GROWTH GROVE I HER
TADO LEYVA LEYVA AYE MITCHELL
MONNING RUBIO.
THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTES THAT'S
ENOUGH TO GET APPLE HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
VERY MUCH REMARKS THANK YOU FOR
CALLING.
I THOUGHT I SAW CENTER
PORTANTINO HERE I SOME COME IN
THERE YOU ARE OKAY.
OKAY SO WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SB.
445% PORTANTINO WELCOME.
I LIKE THE CHAIR IN THE CORNER
BETTER SO I WAS IN THE CORNER
AREA.
THANK YOU ARE MISTER CHAIR YES --
AND COLLEAGUES TODAY I'M
PRESENTING SP FOUR FOUR FIVE
WHICH ESTABLISHES THE CHILDREN
ADOLESCENT AND YOUNG ADULTS
SUBSTANCE USE.
DISORDER ACT I'D LIKE TO BEGIN
BY ACCEPTING THE TECHNICAL
AMENDMENT PRESENTED BY THE
COMMITTEE AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR CONTINUED
WORK -- WITH MY STAFF AS WELL AS
BEFORE FOUR FIVE REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. TO CONVENE AN EXPERT
PANEL TO DEVISE -- ON THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A YOU SUBSTANCE.
TREATMENT STANDARD.
THE BILL ALSO DEFINES YOUTH
SUBSTANCE -- TREATMENT DISORDER --
SERVICES TO INCLUDE ANY PUBLICLY
FUNDED DIRECT SERVICE INTENDED
TO ADDRESS OR TREAT S. U. D. IS
FOR INDIVIDUALS.
FROM BIRTH TO TWENTY SIX YEARS
OF AGE COLLEAGUES CALIFORNIA HAS
MADE NMEROUS ATTEMPTS TO
ADDRESS THE COMPLEX NOT OF
ISSUES RELATED TO MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
AND YET OUR SYSTEMS AND PROGRAMS
DON'T SEEM TO CARRY OUT OUR
INTENTIONS.
WE SEE THE RESULTS AROUND US ON
THE STREETS IN OUR SCHOOLS AND
IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTM.
MULTIPLE STUDIES HAVE
ESTABLISHED THAT ADOLESCENTS ARE
MORE VULNERABLE THAN ADULTS TO
ALCOHOL CANNABIS.
TOBACCO AND OTHER DRUG RELATED
PROBLEMS I SOMEONE SAID THAT
SAID A TEENAGER COULD END UP
WITH -- ALCOHOL PROBLEM IN THREE
TO SIX MONTHS -- AND OFF OFTEN
TOO MANY DO SERVICES FOR YOUTH
NEED TO BE INTEGRATED HEN
WRAPAROUND SERVICES ARE
NECESSARY TO SERVE THE YOUTH
MOST IN NEED.
WHEREVER THEY ARE IN A COMMUNITY
WHETHER IT'S ON THE STREET IN A
HOMELESS SHELTER IN FOSTER CARE
GROUP HOMES ARE IN SCHOOLS.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES THROUGH THE DEVELOPMENT
OF A YOUTH TREATMENT STANDARD
FOR CHILDREN ADOLESCENTS AND
YOUNG ADULTS BY SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESSING THEIR NEEDS.
AS DIFFERENT AND DISTINCT FROM
ADULT TREATMENTS BY DEVELOPING A
NEW METHODOLOGY FOR CARING FOR
OUR YOUNG POPULATION AND I HAVE --
SEIU HERE TO SPEAK ON THE BILL'S
BEHALF AS WELL.
OKAY THANK YOU CENTER PARTY NO
THAT WOULDN'T SUPPORT.
OVER HERE IS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S SOCIETY OF
ADDICTION MEDICINE ONE OF THE
MULTITUDE AS CO SPONSORS OF THIS
LEGISLATION.
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE THAT THERE
ARE NO STANDARDS AND THOUGH.
STANDARDS FOR TREATMENT OF YOUTH
OF OUR MOST CRITICAL CITIZENS.
AND SO THIS BILLS AN ATTEMPT TO
CREATE THOSE ARE SPEND HALF HARD
TO CAMP SO OVER THE YEARS BUT
NOTHING'S EVER GONE THROUGH --
THIS BILL PASSED BOTH HOUSES OF
THE LEGISLATURE -- EIGHTY THEN
NOTHING AND THIRTY NINE TO
NOTHING LAST YEAR.
THE GOVERNOR THAT GOVERNOR WHO
HAD LESS INTEREST IN CHILDREN
AND KIDS.
VETO THE I'M SORRY BUT HE VETOED
THE BILL.
AND WE THINK THIS GOVERNOR.
HAS MORE CONCERN AND MORE HEART
FOR KIDS AND UNDERSTANDS THE
KIDS NEED THE BEST AND NOT JUST
WHATEVER COMES ALONG SO.
THAT'S WHY WE WORK WITH CENTER
PORTANTINO. TO TO BRING THIS
BILL BACK WHAT ABOUT MY CHECK A
SET A MULTITUDE OF OTHER CO
SPONSORS AND WE CERTAINLY HOPE
HE'LL SUPPORT THANK.
I THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT BACK MICROPHONE.
MARK AGAIN ON BEHALF OF SHATTER
PROOF -- WE ALSO HEARD SUPPORT
THE BILL IN AN ECHO THE COMMENTS.
YOU KNOW ADDICTION STARTS WHEN
YOU'RE YOUNG -- AND CONTINUES ON
SO WE NEED TO ADDRESS IS
TERRIBLE IN VULNERABLE
POPULATION.
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION PARK
MENDOZA WITH US YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA CO SPONSOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
SHERRI DALY CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM ADDICTION PROGRAMS
AND PROFESSIONALS AND SUPPORT.
IF.
KLAY DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MICHELLE GIVEN SO THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KELLY BEAM ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MAURICE RICHARDSON ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSE WITH
ASSOCIATION OF SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GILBERTESE REGISTERED NURSE --
SCA YOU WANT TO ON OUR END AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RIGHT SEEN NO OTHER -- PEOPLE
THE MICROPHONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SAYING NINE QUESTION FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY THE MOST BILLS AND MOVE BY
SERRA LEYVA SEEN ALL THE
QUESTIONS -- THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH RAIN THIS BILL FORD I
GUESS I DO HAVE TO SAY I
GOVERNOR BROWN TO DO SOME THINGS
FOR KIDS.
BUT WITH THAT I WILL BUT I
APPRECIATE THAT I WILL LEAVE --
CENTER FOR YOU IT'S LIKE THE
CLOTHES.
I THINK I WAS THE CENTER WITH
THE MOST BROWN VETOES.
ON THE MAJORITY SIDE OF THE
CAUCUS.
I THINK I HAD FIVE VETOED LAST
YEAR.
THE JUNE ALL RIGHT WE WERE SHARE.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND I'M HOPEFUL THAT OUR
NEW GOVERNOR WILL SIGN THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHTS
OF THE EMOTION IS THE PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS IT'S
BEEN SECOND BY CENTER LEYVA
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN HI HI STONE.
STONE AYE DORADO DRAWS -- I GROW.
GROVE I HER TADO.
LEYVA LEYVA AYE MITCHELL MONNING
RUBIO.
RUBIO I SEE.
THAT THOSE EXPERTS THAT'S ENOUGH
TO GET IT OUT TO WE WILL HOLD
THE BILL OPEN AND THE ROLE OF
GOOD -- FOR THAT SOME MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY.
AND I STILL SEE CINEMARK SO
ACTUALLY CENTER LEYVA YOUR NEXT
UP IN THE FALL ORDER.
WELL THAT'S THE RESIDENTS ON
DOING IF THE ROUTE THIS BILL.
YES.
XEROX FOR EXAMPLE.
SHE HAS TO TAKE.
SO -- THIS IS ITEM NUMBER THREE
C. OF TWO BILLS BEFORE US SO WHY
SOME YOU TAKE THEM UP ENOUGH
I'LL ORDER NUMBER ORDERS OKAY SO
WE'RE GONG TO DO FIRST WHEN I
DO OF ITEM NUMBER THREE SB --
TWO TWO SEVEN BUT CERTAINLY VOTE
WELCOME.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS.
MEMBERS AS MANY OF YOU MAY
REMEMBER SEVERAL OF YOU SAW A
VERY SIMILAR VERSION OF THIS
BILL LAST YEAR MY SB.
TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT AFTER
PASSING BOTH HOUSES FORMER
GOVERNOR BROWN VETOED THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATING
LEGISLATION SAYING THE HOSPITALS
ARE BEST EVALUATED.
IN A COMPREHENSIVE MANNER
NEEDLESS TO SAY I RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE.
NURSE TO PATIENT RATIOS ARE SO
IMPORTANT FOR THE COUNTLESS
PATIENTS WHO SEE KAREN HOSPITALS
THE NURSES WHO WORK HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
SB TWO TWO SEVEN EMPOWERS THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH CV PH TO ENSURE PUBLIC
SEES ME TO ENSURE PATIENT SAFETY
BY ENFORCING NURSE TO PATIENT
RATIOS.
AND FINING HOSPITALS THAT
REPEATEDLY BREAK THESE STANDARDS.
DESPITE MANDATED AND
LONGSTANDING NURSE PATIENT
RATIOS SOME HOSPITALS CONTINUE
TO VIOLATE THESE VITAL
REQUIREMENTS.
FROM 200-082-2000 SEVENTEEN
THERE WERE A TOTAL OF SIX
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR
ALLEGATIONS REPORTED TO CD PH IN
REGARDS TO OUT OF RATIO
DEFICIENCIES.
UNFORTUNATELY THE DEPARTMENT'S
CURRENT ENFORCEMENT MEASURES ARE
SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH.
CURRENTLY THE DEPARTMENT
CONDUCTS SURVEYS EVERY THREE
YEARS TO ENSURE THE HOSPITALS
ARE COMPLYING WITH THE LAW.
HOWEVER THIS PERIODIC CHECK IS
FAR TOO INFREQUENT ALLOWS
HOSPITALS TO PREPARE BEFORE CITY
PH CAM FOR CAN DUCKS THEIR
SURVEY.
SB TWO TWO SEVEN WOULD ADDRESS
THIS PROBLEM BY REQUIRING THE
DEPARTMENT'S CONDUCT UNANNOUNCED
VISITS TO HOSPITALS TO INSPECT
FOR COMPLIANCE WITH NURSE
STAFFING REQUIREMENTS.
THIS MEASURE WOULD ALSO EMPOWER
THE DEPARTMENT TO ENFORCE THE
STAFFING REQUIREMENTS WITH FINES
WERE STAFFING RATIOS HAVE BEEN
BY LA.
SB TWO TWO SEVEN IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT SO THAT WE CAN PROTECT
PATIENT HEALTH AND SAFETY IN
CALIFORNIA HERE IN SUPPORT TODAY
IS GAIL BATISTE PRESIDENT OF
SEIU LOCAL ONE TWO ONE ARE AND
MARK WINDOWS -- WITH SCA YOU AND
SO IN YOUR ROBERTSON WITH YOU
NECK.
OKAY THANK YOU WITNESSES SUPPORT
SIX MINUTES TOTAL OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU -- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
GILBERTESE.
I'M THE PRESIDENT OF SCE I YOU
WANT TO ONE ARE AND THE UNION
THAT REPRESENTS REGISTERED
NURSES THROUGHOUT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
I AM ALSO AN OPERATING ROOM
NURSE AT DIGNITY NORTHRIDGE
HOSPITAL MEDICAL CENTER AND I
BECAME A NURSE THIRTY SIX YEARS
AGO BECAUSE I WANTED -- TO CARE
FOR THE SICK AND THE RUNNABLE.
I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK THREE AYE
VOTE ON SB.
TWO TWO SEVEN CALIFORNIA IS THE
ONLY STATE IN THE NATION WITH
NURSE TO PATIENT RATIOS.
THESE RATIOS ARE INTENDED TO
KEEP OUR PATIENTS SAFE AND
PRODUCE THE MOST OPTIMAL HEALTH
OUTCOMES FOR PATIENTS.
HOWEVER THE ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM FOR TITLE TWENTY TWO
REGULATIONS NEED TO BE FIXED AND
STRENGTHENS.
CURRENTLY THE PENALTIES FOR
VIOLATING THE LAW ARE NEARLY
NONEXISTENT.
IN FACT MOST OF THE TIME WHEN
THE HOSPITAL'S FOUND TO BE IN
VIOLATION OF THE NURSE TO
PATIENT RATIOS CITY PH GIVES
THEM CITATIONS KNOWN AS PLANS OF
CORRECTION.
SURPRISINGLY THERE IS NO LIMIT
ON HOW MANY PLANS OF CORRECTION
A HOSPITAL CAN GET AND MOST IF
NOT ALL HOSPITALS ARE NEVER FIND.
THIS IS WHY HOSPITALS ARE
WILLING TO CONTINUOUSLY BREAK
THE LAW AND PUT PATIENT SAFETY
AT RISK.
AS A NURSE I CAN TELL YOU THAT
VALUE TO COMPLY WITH NURSE
STAFFING RATIOS BUT PATIENTS AT
REST.
THE NURSES HERE TODAY THAT WILL
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
WILL ALSO TESTER IMPORTANCE OF
NURSE STAFFING RATIOS AND HOW
THEY PROTECT THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF PATIENTS. FOR EXAMPLE
IS MENTIONED IN OUR EARLIER
PRESS CONFERENCE KATHY A
RIVERSIDE ARE AND DISCUSSED HOW
A PATIENT DEVELOPS THEORY
SECONDARY ILLNESSES.
AS A DIRECT RESULT OF
DANGEROUSLY.
LOW STAFFING LEVELS.
IMAGINE IF THAT PATIENT WAS YOUR
MOTHER YOUR FATHER.
WIFE HUSBAND SHALL OR YOURSELF.
THAT IS WHY WE ARE HERE TODAY.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO PROTECT OUR
PATIENTS BETTER AND ENSURE THAT
THEY RECEIVE THE HIGHEST QUALITY
OF CARE.
SB TWO TWO SEVEN WOULD CREATE A
GREATER DISINCENTIVE BY
INSTITUTING REPEAT OFFENDER
LANGUAGE.
HOSPITALS THAT WILL FULLY AND
CONSISTENTLY VIOLATE NURSE TO
PATIENT RATIOS WILL NOW FACE
FINES DEPENDING ON HOW OFTEN
THEY VIOLATE TITLE TWENTY TWO
REGULATIONS.
WHAT GOOD IS A REGULATIONS IF
THERE'S NO ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM?
ALLOW CD PH INVESTIGATORS TO
CONDUCT UNANNOUNCED VISITS.
SO THAT THESE REPEAT OFFENDERS
WON'T BE ABLE TO SKIRT THE LAW
BEFORE THE STATE CAN INVESTIGATE
VIOLATIONS.
THIS MEASURE IS COSPONSORED BY
SEIU ONE TO ONE ARE AN S. C. R.
U. NURSE ALLIANCE A NEW MAC.
AS NURSES WE TOOK AN OLD TO
PROTECT AN ADVOCATE FOR OUR
PATIENTS SB TWO TWO SEVEN A
SOUND POLICY THAT ALIGNS WITH
OUR FULL.
ON BEHALF OF ALL THE NURSES OF
SCA YOU WANT TO ON OUR END.
AS RAW CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOU TO PASS SB TWO TWO
SEVEN TO PROTECT PATIENTS THANK
YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK MENDOZA
WITH US HERE YOU CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA'S GONE TOO LONG
WITHOUT A STRONG ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE
WITH NURSE TO PATIENT RATIOS.
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN CITY PH
IMPLEMENTED REGULATIONS ON
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES FOR A
BROAD RANGE OF I. OBLATIONS.
AMONG THEM BEING VIOLATIONS OF
NURSE STAFFING RATIOS.
WHILE THESE REGULATIONS WERE
INTENDED TO INCENTIVIZE
HOSPITALS TO COMPLY WITH THE
RATIOS THE REGULATIONS HAVE
UNFORTUNATELY HAD THE OPPOSITE
EFFECT.
NOTABLY SINCE TWENTY THIRTEEN
WHEN THE REGULATIONS WERE
IMPLEMENTED WE HAVE SEEN SOME OF
THE HIGHEST RATES OF HEART
HOSPITALS VIOLATING THE STAFFING
REQUIREMENTS.
WHEN CITY PEACH DISCOVERS A
VIOLATION OF THE NURSE STAFFING
RATIOS THEY ADMINISTER A PLAN OF
CORRECTION CITATION THAT CARRIES
NO MONETARY OR CRIMINAL
LIABILITY ATTACHED TO IT?
SB TWO TWO SEVEN NARROWLY FINDS
HOSPITALS THAT REPEATEDLY AND
WILLFULLY VIOLATE THE RATIOS.
THE MEASURE GIVE SPECIAL
CONSIDERATION TO SMALL AND RURAL
HOSPITALS AND ALLOWS YOU TO
PEACH TO IMPLEMENT THIS MEASURE
WITHOUT REGULATIONS IF PASSED
INTO LAW.
MOREOVER THE MEASURE REWARDS
HOSPITALS THAT COMPLY WITH THESE
RATIOS DESPITE HAVING VIOLATIONS
IN THE PAST.
THE CONCEPT OF NURSE STAFFING
RATIOS HAS BEEN IN PLACE FOR
OVER FOUR DECADES AND HAS
ALLOWED HOSPITALS AMPLE TIME TO
COME INTO COMPLIANCE WITH THE
NURSE STAFFING RATIOS.
WHEN THE NURSE DOES NOT HAVE
ENOUGH TIME TO TURN A PATIENT IN
WHEN A NURSE CANNOT GIVE
MEDICATION IN A TIMELY MANNER
THE PATIENT CAN DEVELOP AN
INFECTION OR SUFFER FROM
EXCRUCIATING PAIN?
AND ABOVE ALL WHEN THE NURSES
RUNNING AMONG VARIOUS DIFFERENT
ROOMS AND APARTMENTS THE NURSE
ME NOT NOTICE THE SUBTLE CHANGE
IN THE PATIENT'S CONDITION THAT
COULD LEAD TO THEIR DEATH.
I URGE AN AYE VOTE ON SB TWO TWO
SEVEN TO NOT ONLY PROTECT OUR
NURSES BUT ULTIMATELY TO ENSURE
THAT HOSPITALS ARE DOING
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO
PRIORITIZE A PATIENT'S HEALTH
AND SAFETY THANK YOU.
HI GOOD DAY AND THIS IS MY FIRST
TIME HERE I'D LIKE TO TANK.
GERMAN PAN AND THE MEMBERS OF
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE -- MAMA
HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
TWO TWO SEVEN AT ALSO LIKE TO
THANK ON SENATOR CONNIE LEIVA
WHOSE ALTERING THE BILL FOR US.
I'M HERE REPRESENTING YOU KNOCK
THE AUG THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
MEMBERS THAT WE HAVE -- WITHIN
THE UNION MY NAME IS SO YOUR
CHANCE TO FEEL JUST A CORRECTION
ON MY LAST NAME.
I'M A REGISTERED NURSE I WORK ON
MAKE SEARCH TELL THE AND I'VE
BEEN WORKING AS A REGISTERED
NURSE FOR THE LAST TWENTY YEARS.
ALL WE KNOW THAT IT'S ALMOST THE
SAME EQUIVALENT TIME FROM SINCE
THE BILL WITH PATH WHERE WE
SUPPOSED TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
TO REACH IT TO PROTECT THE
PATIENTS FOR THEIR SAFETY.
HOWEVER OVER THE LAST EIGHT TO
TEN YEARS -- THERE HAVE BEEN SO
MANY CHANGES WITHIN THE
HOSPITALS AND THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
REINFORCING THE BILL AT ALL.
DIFFERENT WE ENDED UP WITH A LOT
OF PATIENT FALLS WE ENDED UP
WITH PATIENTS DYING WE ENDED UP
WITH A PATIENT LIKE THAT ARE NOT
BEING ANSWERED I MYSELF
PERSONALLY -- ENDED UP HAVING
SOME PROBLEMS THAT WERE MADE
WORSE BECAUSE THE NURSE TOLD ME --
TALKED AT MINISTRATION SHOULD
OUT TRYING TO SEE ME AND I ENDED
UP WITH MY LEVELS DUBLIN AND
ENDED UP SIX STATES IN THE
HOSPITAL INSTEAD OF FOUR SO
THOSE ARE THE KIND OF PROBLEMS
THAT WE'RE HAVING BECAUSE OF
STOPPING ISSUES -- I WANT THE
BEST EXPERIENCE IN THE BEST
OUTCOME FOR THE PATIENT -- SB
TWO TWENTY SEVEN WILL DELIVERS
FIFTY CAN CARE BY FINISHED
FINING HOSPITALS WHO HABITUALLY
CUT CORNERS AND ENCOURAGE THEM --
TO STOP APPROPRIATELY SO ON
BEHALF OF ALL THE NURSES THE
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND MEMBERS.
WE LIKE TO GET AN EYE ON THIS
VOTE SB TWO TWENTY SEVEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANKS VERY MUCH.
OTHER WITNESSES AS A PORT NAME
ORGANIZATION IF YOU HAVE ONE AND
YOUR POSITION.
I'M SURE IT'S PAL FOR PROVIDENCE
SAINT JOSEPH'S EMERGENCY ROOM
WHEN I SUPPORT THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI KATHY MONTSENY NO REGISTERED
NURSE AT RIVERSIDE COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL AND HCA FACILITY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
MARY MILLER MARIN I ALSO WORK AT
AGE CA RIVERSIDE COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
AS WELL THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S JANELLE MAPS AND I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE I WORK AT AGE
CA RIVERSIDE COMMUNITY HOSPITAL
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME'S CAM BEING A MAN I
WORK AT DIGNITY HEALTH
NORTHRIDGE HOSPITAL FOR THIRTY
FIVE YEARS I SUPPORT THIS BILL
YOU.
HI I'M BRUCE SAYS SON I WORK AT
PACIFICA HOST BATTALION LOS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
MONIQUE HERNANDEZ I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE RIVERSIDE
COMMUNITY HOSPITAL H. CA I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JENNY MASS ALL UNIT OWNERS I
STRONGLY SUPPORT YOUR BILL
SENATOR LEYVA.
THANK YOU.
KENDRA HODGES EMMA SAN DIEGO
UNIACKE MEMBER AN EMERGENCY ROOM
NURSE AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MARIA ELENA DHEAS NEONATAL
INTENSIVE CARE UNIT REGISTERED
NURSE.
A GARFIELD MEDICAL CENTER IN
MONTEREY PARK AND ALSO AS THE
ARE YOU WANT TO ONE ARE IN
MEMBER AND I SUPPORT SB.
TWO TWO SEVEN SAMANTHA GOVERNOR
IDEA I'M A REGISTERED NURSE AT
THE WEST HILLS HOSPITAL NEEDS
THE FACILITY AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TERRY THOMPSON I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE AT LA SEE USC
MEDICAL CENTER WORK IN THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT.
I'VE BEEN A NURSE FOR TWENTY
YEARS AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
CHIKARA THOMAS I'M A REGISTERED
NURSE AT HOLLYWOOD PRESBYTERIAN
MEDICAL CENTER AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
SIR FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MATT BROAD CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS
ENGINEERS AND SCIENTISTS OF
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU YOU.
CAR FOR A REGISTERED NURSE NURSE
SEIU SEVEN TWO ONE THE SECOND
LARGEST HEALTHCARE SYSTEM THAT
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IN THE IN THE
COUNTRY AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
TING ON US AT THE MICROPHONE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ACTUALLY
WE CAN MAKE ROOM FOR THEM AT THE
TABLE.
JUST MAKING TO SERVE.
YOU CAN MOVE AROUND CIDER.
I'M SO SORRY.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS -- DEBBIE ROGERS I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION.
THERE'S NO RESPONSIBILITY
GREATER FOR A HOSPITAL THE TO
CARE FOR THE PATIENTS THAT
ARRIVE IN OUR EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT EVERY DAY THAT ARE
CARED FOR IN OUR HOSPITALS.
AS YOU ALL KNOW CON HOSPITALS
ARE COMPLICATED ENVIRONMENTS WE
WE ASKED OUR HOSPITALS -- YOU
KNOW AN AVERAGE TWO HUNDRED BED
HOSPITAL HAS ELEVEN OR SO
NURSING UNITS A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY REGISTERED NURSES -- AND
THAT'S EVERY SINGLE DAY THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS A YEAR.
SO AT ANY WITH THIS BILL THE
DIFFICULTY WITH THIS BILL REALLY
IS A COUPLE OF THINGS ONE IS AT
ALL TIMES EVERY MINUTE EVERY
SECOND OF EVERY DAY.
SO WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THOSE
HUNDRED FIFTY EMPLOYEES.
DRIVING THE FREEWAYS TO GET TO
WORK IF THERE'S A CAR ACCIDENT.
OR A SICK CHILD THAT NEEDS TO BE
DROPPED OFF AT GRANDMA'S HOUSE
INSTEAD OF SCHOOL AND THAT NURSE
IS FIVE MINUTES LATE.
THAT'S A PENALTY UNDER THIS BILL.
SO WHEN WE THINK ABOUT HOW JUST
HOW COMPLICATED -- THESE THINGS
ARE -- ADDITIONALLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH HAS
A REGULATORY STRUCTURE THAT
ALLOWS FOR HOSPITALS TO BE FIND --
UNDER A VARIETY OF CIRCUMSTANCES
AND I WANT TO COMPLIMENT --
COMMITTEE STAFF OF FOR THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND REALLY
THE EXISTING REGULATIONS ALLOW A
FINE FOR EVERYTHING FROM AN
IMMEDIATE JEOPARDY AND THE DEATH
OF THE PATIENT -- TO SOMETHING
WHERE THERE'S NO ACTUAL HARM TO
THE PIT TAKE TO THE PATIENT BUT
POTENTIAL FOR MORE THAN MINIMAL
HARM.
SO THERE'S A WIDE VARIETY OF
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT CAN CURRENTLY FIND A
HOSPITAL FOR BUT IT'S BASED ON
MANY FACTORS THAT THE
LEGISLATION THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PUT INTO.
THE ENACTING BILL THAT THE
DEPARTMENT NEEDS TO LOOK AT IN
ORDER TO CREATE THAT FINE AND SO
IT TAKES IN IT REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
TAKE INTO THE TOTALITY OF ALL OF
THE CIRCUMSTANCES.
AROUND THE EVENT THAT HAPPENED
RATHER THAN A NURSE HAVING TO
STEP AWAY FROM PATIENT CARE FOR
A MOMENT BECAUSE THEIR CHILD'S
SCHOOL -- HAS CALLED WITH A
PROBLEM.
SO WE THINK THAT THE STRICT
LIABILITY STANDARDS THAT APPEARS
IN THE BILL TODAY -- WILL
INCREASE FINES INCREDIBLY -- FLU
SEASON AND FOR NURSES CALL IN
SICK AND THE HOSPITALS ARE
SCRAMBLING TO CALL IN OTHERS
ASKING OTHER NURSES TO STAY
LATER -- WILL JUST INCREASE THE
FINES AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE
OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
CALDERON OUT OSMOSIS STATION
HERE FOR QUESTIONS ALSO WANTED
TO ADD THAT THE SPONSORS HAVE
REPEATEDLY SAID THAT THEY ARE
THIS IS FOCUSED ON THE HAVE
VISUAL OFFENDERS -- ARE
DIFFICULTY IS FOR FIRST AND
FOREMOST S THE REGULATIONS
REQUIRE US AS THE PREVIOUS
WITNESS AS TO BE -- TO HAVE
NURSES AT ALL TIMES AND THERE
ARE MANY SITUATIONS -- WHERE
NURSES STEP OFF THE FLOOR FOR A
MYRIAD OF REASONS -- AND WE MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO GET A NURSE THERE
ON TIME OR A PATIENTS ACUITY
CHANGES AND IT COULD BE TEN
MINUTES BEFORE WE CAN GET A
NURSE THERE.
WE NURSES.
AND AND WE WE APPRECIATE ALL OF
THOSE IN THE ROOM WORK HARD TO
BALANCE THAT DURING THAT SHIFT
BUT AT THAT TIME.
WE WOULD BE FINE THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS OR SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS DEPENDING ON WHERE WE
ARE AND SO FOR US.
COMBINED WITH THE FIND IN THE
OUT ALL TIMES THIS BILL IS VERY
DIFFICULT FOR TO ASK FOR
OPPOSITION.
OTHER.
OPPONENTS SUPPOSED AGAIN NAME
ORGANIZATION AND I CIVIC JOURNAL
I NOW GOT DECISION.
JONATHAN CLAIM TO HAVE A SCRIPT
HEALTH IN OPPOSITION.
CONNIE DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE
DISTRICT HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP
FORUM IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
KAREN SARKISIAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
IN WORKING WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
DISTRICTS IN OPPOSITION.
THE SUCH SHORT ON BEHALF OF
STANFORD HEALTH CARE ON THE
LINES OF CATHOLIC HEALTH CARE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
MICHAEL HAWKINS REPRESENTATIVE
HEALTH CARE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
OKAY SEE NO ONE ELSE OF
MICROPHONE A QUESTION FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
A CENTER STONE.
THANK YOU -- MISTER CHAIR AND
NOW I WANT TO THANK -- ALL THE
NURSES THAT ARE HERE TODAY TO I
I REALLY RESPECT THE WORK THAT
YOU DO.
AND KEEPING OUR OUR CITIZENS
HEALTHY IN HOSPITAL WORKING
UNDER SOME VERY.
STRESSFUL CIRCUMSTANCES --
CENTER LEYVA -- LET ME SAY THAT.
ANY HOSPITAL THAT IS ENGAGED IN
THE PURPOSE FOR INSUBORDINATION
OF THE LAW WITH RESPECT.
TO THE USE RATIOS.
I THINK SHOULD BE IN FACT FIND --
BUT I'M CONSERVE I'M CONCERNED
THAT -- THE OPPOSITION IS MADE
SOME VERY COMPELLING ARGUMENTS
SUCH AS ANDERS COMES IN LATE I
MEAN -- I SEE CEDAR SINAI
HOSPITAL WELL A VERY BRIEF.
LARGE RESPECTABLE INSTITUTION.
TRAFFIC IN LA IS RIDICULOUS MY
DAUGHTER LIVES THERE TAKES ME
HOURS TO GET IN TO SEE HER --
STONE IMPOSSIBLE OF ONE TRAFFIC
ACCIDENT THAT SOMEBODY CAN GET
LIVE THERE LATE -- YOU ALSO WHAT
BY VIRTUE OF THE JOB THE NURSES
DO THEY'RE SURROUNDED BY PEOPLE
THAT ARE SICK IT'S NOT UNCOMMON
THAT THEY CAN BECOME SICK WHILE
THEY'RE WORKING AND THEY GOT TO
GO HOME.
OR IF THERE'S A FAMILY EMERGENCY --
A NURSE MAIN AT MAY HAVE TO GO
HOME AND TAKE CARE FOR A CHILD
OR CARE FOR A LOVED.
ONE AND SO.
WHAT I'M HEARING IS THAT THE LAW
IS VERY RIGID IT'S VERY STRICT
[inaudible]
BUT ARE WE GOING TO BE TAKING
INTO CONSIDERATION HOSPITAL'S
BEST EFFORTS TO COMPLY WITH THE
LAW SO IF YOU NEED THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
HAPPEN AND THEY ARE.
GOING TO LET'S SAY A SERVICE TO
GET A AN EMERGENCY NURSE TO COME
IN AND BACK FILL OR THE CALLING
ON THEIR ARMAMENT TARIAN OF
NURSES THAT ARE NORMALLY ON
THEIR STAFF TO BRING A MAN.
MAYBE IN OVERTIME -- IS THERE
ANY AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'VE TAKEN
OR ARE CONSIDERING TAKING THAT
IS GOING TO KEEP THE GOOD
PLAYERS IF YOU WILL.
FROM GETTING THESE EXTRAVAGANT
FINDS THIRTY AND SIXTY THOUSAND
AND A FOR PURPOSELY EVADING THE
LAW AND PUTTING PATIENTS IN
JEOPARDY YOU SHOULD BE FINE NO
QUESTION ABOUT IT.
I'M WORRIED ABOUT THOSE THOSE
HOSPITALS THAT THROUGH.
POLICIES THAT THEY DON'T 1100%
CONTROL ALL THE TIME BE FALL
DEFICIENT FOR A BRIEF PERIOD OF
TIME UNTIL THEY CAN SATISFY THE
LAW.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR QUESTION SO AS STATED
IN TITLE TWENTY TWO REGULATIONS
SEE SEE OUR SECTION SEVEN ZERO
TWO ONE OUR WHEN A HEALTHCARE
EMERGENCY OCCURS THE HOSPITAL
MUST DEMONSTRATE THAT PROMPT
EFFORTS.
WERE MADE TO MAINTAIN THE
REQUIRED STAFFING LEVELS SO I
THINK THAT SHOULD ADDRESS SOME
OF YOUR CONCERNS I WOULD ALSO
SAY WE HEARD THE OPPOSITION SAY
AT ALL TIMES THAT HAS BEEN IN
STATUTE FOR TWENTY YEARS SO THAT
IS NOT NEW.
AND HOSPITALS ARE UNDER -- THEY
DON'T HAVE AN INVESTIGATION DONE
EVERY DAY EVERY WEEK IT'S EVERY
THREE YEARS SO YOU SOMEONE MIGHT
COME IN LATE AND THEY WON'T BE
RE INVESTIGATED THAT EXCUSE ME
THERE THERE WON'T BE ANY KIND OF
A STUDY THAT DAY SO THEY
WOULDN'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THAT BUT REALLY.
THE STATUTE UNDER TITLE TWENTY
TWO I THINK PROTECTS WHAT YOU
ARE WORRIED ABOUT I KNOW THE
ROUTINE INSPECTIONS EVERY THREE
YEARS BUT CERTAINLY THE
COMPLAINT BASE TO SO -- YOU KNOW
A LOT OF OF THE NURSES -- ARE
PART OF A LARGE LABOR GROUPS.
IF YOU HAVE A LE LABOR --
PROBLEM WITH -- A HOSPITAL -- A
BLUE FLU AS AN EXAMPLE THAT THE
THE REGULARS COME IN THAT DAY
AND THEY'RE STRUGGLING TO GET
THE NURSE RATIOS IN PLACE AND
THEY GOT THESE.
HEINOUS CRIMES BUT I WANTED TO
GIVE THE OPPOSITION A CHANCE TO
RESPOND -- TO MY AT MY QUESTIONS.
ABOUT THE RIGIDITY OF THE BILL --
IS THERE ANY AMENDMENTS THAT
YOU'VE OFFERED THE SENATOR TO
ENSURE THAT.
WHEN YOU HAVE CIRCUMSTANCES
OUTSIDE YOUR CONTROL THAT YOU'RE
NOT GONNA BE FINE THESE
RIDICULOUS AMOUNTS OF MONEY?
COMPLETE STRUGGLING BUTTON.
I'VE DONE THIS BEFORE I DON'T
KNOW THAT WE'VE HAD A
CONVERSATION RECENTLY ABOUT
AMENDMENTS RELATED TO OUR
CONCERNS IT UP RELATED TO THE
OUT ALL TIMES -- AND I'M I HAD
DON'T HAVE THAT RIGGS IN FRONT
OF ME BUT I DO.
I AM CONCERNED THAT -- A NURSE
STEPPING OFF THE FLOOR IT
WOULDN'T NECESSARILY BE AN
EMERGENCY CONSIDER UNDERTHAT
REGULATION I THINK THAT IS
CONSIDERED WHEN YOU THINK OF A
STATE F EMERGENCY -- TYPE
SITUATION SO I'D HAVE TO LOOK AT
THAT RATE I DON'T HAVE IN FRONT
OF ME -- BUT OUR UNDERSTANDING
IS IS THAT.
THAT THAT'S MORE RELATED TO A
SURGE IN AND OUT A SEARCH TYPE
OF AN AS OPPOSED -- TO AN EVENT
WHERE YOU KNOW PREGNANT NURSE
NEEDS TO STOP OFF FOR A MINUTE
AND THEN COME BACK ON SO.
I HOPE THAT ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION.
I'M NOT SURE IF YOU DID EITHER
YEAH WELL I I DON'T WE HAVE NOT
HAD RECENT CONVERSATION RELATED
TO AN INTEREST ON I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE ANSWERS SAID THE LAW
IS NOT DESIGNED TO PROPERLY FIND
THOSE HOSPITALS THAT ARE KNOWING
FULLY NOT.
CURRENTLY USING STAFF THERE HAVE
BEEN A LINE OR TWO RELATED TO
THE HABITUAL -- AND WE DO
BELIEVE WITH PATIENT HARM IS
INVOLVED THE CURRENT FINE
STRUCTURE.
THERE'S A LIST OF THEM EVERY
QUARTER.
OF HOSPITALS THAT ARE FIND
RELATED TO PATIENT HARM SO -- WE
ATTEND OF TEN TO FIFTEEN
UNFORTUNATELY AND AND IF
STAFFING RATIOS WERE FOUND TO BE
IN VIOLATION DURING THAT
IMMEDIATE JEOPARDY -- PENALTY IT
WOULD BE REFLECTED IN THE
DOCUMENT THAT CITY PH POSTS
ONLINE I I KNOW THAT I HAVE SEEN --
ONE IMMEDIATE JEOPARDY WHICH IS
THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF FINE THAT
ON THAT INCLUDED A STAFFING
RATIO VIOLATION.
IF THERE WERE OTHER PROBLEMS --
IN THAT SURVEY THAT THAT THE
HOSPITAL JUST A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION TO EITHER OF YOU HOW
PREVALENT IS -- NURSING RATIO
VIOLATIONS -- OCCURRING IN
CALIFORNIA.
IS IT A PREVALENT PROBLEM.
I DON'T KNOW THAT WE KNOW HOW
PREVALENT THEY ARE I THINK WE
UNDERSTAND HOSPITALS HAVE A
DIFFICULT TIME STAFFING IN AREAS
OF THE STATE WHERE IT'S HARD TO
FIND NURSES.
AND WE DO HEAR ABOUT THAT -- I
KNOW THAT DURING FLU SEASON OUR
HOSPITALS ARE STRAINED -- I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE HAVE A DATA
SET RELATED -- TO RELATED TO
THAT INFORMATION AT THIS POINT
THAT THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
AND FIFTY OR SO -- VIOLATIONS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT FOUND I
GUESS WHEN COMMITTEE ASKED THEM
THAT THAT QUESTION.
OVER A TEN YEAR PERIOD
ENTERTAINMENT PER GALLAGHER MUCH
AND WE WE PROBABLY EMPLOYEE I
WOULD GUESS TWO HUNDRED TO TURN
OVER TWO THOUSAND NURSES ACROSS
THE STATE.
I WOULD PROBABLY. ELEVEN SHIFT
TODAY. TWELVE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO SHOWS A DAY OKAY.
THANK YOU A CENTERS GROWTH.
CAN I ASK YOU TO REPEAT THAT
NUMBER AND I DO APOLOGIZE HI I'M
TAKING A GUESS BUT I'M GONNA
GUESS ABOUT TWO HUNDRED TO TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND NURSES A
YEAR -- AND PLEASE DON'T QUOTE
ME -- AND ESTIMATE AND THEN M.
IF ARE ALIVE OR IF WE HAVE AN
AVERAGE OF ELEVEN DEPARTMENTS
EACH APARTMENT HAS AT LEAST TWO
SHIFTS EIGHT OF TWENTY TWO
SHIFTS.
EACH SHIFT TURN -- CAN CREATE
ISSUES AS WELL.
I THINK WE CAN FOLLOW UP ON A
ABSOLUTE I'M SURE THE PERSON
LISTENING RIGHT NOW IS THE ONLY
A WEEK SOMETHING ON NUMBER OKAY.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I DO
YOU.
I'D LIKE TO THINK THE NURSES MY
DAUGHTER IS A NURSE AND SHE'S
AMID SURGEON -- SO -- I
UNDERSTAND HOW DIFFICULT THE JOB
IT IS -- BUT I DO HAVE THE SAME
CONCERNS THAT MY COLLEAGUE
SITTING NEXT TO ME DOES IT
NGUYEN AND YOU LOOK AT ALL
NURSES AT ALL TIMES.
I HAVE THE SAME CONCERNS BECAUSE
MY CONCERN BASICALLY IS LIKE
MENTIONED IF A PREGNANT NURSERY
NURSE AT INNINGS ACOSTA FOR
FLIRTATION WHAT EVER -- YOU KNOW
MY DAUGHTER IS AT YOU KNOW BEEN
LATE TO WORK -- SHE VERY GOOD
NURSE BUT YOU KNOW THERE'S
TRAFFIC ACCIDENTS AND SIXTY FIVE
SO I GET ALL THAT -- I ALSO --
KNOW THAT CURRENT EXISTING FINES
ARE AT DISCRETION SO SUPPOSE
SOMEBODY DOES COME INTO -- DO A
CHECK OR THERE IS A PHONE CALL
TO THE THE ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
AND THEY COME IN.
AND YOU ARE NOT MEETING THOSE
EXACT STAFFING RATIOS AND THEY
DO AN INVESTIGATION I FACT THEY
FIND OUT THAT AND A NURSE GOT
CALLED BECAUSE SCHOOLS THE
SCHOOL CALLED I HAD AN EMPLOYEE
HERE AT THIS IF THE BUILDING TO
SEE OTHER DAY THE SCHOOL CALLED
AND SAID YOU KNOW.
YOU'RE SENDS REALLY SICK YOU
HAVE TO LEAVE AND COME PICK HIM
UP SO SHE LEFT.
SO IF YOU HAVE THAT SITUATION
AND A NURSES OFF THE FLOOR THE
NEW WOULD BE OUT OF COMPLIANCE.
A RIGHT NOW THE THE ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY COULD MY UNDERSTANDING IS
COULD SAY WELL YOU KNOW THIS
LADY JUST LEFT FOR THIS NURSES
LEFT FIVE MINUTES AGO.
AND THIS PERSON WAS OFF THE
FLOOR GOING TO THE BATHROOM SO
THEREFORE WE CAN SAY THERE'S NO
FINE.
AND MY UNDERSTAND IS BILL DOES
NOT ALLOW DISCRETION IS THAT
TRUE NO THAT'S AND THAT'S NOT
TRUE AT ALL FOR ME SENATOR
ABSOLUTELY -- AS I SAID BEFORE
THAT THE HOSPITAL MUST
DEMONSTRATE THEIR BEST EFFORTS
SO IF SOMEONE LEAVES OFF THE
FLOOR IF SOMEONE IS LACTATING --
IF SOMEONE HAS LEE BECAUSE
THEY'RE SICK OF HAVE TO GO PICK
UP AN ILL CHILD.
I WOULD THINK THAT THE HOSPITAL
CALLING TO TRY AND BRING NURSES
IN TO IMMEDIATELY FILL THAT
POSITION WOULD BE A BEST EFFORT
IT ALSO ALSO TO THE OPPOSITION'S --
SENATOR STONE'S QUESTION AND IT
ISN'T FOR EMERGENCIES THAT SAYS
MùT OR OVER WHAT INSTANCES
WHERE A NURSE GET SICK OR
INJURED ON THE JOB AND AN
INSPECTION IS UNDER WAY.
THE HOSPITAL JUST MUST
DEMONSTRATE PROMPT EFFORTS WERE
MADE SO RATHER THAN JUST
ALLOWING THAT SHIFT TO GO ON
FILLED WE ARE ASKING THAT THE
HOSPITAL MAKE EVERY EFFORT TO
FILL THAT SHIFT AND GET BACK
INTO COMPLIANCE.
SORRY IS THERE ARE YOU UNDER THE
IMPRESSION CENTER LEAVE IT AT
THE HOSPITAL DOESN'T MAKE EVERY
ABSOLUTELY MY DAUGHTER GETS
CALLED IN ON SHIPS THAT ARE HER
SHIFT WITH TIME.
NOT NOT EVERY HOSPITAL OBVIOUSLY
EMMA BUT WE WOULDN'T IT WE WILL
I WOULDN'T BE HERE AGAIN WITH
THIS BILL IF THERE WASN'T A
PROBLEM IF THERE WAS NOT A
COMPLIANCE PROBLEM.
WE INTRODUCE THE BILL TWO YEARS
AGO BECAUSE THERE WAS A
COMPLIANCE PROBLEM THE GOVERNOR
VETOED IT BUT I FEEL SO STRONGLY
AND PASSIONATELY ABOUT PEOPLE'S
CARE PEOPLE'S HEALTH CARE.
I'VE HAD LOVED ONES IN THE
HOSPITAL I KNOW WE YOU KNOW THAT
WE HEAR FROM THE OPPOSITION
THERE'S TWO HUNDRED AND SOME ODD
THOUSAND OUR SHIPS AND WHATNOT
IN ONLY. SIX HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR
ALLEGATIONS REPORT TO CD EIGHT
CITY PH BUT WHAT IF YOUR LOVED
ONE WAS ONE OF THOSE SIX HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FOUR TIMES WHEN
SOMEONE WAS NOT WHEN THE
HOSPITALS OUT OF COMPLIANCE.
NOT EVERY HOSPITALS OUT OF
COMPLIANCE BUT THERE ARE ENOUGH
HOSPITALS OUT OF COMPLAINTS
THAT'S WHY I THINK THERE'S A
NEED FOR THE BILL.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT ON THE
OPPOSITE SIDE OF THAT IF YOU
FIND THESE HOSPITALS SIXTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER INCIDENT
WHEN THERE'S JUST A NURSE IT'S
LATE FOR WORK.
OR SOMEBODY HAS LEFT THE FLOOR
SOMETIMES AS HOSPITALS WILL BE
ABLE TO SURVIVE THOSE PENALTIES
AND FINES AND THEN WE HAVE ZERO
HEALTH CARE SERVICE AND I DO
APPRECIATE THE RULE EXEMPTION
BECAUSE A LOT OF MY DISTRICT IS
RULE.
I HAVE ONE MORE QUESTION -- MY
COLLEAGUE KINDA HIGHLIGHTED ON
IT BUT I GUESS MY QUESTION IS IS
THAT.
IS THIS ANOTHER MECHANISM THAT
CAN BE USED AGAINST THE
HOSPITALS IN LABOR DISPUTE SO
BASICALLY YOU HAVEN'T 90% OF
YOUR NURSES WALK OFF THE FLOOR.
AND BECAUSE THERE'S A LABOR
DISPUTE IN THE HOSPITAL WAS
RESPONSIBLE -- FOR MAKING SURE
THAT THE NURSES RATIO IS MATT.
AND IT'S AN INCIDENT THAT CAUSED
BY THE NURSES ARE THE
INDIVIDUALS THEMSELVES.
AND THAT MAKES IT REALLY
DIFFICULT FOR THE HOSPITALS TO
COMPLY SO IS THERE AN EXEMPTION.
FOR SELF IMPOSED.
THERE IS A RATIO KNOWN ON
EXEMPTION BUT I WOULD SAY THIS.
EVERY NURSE I'VE EVER MET ALL
THE NURSES THAT ARE HERE I
CANNOT IMAGINE ANY OF THEM
WALKING OFF THE JOB AND RISKING
PATIENT SAFETY OUR PATIENTS
LIVES OVER LABOR DISPUTE.
THEY WOULD NOT HAVE GONE INTO
NURSING IF THEY DID NOT CARE
DEEPLY ABOUT EVERY SINGLE PERSON
THAT THEY ARE CARING FOR SO
THERE IS NO EXEMPTION NO MA'AM
THERE IS NOT BUT I WOULD BE
SHOCKED IF NURSES WALKED OFF THE
JOB AND JEOPARDIZED.
PATIENTS HEALTH OVER LABOR
DISPUTE I CAN GIVE YOU A
HOSPITAL WHERE NURSES DID STRIKE
OKAY AND SO -- I DO HAVE A
CONCERN ABOUT THAT -- OKAY WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
WELCOME ALSO JUST LIKE TO SAY
THAT THE SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
FINE THAT IS THE SECOND FIND THE
FIRST A SOLUTION IS.
THIRTY THOUSAND SECOND ONE IS
SIXTY THOUSAND AND MOST OF OUR
HOSPITALS ARE MULTI MILLION
DOLLAR IF NOT BILLION DOLLAR
INDUSTRIES WE DO NOT FEEL THAT
THIS IS SOMETHING SO SIGNIFICANT
THIS FINE THAT WOULD PUT THEM
OUT OF BUSINESS.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
THANK YOU -- THANK YOU CENTER
LEYVA FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AYE -- THEY DID HAVE --
COUPLE QUESTIONS -- IS THE FIRST
OF ALL SWIMMING NOTE THAT THE
FINES -- THAT BASICALLY IF A
VIAL IT BASICALLY MULTIPLE
VIOLATIONS ON THE SAME
INSPECTION SURVEY ACTUALLY COUNT
AS ONE VIOLATION RIGHT SO WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT WELL I ALWAYS
FIND FIVE SO IT'S THIRTY SIXTY
SIX EIGHTY SIX THAT IT.
JUST THIRTY RIGHT.
NOW AND IF THEY FOUND IT AGAIN
ANOTHER INSPECTION THEN IT GOES
UP TO SIXTY BUT IT COULD EVEN BE
HOPEFULLY NOT BUT MULTIPLE
INCIDENTS OCCURRED.
THAT IS INCORRECT AND THEN THE
OTHER.
QUESTION I GUESS I HAVE THE THE
END AND I AND I AND I APPRECIATE --
YOU KNOW YOU'RE YOU HAVE
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE LET'S SAY
SOMEONE THESE GO OFF THE FLOOR
OR SOMETHING -- BUT THERE'S ALSO
THE PART OF ME THAT SAYS IN
NIGHT THAT THOSE RESERVES RECTOR
SIDE USUALLY ENOUGH DOCTORS IN A
RESERVE DOCTORS AROUND RIGHT.
AND YOU HAVE.
TO SO THIS IS IF WE HAVE A
SYSTEM.
RIGHT AS YOU KNOW THERE'S
TRAFFIC I HER TRAFFICKING ALSO
IS THAT IF YOU HAVE A SYSTEM.
WHERE BASICALLY SAID YOU KNOW
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO BE RIGHT AT
THE EDGE?
AND THEN OF ONE LITTLE THING
HAPPENS A TIP THAT ALL OVER
RIGHT WILL BE SHORT.
AND FACE A WORD HEALTH CARE
HEALTH GIMME THINGS HAPPEN RIGHT
THAT WE'RE NOT JUST TALKING Là
ACCIDENT SO WE CAN GET THEIR
ACCIDENT LIKE YOU KNOW A BUS AND
NOW WE HAVE MUCH PATIENTS COME
IN.
I MEAN YOU HAVE TO AND AND I'M
AND THIS IS SOMETHING YOU KNOW
WE CAN WE CERTAINLY CAN TALK
ABOUT BUT ANOTHER TYPE THING WE
HAVE TO HAVE A BUFFER.
TO RIGHT SO WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS
THAT WE'RE NOT IT'S SO WHAT I'M
HEARING ABOUT IS THAT I MEAN IN
TERMS OF STAFFING YOU SHOULD YOU
NEED TO HAVE.
YEAH AT LEAST A LITTLE RESERVE
THERE BECAUSE THINGS DO HAPPEN I
MEAN LEARN HEALTHCARE THINGS
HAPPENED UNEXPECTEDLY.
AND THEY HAPPENED THE UNEXPECTED
HAPPENS SO FREQUENTLY IT NEEDS
TO BE EXPECTED.
RIGHT I MEAN IT JUST DOESN'T TO
DAY AND YEAH WE CAN TALK ABOUT
EXACTLY HOW MUCH AND IN EXACTLY
IN THE AND I APPRECIATE US
EARLIER YOU MENTIONED THAT --
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S BEST EFFORT
RIGHT AND I THINK THIS IS THE
THIS IS PART OF THE BEST EFFORT
NOW DO YOU DOREEN WE'RE NOT
LOOKING AT WE NEED TO HAVE TO
NURSES FOR EVERYONE AND IT'S AT
BUT YOU DO YOU HAVE DO YOU HAVE
TO HAVE AT LEAST.
A LITTLE BIT OF A WITH THE
RESERVE BECAUSE IF NOTHING ELSE.
YOU KNOW THE THINGS HAPPEN RIGHT
SO THE HOSPITAL'S A LITTLE LET
MORE EMPTY YOU KNOW I'D BE JUST
STAFFING RIGHT AT THE EDGE.
AND SO I I THINK THAT WHEN WE
STARTED TO TALK ABOUT LIKE
LITTLE THINGS OUT YOU HAVE A BIG
SYSTEMATIC PROFIT SO I THINK
THAT THE ISSUE IS IS THAT WE
WANT TO BE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
DOING IT IN A SYSTEMATIC WAY AND
TO ME ACTUALLY.
AS SOMEONE WHO'S HAD TO ENFORCE
WORK HOURS RESIDENCIES LIKE
SOMEONE WHO STAFF JUST AT THE
EDGE THAT'S A SYSTEMATIC PROBLEM
THAT'S ACTUALLY SYSTEMATIC
VIOLATIONS OF TECHNICALLY IS NOT
A VIOLATION BECAUSE THEY WILL WE
CAN CROSS THE LINE WE'RE RIGHT
AT IT BUT THEN SOMETHING HAPPENS
IT'S UPSET OVER THAT.
MEANSYOU SYSTEMATICALLY
DESIGNED IT SO THAT YOU THAT
WOULD HAPPEN GIVEN SPECIALLY
VARIATION.
SO I MEAN I YEAH I I AM A I SO I
CERTAINLY HEAR ABOUT AND NOW I
KNOW I DON'T WANT HOSPITAL'S
NICKEL AND DIME BUT THE SAME
TIME I THINK THE FLIP SIDE THOSE
EXPECTATION IS THAT THE
INSTITUTIONS -- WHEN THEY WHEN
YOU SEE A NURSE STAFFING RATIO
YOU'RE NOT JUST STABBING EXACTLY
AT THAT POINT OR JUST A LITTLE
YOU NEED TO HAVE ENOUGH OF
RESERVE TO SHOW THAT YOU'RE NOT
CONSTANTLY CROSSING THAT LINE
THAT IT THAT THAT SHOULD NOT BE
THE NORMAL?
THAT YOU'RE THAT EVERY LITTLE
THING BECAUSE YOU NOW TO HAVE TO
CROSS THAT LINE IT SHOULD BE
LIKE VERY UNUSUAL EVENTS BECAUSE
THE CAUSE THAT TO HAPPEN.
READ DID YOU WANNA SAY SOMETHING
LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE GOING TO SAY
SOMETHING MANY OF OUR HOSPITALS
TO STAFF OVER THE RATIO BECAUSE
WE HAVE TO MANAGE MEAL AND REST
BREAKS BUT DURING FLU SEASONS OR
EVENTS WHERE THE HOSPITAL.
MAY HAVE A PATIENT TURN OVER IT
CAN BE VERY DIFFICULT I THINK
THE FRUSTRATING PART IS THE WAY
WE READ THE BILL THE REGULATORY
SECTION REFERRED TO IS THE OUT
ALL TIME SECTION IT DOES NOT
REFER.
TO THE SECTION SHE'S TALKING
ABOUT IT IS THE AT ALL TIMES IN
THERE ARE INSTANCES HAVING
WORKED IN A HOSPITAL WHERE YOU
KNOW.
THAT YOU CAN HAVE NURSES STEP
OFF THE FLOOR UNEXPECTEDLY AND
IN THOSE INSTANCES WE STRUGGLE
AND WE ARE WORRIED ABOUT WHAT
THIS BILL COMBINED WITH OTHER
OFFERS -- COULD COST OUR
HOSPITAL SO I THINK IF THE GOAL
IS TO GO AFTER VISUAL --
OFFENDERS THAT'S ONE THING BUT
THIS BILL THE WAY WE READ THAT
STOP THE REGULATORY SECTION IT
IS AT ALL TIMES OKAY SOONER BUT
I UNDERSTAND IT ALSO I MEAN WELL
CERTAINLY.
SOME IT IS ALSO A COMPLAINT
DRIVEN THAT IT'S WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SECTIONS EVERY THREE YEARS
RIGHT.
YOU CAN ALSO A COMPLAINT CAN
LOOK BACK OR YOU CAN HAVE
MULTIPLE COMPLAINTS DIVERT GIVEN
CERTAIN SITUATIONS RIGHT OF
WHICH ACTUALLY IF YOU HAD
MULTIPLE COMPLAINTS THAT WOULD
BE ONE FINE.
THAT YOU CAN HAVE MULTIPLE LANES
OVER MULTIPLE DAYS.
OKAY WELL.
YOU KNOW WHAT I I URGE THE IT
THE SPURS YOU CAN WORK OUT SOME
OF THESE THINGS BUT I THINK THE
OVERALL -- I THINK WE NEED TO
HAVE WE NEED TO HAVE BETTER
ENFORCEMENT WHERE -- RECOGNIZING
THAT YOU NEED TO STILL DESIGN
YOUR SYSTEMS WITH SOME
RESILIENCY.
AND THAT AND AND AND THAT -- AND
AND THAT'S PART OF SHOWING YOU
USING YOUR BEST EFFORT IN MY
MIND SO -- A SO I CERTAINLY
THINK THE CONVERSATION NEEDS TO
CONTINUE.
AND AND BUT YEAH I THINK.
I I THINK THAT -- WE WE NEED TO
MOVE THE BILL FORD -- TODAY SELF --
WITH THAT -- SIR NO OTHER
COMMENT THEN -- SIR LABEL WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
I THINK YOU IN CAPS SLATED IT
VERY WELL WHEN YOU SAID THAT
WHEN YOUR STAFFING RIGHT AT THE
EDGE THAT CAN LEAD TO A LOT OF
PROBLEMS.
pALWAYS WILLING AND OUR DOORS
ALWAYS OPEN TO TALK TO
OPPOSITION IF WE CAN GET TO SOME
PLACE WHERE REYES A LITTLE
HAPPIER LITTLE UNHAPPY WE'VE HAD
A GOOD NEGOTIATION.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY I FEEL
INCREDIBLY PASSIONATE ABOUT WHAT
THESE NURSES TO AND THE FACT THE
HOSPITAL'S OF HAD TWENTY YEARS
TO GET IT RIGHT AND THEY HAVE
NOT.
SO THIS IS ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT PATIENTS ARE SAFE BUT IT'S
ALSO ABOUT MAKING SURE THE
NURSES ARE SAFE BECAUSE THEY DO
VERY HARD JOBS MUCH HARDER THAN
WHAT WE DO EVERY DAY AND
PEOPLE'S LIVES ARE LITERALLY ON
THE LINE.
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE OKAY -- IS OUR
MOTION ON THE BILL.
WELL AS I UNDERSTAND FROM THE
RULES THAT I CAN I CAN MOVE IT
AS A COURTESY NORMALLY I DON'T
DO IS THE CHAIR BUT SINCE MANY
OF MEMBERS ARE APPS AND OTHER
COMMITTEES I WILL MOVE THE BILL
AND SEC -- SECRETARY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS A
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AN BY AN ICE STONE.
STONE NO DORADO GROVE.
GROVE NO FURTADO LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE MITCHELL.
MONNING RUBIO.
THE ACCOUNT IS SET -- TO TO ALL
CALL THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT AND THEN YOU ALSO HAVE --
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN SB
[inaudible]
FIVE SEVENTY FOUR A ON THE SIDE.
THAT IS NOT [inaudible]
SELECT THE RIGHT.
GET A CALL BACK.
OUT IN CASE THAT AARON AND I
GUESS ONE OF YEAH SIX MONTHS AGO.
RIGHT OKAY [inaudible]
AND SO BASICALLY.
THE ALL THE ONES.
OKAY LEAST AS MAKING
[inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
WE WORK WITH.
OKAY.
YEAH KNOWN THAT'S ARE YOU.
OKAY. TO BEGIN WITH YEAH OKAY
YES SIR LEYVA THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN I
WILL BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
HOWEVER I DO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THE AMENDMENTS -- TAKEN DO
IGNORE THE REALITY OF MANY
PEOPLE INCLUDING WORKERS ACROSS
THE GLOBE WHO ARE UNDER
TREMENDOUS HEALTH THREATS SUCH
AS OCCUPATIONAL ASTHMA ALLERGIES
AND ENDOCRINE DISRUPTION.
SALON WORKERS WHO ARE LARGELY
WOMEN NEED TO KNOW WHAT
FRAGRANCE ALLERGENS ARE IN THE
PRODUCTS THEY USE TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES FROM ASTHMA RELATED
EXPOSURES.
AND OTHER HARMFUL HEALTH IMPACTS
PROFESSIONAL SALON WORKERS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY EXPLODES
SUPPOSED TO FRAGRANCES IN THE
WORKPLACE HAIR DRESSERS AND
BEAUTICIANS HEAVY FORTY SEVEN
FOLD HIGHER INCREASE.
OF FRAGRANT SKIN ALLERGIES THE
PEOPLE AND OTHER OCCUPATIONS
WORKERS AND CONSUMERS ALSO NEED
MORE INFORMATION TO AVOID THE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF ENDOCRINE
DISRUPTING COMPOUNDS EDCS.
ON HEALTHY PRENATAL AND
CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT BREAST AND
OTHER CANCERS INFERTILITY AND A
HOST OF OTHER ADVERSE EFFECTS SO
ALTHOUGH WE ARE PUTTING THESE
CONCERNS AND ISSUES ASIDE TODAY.
I REMAIN COMMITTED TO WORKING ON
THESE ISSUES IN THE YEARS TO
COME.
MEMBERS SB FIVE SEVENTY FOUR
REQUIRES DISCLOSURE OF FRAGRANCE
AND FLAVOR INGREDIENTS AND
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS THAT
APPEAR ON DESIGNATED AN-AUTHORITATIVE HAZARDOUS CHEMICAL
LISTS TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
HEALTH SAFE COSMETICS PROGRAM SB
FIVE SEVENTY FOUR WILL EMPOWER
CONSUMERS TO MAKE EDUCATED
DECISIONS ABOUT WHICH PRODUCTS
TO USE WITH THEIR KIDS AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND EVEN THEMSELVES. TO
NOTE THIS BILL DOES NOT BAN ANY
PRODUCT INGREDIENTS OR REQUIRE
ANY ADDITIONAL PRODUCT LABELING.
SB FIVE SEVENTY FOUR ALT ALSO
PROTECTS THE CONFIDENTIAL
BUSINESS INFORMATION INCLUDING
PRODUCT INGREDIENT FORMULAS THAT
IS NOT IDENTIFIED AS HARMFUL BUT
BY AUTHORITATIVE BODIES TODAY IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE PUBLIC KNOWS MORE ABOUT
FRAGRANCE INGREDIENTS IN
CLEANING PRODUCTS THAT ABOUT
THOSE THAT THEY USED TO CLEAN
AND THEN WE KNOW ABOUT WHAT WE
PERFUME OUR BODIES WITH.
PUT ANOTHER WAY WE NOR BUT MORE
ABOUT THE FLOOR CLEANER AND
DISINFECTANTS IN OUR SHAMPOOS
DEODORANTS AND BODY SPRAYS.
WE ALSO KNOW VERY LITTLE ABOUT
THE FLAVORS IN CHOPSTICKS
MOUTHWASH AND LIP GLOSS.
MANY OF THE PRODUCTS THAT
CONTAIN POTENTIALLY HARMFUL
FLAVORS.
ARE MARKED BY THEIR MARKETED TO
CHILDREN WITH KRISPY KREME
DONUTS AND ICE CREAM FLAVORS.
ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE AT RISK OF
EXPOSURE TO SECRET HAZARDOUS
FRAGRANCE AND FLAVOR CHEMICALS
AND RELATED HARMFUL CHRONIC
HEALTH CONDITIONS PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS SUCH AS
CHILDREN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
AND PREGNANT WOMEN.
CURRENTLY NO STATE OR FEDERAL
LAW REQUIRES THE DISCLOSURE OF
FRAGRANCE OR FLAVOR INGREDIENTS
TO CONSUMERS OR REGULATORY
AGENCIES.
THIS LOOPHOLE ALLOWS CHEMICALS
TO HIDE UNDER THE WORD FRAGRANCE
OR FLAVOR ON THE LABELS OF THE
BEAUTY PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
WITH LITTLE REGULATORY OVERSIGHT.
OF THE SAFETY CONCERNS.
YOU CAN SEE FOR YOURSELF ON THE
LABELS OF THE PRODUCTS YOU USE
EVERY MORNING AND EVERY NIGHT.
THOUSANDS OF SYNTHETIC CHEMICALS
ARE USED TO CREATE FRAGRANCES
AND FLAVORS A COMPARABLE
COMPRISE THE BEAUTY AND PERSONAL
CARE PRODUCTS WE USE EVERY DAY.
MY FAVORITE LIP GLOSS I'D IT'S
FLAVORED BUT I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT
IS IN IT AND WHAT IS FLAVORED
WITH.
THESE PRODUCTS INCLUDE PERFUME
SHAMPOOS MOISTURIZERS LIPSTICKS
AND HAIR STYLING PRODUCTS.
SOME OF THESE CHEMICALS HAVE
BEEN LEAD TO NEGATIVE HEALTH
IMPACTS RANGING FROM ALLERGIC
REACTIONS TO REPRODUCTIVE HARM
AND INCREASED RISK OF BREAST
BREAST CANCER.
FRAGRANCE CHEMICALS CAN BE FOUND
IN MORE THAN 95% OF SHAMPOOS
CONDITIONERS HAIR STYLING
PRODUCTS ANTIPERSPIRANT AND
SHAVING PRODUCTS AS WELL AS FINE
FRAGRANCES BODIES BRAND LOTIONS.
IN FACT ONE THIRD OF FRAGRANCE
CHEMICALS CURRENTLY IN USE HAVE
BEEN LINKED TO NEGATIVE HEALTH
IMPACTS.
IT IS CURRENTLY.
LEGAL FOR COMPANIES TO NOT
DISCLOSE THESE INGREDIENTS
HOWEVER IN RESPONSE TO GROWING
CONSUMER DEMAND SOME COMPANIES
HAVE BEGUN DISCLOSING FRAGRANCE
AND FLAVOR INGREDIENTS IN TEIR
PRODUCTS AND BIG RETAILERS ARE
BEGINNING TO DEMAND.
INGREDIENT DISCLOSURE AS A
CONDITION OF SELLING PRODUCTS IN
THEIR STORES.
SB FIVE SEVENTY FOUR WILL BE THE
CATALYST NEEDED TO ENSURE THE
CONSUMERS KNOW THE PRESENCE OF
HARMFUL INGREDIENTS AND ALL THE
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS THEY HAVE
THE OPTION OF BUYING.
WITH THIS BILL WE ARE
RECOGNIZING THAT CONSUMERS AND
WORKERS HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW
WHAT INGREDIENTS ARE IN THEIR
BEAUTY AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS THAT THEY USE DAILY.
SB FIVE SEVENTY FOUR WILL ENSURE
THE CALIFORNIA IS ONCE AGAIN A
NATIONAL AND GLOBAL LEADER ON
PUBLIC HEALTH.
SB FIVE SEVENTY FOUR REPRESENTS
THE STRONGEST DISCLOSURE LAW
DISCLOSURE LAW IN THE COUNTRY
AND RARE AND ACROSS THE WORLD OF
HARMFUL FRAGRANCE AND FLAVOR
INGREDIENTS.
WITH ME TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT IS
MEGAN WHITNEY HIT ME FOUNDER AND
CEO OF TRUE BOTH TENTACLES DR
WILLIAM GOODSON SENIOR SCIENTIST
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PACIFIC
MEDICAL RESEARCH INSTITUTE.
AND WHEN APPROPRIATE I'LL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN THANK YOU
CENTER LEYVA -- SIX MINUTES
TOTAL SERVICE TO WITNESSES KEEP
THAT IN MIND THANK YOU.
FOR THE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
WILLIAM GOTTEN FOR THIRTY FIVE
YEARS I'VE BEEN A BREAST CANCER
DOCTOR FIVE STUDY PRESS CANCER
I'VE TREATED BREAST CANCER ARE
DIAGNOSED I KNOW IT WELL. FOR
THE LAST FOURTEEN YEARS I HAVE
CO LEAD A TEAM STUDYING HOW
ENVIRONMENTAL CHEMICALS
INFLUENCE WHAT HAPPENS IN NORMAL
BREAST TISSUE BEFORE IT BECOMES
MALIGNANT.
ALL OF THE SEA BREEZE AND ARE
TOUCHED BY AND MAKE SURE IN
VITAMIN CHEMICALS EVERY DAY.
MOST OF THEM WE DON'T EVEN KNOW
ABOUT.
SOME OF THESE CHEMICALS ARE
PROVING CARCINOGENS THE ONLY BIG
QUESTION IS HOW MANY OF THE
OTHER QUESTIONS OTHER CHEMICALS
CAUSE CANCER.
UNTIL FINAL ANSWERS ARE
AVAILABLE PRUDENT PERSON MIGHT
WANT TO CHOOSE TO AVOID
SUSPECTING SUSPECTED TOXIC
CHEMICALS.
IN THE DO THE TO DO THIS THEY
NEED TO KNOW WHAT'S IN THE
PRODUCTS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE COMPLETE
CONTENTS OF MAKE UP AND PERSONAL
CARE PRODUCTS ARE CURRENTLY
HIDDEN FROM CALIFORNIANS BY A
LABELING NEW POLL.
OUR RESEARCH FOR EXAMPLE ASKED
YOUNG WOMEN TO CHANGE THEIR
COSMETICS FROM THEIR USUAL
COSMETICS TO PHTHALATE IMPAIR
BEEN FREE COSMETICS FOR A PERIOD
OF ONE MONTH WE PROVIDED THEM.
WITH FREE COSMETICS THE STRIKING
THING WAS THAT S WE BEGAN WE
COLLECTED A URINE SAMPLE AND
1100% OF THESE VOLUNTEERS HAD
VALLEY IN THEIR URINE EVEN
THOUGH NONE OF THE PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS WHICH WE DETAILS AN
INDEX VERY CAREFULLY.
LISTED PHTHALATES ON THE LABEL
THEREFORE THIS OUT THERE AND
NOBODY KNOWS ABOUT IT.
WE KNOW THE PHTHALATES CAME FROM
THE PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE MONTH
AFTER THEY HAD BEEN USING
PRODUCTS THAT WERE FREE OF
PHTHALATES.
BUT BALLOTS IN THEIR URINE WENT
AWAY THEIR URINE WAS CLEAN SO TO
SPEAK.
IMPORTANTLY THE YOUNG WOMEN WHO
USE THE CUTS OUT OF THE PRODUCTS
THAT WE GAVE THEM REPORTED THAT
THE PRODUCTS WORKED.
THEY WERE QUITE COMFORTABLE WITH
IT SO YOU DON'T NEED TO HAVE THE
STUFF IN THE COSMETICS.
MANUFACTURERS GROUP THESE
CHEMICALS ON THE LABEL BY
CALLING THEM FRAGRANCES.
AND THEY DON'T REALLY DISCLOSE
THAT THE FRAGRANCES INCLUDES
PHTHALATES AND WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT HEALTH
REASONS TO AVOID.
AND I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT
INDUSTRIAL ACCIDENT I'M TALKING
ABOUT WHAT PEOPLE PUT ON THEIR
BODY IN THE NORMAL COURSE OF THE
DAY.
SOME PHTHALATES NOT BE LEE NOT
ALL PHTHALATES BUT SOME
PHTHALATES ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
INCREASE IN BREAST CANCER.
PHTHALATES ARE KNOWN TO HARM
PREGNANT WOMEN AND NEWBORN
CHILDREN.
ALEX ARE LINKED TO PREECLAMPSIA
WHICH IS A HORRIBLE DEVASTATING
PROBLEM IN PREGNANCY THAT CAN BE
FATAL -- PHTHALATE EXPOSURE IS
LINKED TO INCREASED RISK OF
GROUP IN A CHILD IN THE FIRST
YEAR OF LIFE AGAIN A POTENTIALLY
FATAL PROBLEM.
AND PHTHALATES IN GENERAL ARE
LINKED TO CHANGES IN THE
GENITALIA OF SMALL BABY BOYS.
THIS IS MAINSTREAM SCIENCE
SUPPORTED BY WORK AT THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH SAFETY THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION FOR CANCER
RESEARCH THE EUROPEAN USING
JAPANESE AND CHINESE RESEARCH
CENTERS LOCALLY AT UCSF UC
BERKELEY STANFORD OTHER UC
CAMPUSES HARVESTED HARVARD
ETCETERA.
I DISCUSS VALID SAID ALEX AND I
WOULD JUST POINT OUT THAT THAT'S
ONE THING THERE ARE MANY THINGS.
ADMITTEDLY NOT EVERYTHING BAD
THAT CAN HAPPEN WILL HAPPEN TO
EVERY WOMAN OR CHILD BUT EVERY
PERSON DESERVES THE RIGHT TO
DECIDE WHAT CHANCES THEY WILL
TAKE FOR THEMSELF TO DO THIS
CALIFORNIA'S MUST BE ABLE TO
KNOW WHAT IS IN THE PRODUCTS
THEY ARE USING.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR PAN THE
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS MEGAN HACKNEY AND
THEY'RE GOOD.
I'M I'M THE PRESIDENT OF TRUE
BOTANICALS MORE SAN FRANCISCO
BASED MANUFACTURER OF PERSONAL
CARE PRODUCTS WE VOLUNTARILY
DISCLOSE EXACTLY WHAT GOES INTO
OUR PRODUCTS SO OUR CONSUMERS
DON'T UNKNOWINGLY USE HARMFUL
INGREDIENTS.
THAT ARE OFTEN OBSCURED UNDER
THE FRAGRANCE UMBRELLA.
I'M HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
FRAGRANCE CHEMICALS AS YOU'VE
HEARD CAN BE FOUND IN THE
MAJORITY OF PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS AS DOCTOR GOODS IN JUST
SPOKE TO SOME OF THE CHEMICALS
USED HAVE BEEN LINKED TO SERIOUS
HEALTH PROBLEMS.
THE LACK OF FRAGRANT INGREDIENT
DISCLOSURE CREATES AN UNFAIR
HURDLE FOR CONSUMERS AND WORKERS
ALIKE WHO ARE WANTING TO AVOID
ON SAFE CHEMICAL EXPOSURE.
THE LACK OF FLAVOR INGREDIENT
DISPEL DISCLOSURE IS ALSO A
PROBLEM.
BECAUSE THE MAJORITY OF
TOOTHPASTE WHICH I HOPE WE ALL
USE DALY AND ALSO CONTAIN SECRET
CHEMICALS.
MY SON'S FAVORITE LIP BALM FALLS
VICTIM TO THE SAME ISSUE.
AND HE MORE OFTEN THAN NOT IT'S
THE STRAWBERRY BOMB RATHER THAN
USING IT DESPITE MY BEST EFFORTS.
THIS DISCLOSURE LOOPHOLE ALLOWS
DOZENS SOMETIMES EVEN HUNDREDS.
OF CHEMICALS TO HIDE UNDER THE
WORD FRAGRANCE OR FLAVOR ON
PRODUCT LABELS WITH NO
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT
HOUSE CLEANING PRODUCTS AS
YOU'VE HEARD BY CONTRAST ARE
ALREADY REGULATED IN THIS WAY
YET WE'RE NOT BEATING IN MY SAW.
I'M EXCITED AND HOPEFUL BECAUSE
CLEAN BEAUTY COMPANIES LIKE OURS
REPRESENT THE FASTEST GROWING
SEGMENT OF THE PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS MARKET RETAIL SALES ARE
ESTIMATED TO GENERATE FIFTEEN
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS IN.
TWENTY TWENTY DR GAMBLE UNILEVER
JOHNSON AND JOHNSON AS WELL AS
HUNDREDS OF SMALLER SIZE
COMPANIES LIKE OURS ARE
VOLUNTARILY DISCLOSING FRAGRANCE
IN THERE AND IN THEIR
INGREDIENTS SHOWING IS NOT ONLY
POSSIBLE BUT IS VERY PROFITABLE
TO DO SO.
JUST YESTERDAY THE ACTORS MISS
MICHELLE PFEIFFER LAUNCHED AN
ENTIRELY TRANSPARENT FRONT FINE
FRAGRANCE COMPANY.
SHOWING INNOVATION AND CONSUMER
EMPOWERMENT ARE MOVING INTO THE
MAINSTREAM.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY BECAUSE
CONSUMERS ARE DEMANDING IT.
BEING THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND I
CAN TELL YOU IT'S NOT US IT'S
THEM AND WE'RE RESPONDING. TO
BOTANICALS AND FIFTY SAFE
COMPANIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL BECAUSE
CONSUMERS AND WORKERS NOT ONLY
WANT TO KNOW.
BUT HAVE THE RIGHT TO KNOW WHAT
HARMFUL INGREDIENTS ARE IN THE
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS THAT WE
ALL BRING HOME TO OUR FAMILIES.
AND USE IN OUR WORKPLACES EVERY
DAY.
SIMPLY PUT FRAGRANCE OF LABOR
DISCLOSURE SHOULD BE THE NEW
NORMAL FOR OUR INDUSTRY CENTER
LEAVE HIS BILLS AN IMPORTANT
STEP IN THIS DIRECTION AND I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT IT.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT THE BACK MICROPHONE NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION.
MY NAME IS JAN ROBINSON FLINT I
WORK WITH BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS AND WE SUPPORT I AM
ALSO THE CO CHAIR OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR HEALTHY AND
GREEN ECONOMY.
CHANGE COALITION AND WE ARE
SUPPORT ALSO.
HI AND INSECURE MEYER ON BEHALF
OF THE OTHER A CO SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL WOMEN'S VOICES FOR THE
EARTH.
AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHY NAIL SALON COLLABORATIVE
WOODLAND COALITION FOR GREEN
SCHOOLS WORK SAVE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
COALITION FOR OCCUPATIONAL
HEALTH AND SAFETY THE CENTER FOR
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS AND JUSTICE
AT UC BERKELEY LAW.
AND UCLA CENTER FOR THE STUDY OF
WOMEN THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS POLLY MARSHALL I AM A
BREAST CANCER SURVIVOR AND
MOTHER.
AND I'M ALSO HERE SPEAKING FOR
BREAST CANCER OVER TIME AN
ORGANIZATION OF BREAST CANCER
SURVIVORS. FOR US THIS IS NOT
JUST AN ISSUE OF RIGHT TO KNOW
THIS IS AN ISSUE OF RIGHT TO
SURVIVE AND RIGHT TO PROTECT OUR
CHILDREN THANK YOU HELP US DOING
DO THIS BY SUPPORTING THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU GOT TO BE
TO HI MY NAME IS SAMANTHA
TOURISM A MASTERS IN PUBLIC
HEALTH GRADUATE STUDENT AT SAN
FRANCISCO STATE UNIVERSITY.
I AM ALSO THE STUDY COORDINATOR
FOR BREAST CANCER OVER TIME AND
ALSO THE GRANDDAUGHTER OF A
BREAST CANCER SURVIVOR AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR
JUST A MINUTE.
MY NAME IS TIFFANY CAL I
REPRESENT HAND SKIN CARE
COSMETICS BASED IN SAN MATTEO --
I'M ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
FOLLOWING COMPANIES ESSENTIAL EO
ESSENTIAL OILS HAPPY PRETTY YOU
RICKY SALON AND SPA.
INTELLIGENT NUTRIENTS IN HARMONY
JUICE BEAUTY JUST THE GOODAND
MINDFUL MINERALS WE ARE ALL
COMPANIES TO DISCLOSE THEIR
FRAGRANCES AND FRAGRANCE AND
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
HI I'M JOE IN STARK MEN I'M A
MOTHER TO A SPECIAL NEEDS ADULT
I AM A HAIRSTYLIST FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS I'M ALSO THE
FOUNDER OF INNER SENSE ORGANIC
BEAUTY WHICH IS A HAIR CARE
COMPANY.
THAT HAS BEEN DISCLOSING IN OUR
FRAGRANCES SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SIX AND I AM HERE AND STRONGLY
SUPPORT WITH OTHER COMPANIES --
AS AMERICAN SUSTAINABLE BUSINESS
COUNCIL CALIFORNIA BABY CRYING
SHE DE MISS EARTH MAMA ORGANICS
EGO PLUM SUSTAINABLE SWAG EIGHTY
TWO DEGREES -- AND OF ALL OF OUR
OWN MONDAY SOLUTIONS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI I'M MORTGAGING CIRCLE IN --
OWNER OF INNER SENSE AGAIN A PT
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LAUREN DOKO I AM
DIRECTOR AT INNER SENSE ORGANIC
BEAUTY WHICH IS A LEADER IN
CLEAN BEAUTY HAIR CARE.
I SUPPORT THE SPELL.
THANK YOU.
HI IVANA GANG WITH BEAUTY
COUNTER WERE MAKERS OF CLEANS
THE FOR COSMETICS AND PERSONAL
CARE PRODUCTS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE SPELL ALONGSIDE
OTHER CALIFORNIA NATIONAL
MANUFACTURERS AND BUSINESSES
INCLUDING.
CREDO DETOX MARKET SOME
GENERATION BIOSCIENCE SKIN OWL
MAY LINDSTROM CODES -- CO AND
GOT DISCARDED.
THANK YOU.
BALLERINA BUT WITH CALIFORNIA
HEALTH COLLISION ADVOCACY IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HELLO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
CHRISTIE'S ABOVE IT A PURCHASE
FROM EDUCATE ADVOCATE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JANUARY TEARS ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M SUSAN LITTLE WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP AND
I'M ALSO BEEN ASKED TO REGISTER
THE SUPPORT OF CALPERS.
US PER CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL NATIONAL
STEWARDSHIP ACTION COUNCIL AND
PLASTIC POLLUTION COALITION.
THANK YOU.
LINDA DINNER WITH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
SHANNON PRIMER FROM EMPOWER
FAMILY CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO AN
EDUCATIONAL PARALEGAL I HAVE
MANY CLIENTS WITH THIS ISSUE
INCLUDING ONE WITH MASS CELL
DISEASE.
AND I ALSO HAVE SEVERE ASTHMA
AND ALLERGIES MYSELF I'M FULLY
IN SUPPORT.
YOU.
MORE INCOME ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL WE'VE ALSOBEEN ASKED
TO REGISTER SUPPORT FOR AS YOU
SO CITIZENS FOR CHOICE CLEAN
WATER ACTION AND COMING CLEAN
THANK YOU.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP CALIFORNIANS
ARE SORRY THE CALIFORNIA LEAVE
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AND I'VE ALSO BEEN
ASKED TO ENSURE SUPPORT PEOPLE
COULD NOT BE HERE.
ECOLOGY CENTER ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH STRATEGY CENTER NON TOXIC
REVOLUTION AND OREGON
ENVIRONMENTAL COUNCIL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- JIM WHEN BURKE ON
BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
LEE SAID VAN FLEET I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE OF NURSES
FOR A HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT
PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY SAN FRANCISCO AND
LA.
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA ASTHMA
COLLABORATIVE THE COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR ABLE DIFFERENTLY
BREAST CANCER ACTION LEARNING
DISABILITIES ASSOCIATIONS OF
GEORGIA ILLINOIS IOWA MAINE NEW
JERSEY OKLAHOMA SOUTH CAROLINA
TENNESSEE TEXAS IN UTAH AND
FINALLY HEALTH CARE WITHOUT HARM.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
SEVEN FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HELLO -- DOCTOR TO CARBON TINY
CAM A TIE WILL AND I AM WITH THE
UC DAVIS ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
SCIENCES CENTER AND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI I'M DOCTOR CLAUDIO LOPEZ I'M
AN OBGYN RESIDENT AND I'M HERE
WITH THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
SECTORS AND GOING TO COLLEGE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DOCTOR AND WE'LL
SEND THEM ANOTHER OBGYN RESIDENT
AT UC DAVIS HERE ON BEHALF OF A
COG SO AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBSTETRICIANS AND GYNECOLOGISTS
STRONG SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MATTHEW MONSON
WITH PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE AND
A PROGRAM THE REGIONAL ASTHMA
MANAGEMENT PREVENTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK THANK
YOU.
MAKE IT ACROSS THE WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT ALSO
REGISTERING SUPPORT FOR C. FOR
STATES THE SAPPY WOMEN'S
ALLIANCE SCIENCE ENVIRONMENT
HEALTH NETWORK.
THE SEVENTH GENERATION ADVISORS
THANK YOU.
SIR FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CATHERINE BATES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE SEVENTY FOUR
ON BEHALF OF THE ALASKAN
COMMUNITY ACTION ON TOXICS JUST
TRANSITION LINES AND THE
CALIFORNIAPAN NOTHING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HERE FROM SAN FRANCISCO BASED TO
THE TENTACLES IN SUPPORT ALSO
HERE ON BEHALF OF OZ NATURALS TO
STAY NATURAL SUZANNE'S ORGANICS
SUNTECH READY TEN OVER.
TEN ZORA HUNDRED PEER PURIFIED
SEVEN ACTS AND THE HOLISTIC
HEALTH COMPANY THANK YOU THANK
YOU. FIVE UNIVERSITIES HERE WE
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA ROOM TO TO
SEE THE LINES AND ALSO
REGISTERED TO FIRST SUPPORT FOR
COMMUNITIES FOR BETTER
ENVIRONMENTS IN CALIFORNIA'S.
COMMITTEES AGAINST TOXICS THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
DOT THE RIVER MINISTER CIVIL
RIGHTS AND HUMAN RIGHTS SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU HAVE A
GOOD DAY THANK YOU.
SIR HUTCHINSON WITH ACT FOR
WOMEN AND GIRLS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA
BLACKOUTS NO CAN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
CASEY NO OTHER UP WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE MAKE ROOM FOR THEM AT THE
TABLE.
OKAY SIR MOVED TO THE SIDES
PERHAPS [inaudible]
CENTER THERE [inaudible]
OKAY.
SO DOCTOR PAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE GOOD
AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS JAN SELDOM VICE
PRESIDENT OF SCIENCE FOR THE
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS COUNCIL.
PHD CHEMIST AND A BOARD
CERTIFIED TOXICOLOGIST AND I'M
HERE ON SB. FIVE SEVENTY FOUR TO
VOICE OUR POSITION IN OPPOSITION
UNLESS AMENDED.
WE APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENT SO FAR BUT WE STILL
HAVE ADDITIONAL COMMENTS WHICH
WE WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS. TO
BEGIN WE WORK COLLABORATIVELY
WITH NUMEROUS STAKEHOLDERS TO
HELP ESTABLISH REGULATIONS AT
BOTH THE FEDERAL AND STATE LEVEL
THAT PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY AND
OVERSIGHT FOR COSMETICS.
UNDER THE U. S. FEDERAL LAW
PERSONAL CARE COMPANIES TO
DISCLOSE INDIVIDUAL INGREDIENTS
ON PRODUCT LABELS.
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF FRAGRANCES
WHICH FTA ALLOWS TO BE LISTED
COLLECTIVELY AS FRAGRANCE.
THIS RECOGNIZES THAT FRAGRANCES
SHOULD BE PROTECTED.
UNDER OUR NATION'S INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY LOSS.
FRAGRANCES HAVE VALUE PRECISELY
BECAUSE THEY ARE CONFIDENTIAL.
FURTHER SB SEVEN OF FIVE SEVENTY
FOUR DUKE CLEATS THE WORK ORDER
BE DONE ALREADY DONE UNDER
EXISTING CALIFORNIA LAWS.
AND FOR THE FOLLOWING ADDITIONAL
REASONS SHOULD BE REJECTED.
THE BELIEVE THE FRAGRANCE
INGREDIENTS PERCENT TO HUMAN
HEALTH RISK IS UNFOUNDED.
THERE IS A ROBUST PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE REVIEW.
UNDERTAKEN BY THE RESEARCH
INSTITUTE FOR FRAGRANCE
MATERIALS EXPERT PANEL ON
FRIEDMAN SAFETY.
A REVIEW PANEL OF
INTERNATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
EXPERTS.
THIS SYSTEM WORKS.
AND DECADES OF CONSUMER
EXPERIENCE WITH OUR PRODUCTS
DEMONSTRATES THE AMONG THE
SAFEST PRODUCTS REGULATED BY FDA.
NEXT XP -- SB FIVE SEVENTY FOUR
RELIES ON TWENTY SEVENTH FLOOR
TATE OF LISTS WHICH ARE
DUPLICATIVE.
SOME NOT ROOTED IN SOUND SCIENCE
AND WILL CAUSE CONSUMER
CONFUSION. FOR EXAMPLE PROP
SIXTY FIVE ESTABLISHES A ROBUST
PROCESS. TO REVIEW LISTS OF
AUTHORITATIVE BODIES IN THE TERM
AND WHICH MATERIALS REQUIRED
DISCLOSURE UNDER PROP.
SIXTY FIVE THE INCLUSION OF
THESE LISTS AND FIVE SEVENTY
FOUR WILL MAKE THE ENTIRE PROP
SIXTY FIVE PROCESS MOVED.
THE CALIFORNIA SAFER COSMETICS
PROGRAM THAT INCORPORATES A LIST
OF LISTS WHICH INCLUDE PROP.
SIXTY FIVE AND OTHER LISTS WHICH
ARE INCLUDED AMONG THE TWENTY
SEVEN ADDITIONALLY.
LISTS ARE -- ARE INCLUDED.
WHICH IDENTIFY MATERIALS WHICH
ARE PROPOSED TO BE TESTED HAVE
NOT.
SHOWN TO CAUSE ANY ADVERSE
EFFECT.
AND OTHER LISTS WHICH IN FACT
ESTABLISH SAFE EXPOSURE LEVELS
FOR MATERIALS. FOR THESE REASONS
AND OTHERS WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU. FOR YOUR NO VOTE ON SB FIVE
SEVENTY FOUR UNLESS AMENDED.
UNFORTUNATELY WE WERE ONLY ABLE
TO HAVE A DIALOGUE WITH THE
OTHER AUTHORS AND SPONSORS LATE
LAST WEEK AND HOPE THIS
COMMITTEE RESERVES ITS RIGHT. TO
HEAR AND SEE THIS BILL AGAIN AS
IT IS DESCRIBED AS A WORK IN
PROGRESS.
AS AN INDUSTRY THAT HAS OPENLY
LABELS PRODUCTS TO THE
INGREDIENTS SINCE THE SEVENTIES.
WE ARE EAGER TO WORK WITH YOU
AND CRAFT A THOUGHTFUL.
THE PROGRAM TO ASSURE THE
CONSUMERS -- SAFETY -- WHILE
PROMOTING SCIENCE BASED
REGULATIONS THAT PROTECT
CONFIDENTIAL BUSINESS
INFORMATION THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON COOKING YOURS ON
BEHALF OF THE FRAGRANCE CREATORS
ASSOCIATION ARE ASSOCIATION AS
THE PRINCIPAL TRADE ASSOCIATION
FOR THE FRAGRANCE INDUSTRY IN
THE UNITED STATES AND WE DO HAVE
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON SB.
FIVE SEVENTY FOUR OUR MEMBERS
CREATE AND MANUFACTURE THE
FRAGRANCES INCENSE THAT ARE USED
IN PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS AS
WELL AS HOME CARE PRODUCTS.
WE ALSO REPRESENT FRIEDEN
FRAGRANCE INGREDIENTS SUPPLIERS
AND FINISHED PRODUCT
MANUFACTURERS OF FRAGRANCE
CONTAINING PRODUCTS.
THE FRAGRANCE INDUSTRY FIRST AND
FOREMOST IS COMMITTED TO THE
SAFETY OF OUR PRODUCTS THE
INDUSTRY ESTABLISH THE RESEARCH
INSTITUTE A FRAGRANCE MATERIALS
IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY SIX THE
ORGANIZATION CONTINUALLY
EVALUATES THE FRAGRANCE PALETTE
INGREDIENTS AND PLACES
RESTRICTIONS ON INGREDIENTS AND
HAS BANNED INGREDIENTS ON THE
SCIENCE SUPPORTED THE NEED TO DO
SO.
EVEN IN THE ABSENCE OF A FORMAL
GOVERNMENT REQUIREMENTS.
WE ALSO TAKE THE INGREDIENT
COMMUNICATION OF THE MATERIALS
WE USE VERY SERIOUSLY WE ARE
RESPONDING TO THE INCREASED
DESIRE OF CONSUMERS TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT'S IN THE
PRODUCTS THE USE EVERY DAY.
OUR MEMBERS TRIVE TO HELP THEIR
CUSTOMERS WO ARE THE COSMETIC
MANUFACTURERS TO DELIVER THAT
INFORMATION TO THEIR CUSTOMERS
WHILE ALSO PRESERVING THE
UNIQUENESS OF THESE PROPRIETARY
BLENDS WHICH IS THE ARTISTRY OUR
MEMBERS HAVE BUILT THEIR
BUSINESS AROUND.
AND WE HOPE WE CAN ACHIEVE THAT
BOUNCE IN SB.
FIVE SEVENTY FOUR WE'D LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE AND THE SPONSORS FOR
THE AMENDMENTS WHICH DO ADDRESS
SOME OF OUR CONCERNS BUT QUICKLY
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE REMAINING
CONCERNS ON ABOUT -- WELL WE
APPRECIATE THE NEW TITLE OF THE
ACT AS WELL AS THE CHANGES MADE
TO CERTAIN ASPECTS IN THE INTENT
LANGUAGE.
OUT WE DO YOU HAVE REMAINING
CONCERNS WITH HOW SOME OF THE
INFORMATION IS DRAFTED -- AD
HOW.
IT IT PORTRAYS THE THE INDUSTRY
IN PARTICULAR IN THE MATERIALS
WE USE THEM ALL BE OFFERING A
SUGGESTION STOP COMMUNICATING
CONTEXTUALIZE THAT INFORMATION --
ON THE ALLERGENS -- AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE THE THRESHOLD FOR THE
FRAGRANCE ALLERGENS TO TRIGGER
DISCLOSURE UNDER THIS BILL.
THIS WAS THE COMPROMISE THAT WAS
REACHED IN SB TWO FIFTY EIGHT
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO MAINTAIN
THIS CONSISTENCY -- ACROSS ALL
PRODUCT LINES AND REGIONS OF THE
WORLD.
AND LASTLY I WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE REMOVAL IN
PARTICULAR OF THE A. L. EASY
ASTHMA JOURNALISTS AND THE
DANISH AND CONSTRUCTOR LIST
WHICH WERE PREVIOUSLY IN THE
BILL.
HOWEVER WE DO BELIEVE THAT ALL
THE DOZEN A LIST THAT.
MAY END UP IN THE FINAL VERSION
THE RELIABLE AUTHORITATIVE LESS
THAT ARE PEER REVIEWED SCIENCE
BASE AND AVAILABLE FOR A PUBLIC
COMMENT PROCESS.
SO WE APPRECIATE THE STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT PROCESS THE AUTHOR
HAS CONVENE AND WE ARE STRONGLY
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING A
CONSTRUCTIVE DIALOGUE ON HOW
BEST TO COMMUNICATE FRAGRANCE
INGREDIENTS AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
DON CAP CAME ACU CAP CAN
ASSOCIATES HERE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WILL IN
MY COMMENTS ARE WITH THOSE WHO
SPOKE AND AN OPPOSING THE CEMENT
A POSITION LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING AT THE AUTHOR AND
PROPONENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ADAM WRIGLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR FOR THE
IT DOMINANCE TAKEN BUT WE A DISH
ALSO HAVE ADDITIONAL CONCERN SO
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU.
THANKS THANK YOU.
OKAY SEEN OTHER.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OF CENTER GROVE
-- COULD YOU --
JUST -- ELABORATE A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT WHAT THEY DO -- THAT
IS MY UNDERSTANDING THESE --
INTERNATIONALLY -- RECOGNIZE
GROUP OF EXPERTS THAT ARE
EVALUATING THAT THIS AYE SOON
THE SAFETY AND EFFICACY OF SOME
OF THESE -- FRAGRANCES -- AND
THAT THE FDA HAS A ROLE AS WELL
COULD YOU JUST ELABORATE ON
THOSE.
TWO ARE CERTAINLY -- OF THE
RESEARCH INSTITUTE FRAGRANCE
MATERIALS OPERATES COMPREHENSIVE
REVIEW PROGRAM OF ALL COSMETIC --
ALL FRAGRANCE INGREDIENTS -- IT
IS A RESEARCH INSTITUTE WHICH
HAS -- A EXPERT TO A PANEL OF A
INTERNATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
EXPERTS -- THEY REPAIR REPORTS
I'M IN THE EXPERTS -- OPINE ON
THE SAFETY OF THESE -- ROOM --
REVIEWS MAY RESULT IN A
CONCLUSION THAT THE MATERIAL IS
SAFE OF THAT THE MATERIAL IS
SAFE WITH RESTRICTIONS OR THE
MATERIAL IS PROHIBITED -- THOUGH
WHOSE -- CONCLUSIONS ARE THEN
ADVANCED THROUGH THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION -- AND OUR OWN
OBLIGATION OF MEMBERSHIP -- FOR
MEMBERS WHICH REPRESENT OVER 90%
OF THE OF FRAGRANCES SOLDO
WORLDWIDE.
ALSO IT IS ON THE FLOOR TATE OF
A BODY OF WHICH CHAU PUBLISHES --
THEY REPORTS IN -- IN PUBLIC --
AND PEOPLE CAN REVIEW THEM ACT.
SO A SENSE OF THE R. F. M. IS
BEEN IN EXISTENCE -- I ASSUME
FOR MANY YEARS -- HAS THERE BEEN
ANY CASES OF ANY TOXICITIES --
THAT HAVE RESULTED IN MORBIDITY
OR MORTALITY ASSOCIATE WITH
THOSE FRAGRANCES THAT WERE
LISTED.
OF I AM UNAWARE THAT THERE ARE
ANY OKAY ARE YOU AWARE OF ANY
INSTANCES.
WHERE ANY COSMETICS OF BECAUSE
MORBIDITY OR MORTALITY
ASSOCIATED WITH?
BRING THE MEN I MEAN WHEN I WHEN
I WAS A PHARMACY SCHOOL THESE A
SAFE YOU CAN IF YOU CAN BRING
THAT IT'S IN YOUR BLOOD.
SO -- IN FACT IT KIND OF GOES --
TO ONE OF THE LEVELS OF RECOVER
OF RESEARCH -- SEE HERE -- FOR
THE CDC IT SAYS -- LET'S SEE
HERE [inaudible]
THAT.
IF IT'S A DESIGNATED W. IT'S
JUST THE TAXES IN THE BLOOD OF
THE YEAR AND IT DOESN'T -- SAY
THAT FITS TOXIC OR OR NON TOXIC
WE WE WE APPRECIATE THE REMOVAL
OF THE CDC LIST WHICH IS EXACTLY
THAT IT'S ASSEMBLY OF THE
PRESENCE.
OF THERE'S NO RISK ASSESSMENT
DONE THERE'S NO SUGGESTION BY
CDC THAT THE PRESENCE -- IS
EITHER AN INDICATION THAT THE
MATERIAL IS SAFE OR UNSAFE.
WELL WE ARE FULLY CONFIDENT THAT
THROUGH THE INDUSTRY
RESPONSIBILITY AS WELL AS THE
ASSESSMENT OF EXTERNAL OF REVIEW
BODIES INCLUDING.
OF THE REFORM OF GROUP FOR
FRAGRANCES AS WELL AS THE
COSMETIC INGREDIENT REVIEW FOR
COST MEDIC INGREDIENTS TAT THE
MATERIALS THAT ARE IN THE MARKET
ARE SAFE THEY ARE USED SAFELY.
OKAY AND THEN THE YOUNG LADY
THAT REPRESENT A LOT OF THE
FRAGRANCE COMPANIES CAN YOU TALK
ABOUT THE UPPER PART TERRY
SECRETS THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
THOSE FRAGRANCES AND IF.
THOSE INGREDIENTS THAT ARE
MAKING UP THOSE FRAGRANCES ARE --
PLACED ON BOTTLES FOR THE WORLD
TO SEE -- WHAT WOULD STOP ANYONE
IN THE WORLD FROM DUPLICATING
THOSE?
NON PATENTABLE -- INGREDIENTS
RIGHT SURE -- YEAH AS YOU
MENTIONED SO ARE -- FORMULATIONS
ARE NOT PATENTABLE -- AND SO
WHENEVER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HOW
TO COMMUNICATE INGREDIENTS WITH
CONSUMERS WERE REALLY ALSO
CONSIDERING THAT COMMUNICATION
IS GONNA GO TO OUR COMPETITORS
RIGHT AND SO ONCE YOU HAVE YOUR
SORT OF YOUR RECIPE OUT THERE IT
DOESN'T.
TAKE MUCH FOR THE SCIENTISTS
THAT WORK FOR MAYBE YOUR
COMPETITORS TO TO PIECE TOGETHER
EXACTLY YOU KNOW A LITTLE BIT OF
THIS AND A LOT OF THAT AND GET
VERY VERY CLOSE -- TO TO YOUR
PROPRIETARY BLEND SO THAT'S WHY
WE TAKE THESE -- CONSIDERATION
SO ERIOUSLY WE CERTAINLY WANT
CONSUMERS TO HAVE THE SAFETY
INFORMATION THAT THEY THAT THEY
NEED TO MAKE PURCHASING
DECISIONS INFORMED PURCHASING
DECISIONS BUT WE ALSO YOU KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF CONTACTS
IMPORTANT GOES ALONG WITH THAT.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY THE CHAIR MY COLLEAGUE
ASKED THEM THE QUESTION TAT I
WAS CONCERNED ABOUT WHICH IS THE
PATENTED ISSUE ONE THAT ON THE
FRAGRANCE LINE SO I APPRECIATE
THAT AND I HE ASKED MY QUESTION
THANK YOU -- MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- ENJOY
THIS IS A COMPLEX ISSUE THAT HAS
BEEN AROUND FOR A LONG TIME.
WE'VE TRIED TO ADDRESS IT BOTH
LEGISLATIVELY IN THE BUDGET --
AND WHAT'S CLEAR TO ME IS THAT
IT'S AN ISSUE THAT'S THAT'S NOT
GOING AWAY THAT THAT WE STILL
HAVE CLEAR CORPS DIVISIONS
WITHIN THE INDUSTRY -- THOSE IN
THE HEALTH.
OF TE PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY WORLD AND
SO I THINK A SIMPLE.
UP OR DOWN VOTE ON THIS BILL
ISN'T GOING TO RESOLVE IT.
I'M CURIOUS I HEARD IT WAS PUT I%
WASPLEASANTLY SURPRISED BY TWO
THINGS I THINK ABOUT DOES MY
HISTORY IN THE LEGISLATURE
LEGISLATURE HERE THIS ISSUE.
NUMBER ONE THE SHEER NEW NUMBER
OF COMPANIES IS A WHOLE NEW
INDUSTRY THAT'S EMERGING QUITE
FRANKLY THAT APPEARS TO WANT TO
GIVE CONSUMERS AN ALTERNATIVE --
AND SO THAT WAS DIFFERENT THAT
I'VE NOTED.
THE SECOND THING IS I TIP MY HAT
TO YOU FOR ENGAGING IN A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS AND THAT THE
OPPOSITE YOU COULD SAY THAT THEY
ARE ACTIVELY ENGAGED.
I DON'T KNOW THAT I WAS TRACKING
ALL OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT YOU
DIDN'T TAKE FROM MY HEARD WE'RE
DEALING WITH TERMINOLOGY I
APPRECIATE YOU DON'T WITH THE
TERM TOXIC USE THAT I GET THAT --
AND SO YOU REMOVE THE AISLES BUT
IF THE OPPOSITION -- TO THE
CHAIR COULD GIVE ME A HIGH LEVEL
KIND OF SUMMARY OF THE CORE
ISSUES.
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN ADDRESSED IN
THE AMENDMENTS -- BOTH THE
COMMITTEE SUGGESTED AND THE
CHAIR HAS AGREED TO TAKE.
I WANT TO GET A SENSE OF WHAT'S
THAT WHAT'S LEFT THE CURRENT GAS.
AND YOU KNOW AND I AND I'M AND
I'M ASKING THIS ISSUE LET ME ASK
YOU THESE QUESTIONS OF PUSHING
HARD ON THIS.
BECAUSE I GET BOTH SIDES I ALSO
REPRESENT A DISTRICT THAT HAS
LIKE SEVEN MANUFACTURERS -- SO
I'M.
I NEED TO HEAR THE DIFFERENCE
THANK YOU.
WELL I THINK THE CORE ISSUE FOR
US IS REALLY THE LISTS OF LISTS --
AND WHETHER THEY ARE RELEVANT TO
ASSESSING THE SAFETY OF OR THE
RELEVANT TO INFORMING CONSUMERS
OF IMPORTANT INFORMATION -- MANY
OF THESE LISTS WE WE THINK ARE
APPROPRIATE -- AND TO OUR
AUTHORITATIVE UP SOME OF THE
LIST HOWEVER ARE ARE WELL JUST
RESEARCH LISTS -- THERE --
INGREDIENTS THAT SOMEONE WOULD
LIKE TO TEST SOMETIME IN THE
FUTURE TO DETERMINE WHETHER THEY
DO IN FACT BECAUSE THOSE AFFECTS.
A ONE OF THE WITH THE A LIST
THAT -- WE APPRECIATE HAVING
BEEN REMOVED -- WAS A A LIST
THAT CAME OUT OF DENMARK --
WHICH DOESN'T TO FOLLOW THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION'S
THAT'S BEEN REMOVED RIGHT LET'S
TALK A LITTLE WE WE HAVE OTHER
LISTS -- IN THERE THAT WE WOULD
VERY MUCH LIKE TO DISCUSS
WHETHER THE TO IN FACT INFORM
CONSUMERS.
OF INFORMATION WHICH IS --
HELPFUL HELPFUL AND AND SENATOR
MITCHELL IF I MAY THE THE FIFTH
AMENDMENT THAT WE TOOK --
DELETED THREE OF A LIST IN ORDER
TO MAKE THESE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS CONSISTENT WITH THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR SB
TWO FIFTY EIGHT WHICH IS THE
CLEANING PRODUCT LIST.
SO WE DO NOT THINK THAT WE ARE
ASKING MORE OR LESS BUT JUST
ASKING THE INDUSTRY OVER THE
OTHER CORRECT.
THE I'LL JUST ADD A COUPLE
THINGS HIGH LEVEL -- SO SOME OF
THE OTHER AMENDMENTS WE'VE
REQUESTED INCLUDE A THE
DEFINITIONS AROUND WHAT IS A
COSMETIC AND TRYING TO A LINE
THOSE WITH THE FEDERAL
DEFINITIONS AND STATE
DEFINITIONS IN THE SHERMAN FOOD
AND DRUG BECAUSE MEDIC ACT --
ALSO -- THE IDEA OF WHETHER OVER
THE COUNTER COSMETICS ARE OVER --
ARE INCLUDED OR WE'D PREFER
THOSE NOT TO BE INCLUDED BECAUSE
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE THERE
ALREADY REGULATED BY THE F. YES.
YEAH THIRTY REGULAR BY THE FDA
THEY GO THROUGH A DRUG MONOGRAPH
PROCESS AGAIN -- TAKE A POLICY
TO IT MORE -- TECHNICALLY BUT
YES THEY ARE REGULATED
DIFFERENTLY -- ALSO THE IDEA OF
DISCLOSING TO THE STTE DATABASE
VERSUS DISCLOSING ON THE PRODUCT
MANUFACTURERS WEBSITE WE DO
BELIEVE A CONSUMER MORE
NATURALLY WOULD GO TO APART
MANUFACTURES WEBSITE RATHER THAN
THE SEA FOR COSMETIC PROGRAM --
SO THAT'S ALSO A REQUEST -- AND
THERE I'M SORRY THERE MIGHT BE A
COUPLE MORE BUT WE GIVE ME A
SENSE.
SENATOR LEVEL TWO WOULD YOU MIND
WE'RE KIND OF RESPONDING OR NO
NOT AT ALL NEEDS TO THE CHAIR IN
TERMS OF WHY THOSE PARTICULAR
MEMBERS WERE NOT ADDRESSED YES
SO IN REGARD TO THE STATE
DATABASE VERSES THE COMPANY
WEBSITE.
WE FEEL THAT A STATE DATA BUT
BASS IS A BETTER PLACE FOR
PEOPLE TO GO SO THEY CAN LOOK
AND GET MAYBE A MORE.
REALISTIC -- LOOK AT WHAT IS IN
THERE IF YOU'RE REFER TO A
COMPANY'S OWN.
WEBSITE -- IT'S A LITTLE BIT
LIKE THE FOX GUARDING THE HEN
HOUSE SO WE'RE JUST LOOKING FOR
MAYBE A MORE NEUTRAL THIRD PARTY.
I WOULD ALSO SAY I THINK THAT WE
TOOK.
A LOT OF AMENDMENTS IN THIS VERY
FIRST POLICY COMMITTEE -- WE DID
HAVE A ROBUST STAKEHOLDER
MEETING IT WAS THE FIRST I DON'T
THINK IT WILL BE THE LAST SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK TOGETHER WITH EVERYONE AS
EVERYONE HEARD ME SAY.
IF EVERYONE WALKS WITH A LITTLE
HAPPY OR A LITTLE UNHAPPY WE
HAVE DONE OUR JOB.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU AND ADDED SAUCE EIGHT
I WANT THANK YOU SIR LEYVA AND
FOR FOR WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND WE DID HAVE A
RIGOROUS DISCUSSION -- THE ACT I
APPRECIATE THAT -- THE OPPONENTS
STILL HAD SOME MORE THINGS BUT
YOU KNOW WE PRESENT WE TALKED
ABOUT WHERE TO LIST RESIDES IN
CERTAINLY COMPANIES ARE FREE TO
PUT ON THEIR OWN WEBSITES --
WHAT BUT I THINK THE IDEA THAT
BE IN A CENTRALIZED PLACE WE
ALSO TRY TO DISTINGUISH BETWEEN
TOXIC AND ALLERGENS RIGHT?
SELVES IT NO PEANUTS A LOT
PEOPLE ALLERGIC TO THOSE THAT IS
MAKING TOXIC BUT PEOPLE MAY NEED
TO KNOW IF YOU'RE ALLERGIC TO
PEANUTS SO YOU HAVE TO TO SO WE
TRY TO CLARIFY.
TOXINS VERSUS OTHER TYPES OF THE
STATE MAY HAVE A REACTION FOR
SPECIFIC HOURS SOME PEOPLE BUT
ISN'T.
BY DEFINITION A TOXIN PER SE SO
WE TRIED TO CREATE CERTAINLY
MANY STEPS IN CLARIFICATION I
UNDERSTAND -- THAT THE THAT
STAKEHOLDERS STILL HAVING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE PAST NOT
JUST FOR THIS BILL BUT HOPEFULLY
COME TO SOME.
BROADER AGREEMENT ABOUT --
DISCLOSURE AND AND BE SURE TO
TRANSPARENCY AND ALSO SAFETY FOR
PATIENTS AND CERTAINLY --
APPRECIATE -- YOU CENTER LEYVA
FOR FOR A FACILITY THAT
CONVERSATION THROUGH THIS BILL --
SO A YES SIR MITCHELL I'M SORRY
TO EXPAND THANK YOU -- SOMETHING
YOU SAID TRIGGERED FOR ME.
IF YOU HAVE THE VOTES TO GET THE
BILL OUT I'M GONNA LAY OFF.
ONLY BECAUSE I'VE BEEN A STRONG
PROPONENT OF FULL DISCLOSURE
INFORMED CONSENT.
ONLY GONNA LAY OFF ON BECAUSE I
WANT TO ENCOURAGE BECAUSE I
BECAUSE A I THINK ABOUT THE
PAST BILLS THAT I HAVE BEEN UP
ON I'M PRETTY SURE EVERY TIME.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THERE HAS BEEN
QUITE THE STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
THAT THERE APPEARS TO BE SO I
WANT TO APPLAUD YOU FOR THAT.
AS I'M GONNA LAY OFF AND I WOULD
LIKE TO BE KEPT KIND OF IN THE
LOOP ON YOUR STAKEHOLDER PROCESS --
AND SO I'M GONNA LAY OFF JUST TO
SIGNAL MY DESIRE TO CONTINUE TO
BE ENGAGED I OF COURSE RESERVE
THE RIGHT TO BE IN SUPPORT THE
BILL ON THE FLOOR IN AN ON ON
GOING BASIS.
I WON'T LET YOU LOSE IT TODAY
BECAUSE I DO THINK IT'S A PART
LIKE I SAID IT'S TOO COMPLEX AN
ISSUE FOR THE SIMPLY DO THIS
TODAY -- SO I'LL SEE IF YOU
DON'T HAVE A I WILL VOTE FOR IT
TO KEEP THE PROCESS GOING AND
THE DIALOGUE GOING -- IF AT ANY
POINT.
SICKLE TO PROCESS BREAKS DOWN
OFF THE ENGAGE WITH BOTH
PROPONENTS AND OPPONENTS AGAIN
THAT COULD HELP INFORM MY
DECISION TO GO FORWARD BASIS.
IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE TO
ME -- OFF FROM A HEALTH
STANDPOINT FOR FRIDAY
PERSPECTIVE -- AND SELECTED THE
ENGAGED IF YOU WOULD ALLOW ME TO
DO SO ABSOLUTELY CENTER MAKING
LIKE YOU VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE
THAT SALT TUNE INTO THE VOTE
COUNT BUT I'LL LAY OFF ON THE
FIRST PASS.
CENTER STONE.
THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER CHAIR --
INCHES ONE FINAL QUESTION FOR
FOR YOU ALL -- LET'S ASSUME THAT
THERE IS NOT GONNA BE ANY
FURTHER COOPERATION AND THIS
BILL IS GOING TO PASS -- WE'RE
DEALING WITH SOME PRODUCTS THAT --
ARE SOLD WORLDWIDE -- MAYBE SOME
THAT ARE NOT IN THE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF SALES BUT IN THE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF SALES -- LET'S TAKE SONOMA AS
AN EXAMPLE SHE KNOWS A BRAND --
I'M SURE THEY GUARD THEIR THEIR
FRAGRANCE -- FORMULAS VERY
CLOSELY TO THE BEST AND IF
THEY'RE REQUIRED TO REVEAL THEIR
INGREDIENTS WOULD IT BE.
SAFE TO ASSUME THAT THEY JUST
WILL NOT MARKETING CALIFORNIA
AND TAKE THEIR PRODUCTS
ELSEWHERE.
WELL I CERTAINLY YOU KNOW I
DON'T REPRESENTATION ALSO I
DON'T KNOW WHAT SORT OF DECISION
THEY WOULD HAVE BUT I DO THINK
IT.
IT CUT EVERYBODY WOULD HAVE TO
MAKE THAT DECISION FOR
THEMSELVES RIGHT IT CERTAINLY
EACH COMPANY IF THEY WERE FACED
WITH THAT.
THERE WOULD BE A MEETING --
CONSIDERING THEIR OPTIONS OKAY
AND AND THEN MAYBE TO THE AUTHOR
ASSUMING THAT WERE THE CASE AND
CHANNEL SAID WE'RE NOT GOING.
TO ALLOW OUR PRODUCT TO BE SOLD
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT COULD REVEAL
OUR FORMULAS FOR THOSE
FRAGRANCES -- WHAT'S TO STOP A
ONLINE COMPANY FROM BRING THOSE --
IN THE DON'T HAVE A WAREHOUSE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT CAN THEY CAN THEY
CAN SELL ONLINE JUST WITH YOUR
BILL EFFECTUATE ANYTHING THAT'S
BROUGHT IN THROUGH.
A SHIPPING APPARATUS.
I DON'T THINK IT WOULD US
SENATOR STONE AND YOU KNOW THIS
ISN'T ABOUT A COMPANY TELLING US
WHAT THEIR FORMULA IS BECAUSE
THE WAY YOU MIX INGREDIENTS
THAT'S HOW YOU GET A CERTAIN
SMELL OR A CERTAIN FLAVOR.
ALL THIS BILL IS ASKING BE DONE
IS THAT THESE THESE INGREDIENTS
THAT COULD BE WELL IN THE
INGREDIENT IS LISTED WE'RE NOT
TELLING HOW YOU MIX IT WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN THEY COME TOGETHER.
SO I THINK THERE'S A LITTLE
SUBTLE DIFFERENCE THERE IN
LISTING THE INGREDIENTS AND
ACTUALLY TALKING ABOUT WHAT THE
FORMULA IS TO MAKE THE PRODUCT --
I THINK IT'S SUBTLE BUT I THINK
IT'S THEREBUT NO THE BILL DOES
NOT DO ANYTHING -- WITH --
THINGS BEING SHIPPED IN IF I
ORDER IF I SITTING IN MY LIVING
ROOM AND I ORDER SOMETHING FROM
FRANCE OKAY.
SO SO I WORRY THAT -- IF THIS
BILL WERE TO PASS IN ITS PRESENT
FORM INGREDIENTS -- IT DOESN'T
TAKE. TOO MUCH CHAU
EXPERIMENTATION I'M GONNA
COMPANY PHARMACY I DO FRAGRANCES
ALL TIME WITH MY PRODUCTS AND
SOMETIMES IT MAKES A COUPLE TO
TRY TO GET CLOSE TO MAYBE
SOMETHING IS COMMERCIALLY
AVAILABLE -- WITHOUT COPYING OF
COURSE -- WHEN YOU'RE DOING YOUR
SPARE TIME SO I'M MORE?
I'M WORRYING THAT WE COULD BE
HURTING I'M MORE INTO WE COULD
BE HEARD IN SOME CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS -- IF THIS BILL IS
MISCONSTRUED AND AND PASSED IN A
FORM THAT WOULD PROHIBIT THEM
FROM KERN PRODUCTS SO I DID
JERRY MY CONCERNS I HOPE YOU
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPONENTS AS WE ALWAYS DO.
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU
SENATOR STONE OKAY ARE THERE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS.
IS THERE A MOTION.
AS COULD SOMEONE DO A COURTESY
MOTION ALL RIGHT I WILL DO THANK
YOU CENTER MITCHELL WORKERS THE
MOTION -- AND CLOSE.
YES -- AND SO US AS FAIRLY BUT
YOU YOU MAY CLOSE AND THAT IS MY
COMMENT THAT -- I NOW KNOW WHO
TO TALK TO I WANT A GIFT FROM MY
WIFE'S [inaudible] TO SHEA.
PLEASE ENTER A THAT IS QUITE
ALRIGHT THANK YOU TO US SENATOR
PAN MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I WOULD
JUST SAY TO OUR OUR PHARMACY
CHEMIST -- MY DAUGHTER'S MARRIED
TO A CHEMIST ALSO -- AND I WOULD
JUST SAY Y'ALL ARE SMARTER THAN
MOST OF US OKAY NOT EVERYONE CAN
MIX INGREDIENTS TOGETHER AND
MAKE IT TURN INTO SOMETHING THAT
DOESN'T EXPLODE.
SO THIS BILL REALLY IS ABOUT I
NEED TO KNOW IT'S ABOUT WANTING
TO KNOW WHAT I PUT ON MY BODY IN
MY BODY ON MY HAIR.
AND I THINK THAT AS A SOCIETY
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO GET BETTER I
THINK THAT THINGS HAVE CHANGED
AND PEOPLE AT AS AN IS EXHIBITED
BY COMPANIES NOW THAT.
THAT SHOW THESE PRODUCTS AS YOU
HEARD FROM SO MANY OF THE
SUPPORTERS AND AS SENATOR
MITCHELL SAID.
THERE ARE SO MANY COMPANIES THAT
SAY YOU KNOW WHAT PEOPLE WANT TO
KNOW IT DOESN'T MEAN I'M NOT
GOING TO BUY IT I JUST WANT TO
KNOW I WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S IN MY
FAVORITE LIP GLOSS THAT I USE
EVERY DAY.
THIS BILL DOES NOT BAN ANY
INGREDIENTS THIS BILL DOES NOT
REQUIRE ANY LABELING ALL IT DOES
IS SAY TELLS WHAT'S ON THERE SO
I AS A CONSUMER CAN GO ON TO THE
WEB ON TO THE STATE'S WEBSITE.
LOOK AT THE LIST AND GET AN IDEA
OF WHAT I WANT TO PUT ON MY BODY
OR IN MY BODY THIS IS NOT
CHANGED THE WAY COMPANIES TO
BUSINESS THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO LIST THEIR GRADIENTS BUT THAT
DOES NOT CHANGE THE WAY THEY DO
BUSINESS.
WE WILL ABSOLUTELY KEEP WORKING
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS THAT'S
WHAT WE TRY TO DO ON TEAM LEYVA
BUT THIS IS REALLY JUST ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT WE KNOW AS WE
KNOW WHAT WE'RE USING TO CLEAN
OUR FLOORS WERE USING TO CLEAN
OUR WINDOWS WE KNOW WHAT'S IN
THOSE PRODUCTS.
EVERYONE HAS A RIGHT TO KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE PUTTING ON OUR IN
THEIR BODY SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
I THANK YOU SIR LEYVA -- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY IT'S BEEN
THAT SECOND IT AS A COURTESY --
MOTION BY SENATOR MITCHELL --
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN HI AND I A STONE.
STONE NO DORADO GROVE GROVE
KNOWN FURTADO.
LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
AUTHORIZES. ONE VOTE ON THIS
RIGHT NOW THE TORONTO.
ON THE THE CHEMICAL INGREDIENTS
ONE SB FRAGRANCE.
FIVE SEVENTY FOUR OKAY SHE'S
INCOME [inaudible]
TORONTO IS [inaudible]
I OKAY SO THAT BILLS CURRENTLY
THREE TO HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
APPARATE SAVINGS IF YOU'RE
THINKING OF RESEARCH ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU -- CENTER MORE LIKE
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
SO WE'LL TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN SB.
SIX FORTY BUT SIR MORE LACK
[inaudible] NINE AGAIN THANK
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
JUST WANNA.
BE SENSITIVE TO ALL THE PEOPLE
LEAVING THE ROOM BUT ON THIS
BILL MR I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
YOUR COUNSEL AND GUIDANCE --
COLLEAGUES SOME PEOPLE JUST.
JUST -- CANNOT TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES.
AND WE'RE LEAVING THEM TO THE
ELEMENTS OUT ON OUR STREETS
THAT'S OUR CURRENT SOLUTION AND
AND THAT'S INHUMANE.
AND IT'S UNCONSCIONABLE.
BRING THEM INTO A SUPERVISOR
ENVIRONMENT IS ALSO EXPENSIVE.
MENTALLY ILL INDIVIDUALS ON OUR
STREETS HAVE BEEN A TRAGIC
CONSEQUENCE OF THE SHORTCOMINGS
OF THE LAND SHERMAN PETROUS
SHORT ACT.
I DON'T HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS I
DO KNOW THAT SB SIX FORTY
PROVIDES AN OBVIOUS ONE AND I'M
NOT.
THE FIRST TO PROPOSE IT.
THE BIG QUESTION IS WHETHER OUR
CURRENT PRIVATE SECTOR HOSPITAL
PARTNERS ARE READY FOR A BETTER
DEFINITION OF GRAVELY DISABLED.
AND THE POTENTIAL OF
CONSERVATORSHIP LANDING IN THEIR
HALLS AND ROOMS.
OR NEW FACILITIES DESIGNED FOR
THIS MEDICAL NICHE.
MISTER CHAIR THANKS FOR HOLDING
AN APPRECIATION FOR THIS
JUXTAPOSITION.
OF DOING WHAT'S RIGHT AND DOING
WHAT'S FEASIBLE UNDER THE
CURRENT PARADIGM.
THIS PAST SUNDAY THE SACRAMENTO
BEE.
HAD AN EDITORIAL THAT WAS --
SUBMISSION IS PROVIDED BY A
NANCY WEAVER TEICHER TO ATTACK.
WITH THE TITLE FOR MENTALLY ILL
HOMELESS PEOPLE ESCAPING LIFE ON
STREETS CAN BE HARD.
THE PEACE DETAILS THE DIFFICULTY
OF FINDING SANDY A ROOM.
ON APRIL SECOND KAISER ANNOUNCED
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL SEE MASSIVE
SURGE OF HOMES PATIENTS BY
PHILIP BREEZE.
COMING FROM ORANGE COUNTY.
WE HAVE A UNIQUE MODEL IF A
HOMELESS PERSON IS RELEASED FROM
HOSPITAL WE HAVE A NON PROFIT BY
THE NAME OF ELIMINATION
FOUNDATION WHICH PROVIDES
RECUPERATIVE.
ROOMS AND BEDS AND THEN THEY
LOCATE SUPPORT OF HOUSING AND
THEN THEY ARE FOLLOWED BY PERMIT
HOW TO HOUSING WE HAVE A
PIPELINE.
BUT THIS PIPELINE PASSED TO BE
REPLICATED THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
CONSEQUENTLY THERE REACH THE
INTENDED GOAL IS TO DO IT WAS
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES I'M
PROPOSING A FEW.
ITEMS NUMBER ONE THAT.
LETTERMAN IS BROKEN EVEN THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE HAS
REQUESTED THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT COMMITTEE FOR AN AUDIT OF
THE ACTS IMPLEMENTATION. TO THAT
INSTITUTIONALIZING CERTAIN.
EXCUSE ME CERTAIN CLINICAL YOU.
AUTHORIZED INDIVIDUALS IS THE
COMPASSIONATE AND APPROPRIATE
APPROACH TO PURSUE INVOLUNTARY
HOLDS CAN BE THE MOST YOU MAIN
SOLUTION. THREE THAT LAURA'S LAW
IS BEING ENACTED IN MANY
COUNTIES AFTER ORANGE COUNTY IN
SB FIVE EIGHTY FIVE BY SENATOR
STEINBERG BACK IN.
TWENTY THIRTEEN PROVIDED A CREW
CRITICAL FUNDING SOURCE AND
DIRECTION BUT IT IS ONLY A
SEGMENT.
AND NOT ALL.
OF THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES ARE
USING LARA WALKED. FOR THAT
LOWERS Là MAY BE A GOOD
STARTING PLATFORM FOR DEALING
WITH THE GRAVELY DISABLED AS IT
RELATES TO DEALING WITH HIS ME
FOR MY THROAT. FOR DISABLED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER.
MITCHELL.
THING OUT OF ITS ALLERGIES ARE
CALLED EVERY MARCH SOMETHING
HAPPENS APPEARED.
THE FRAGRANCES.
OKAY I'LL TRY AND GET BACK ON
TRACK THE THAT THAT LOWERS Là
MAY BE A GOOD STARTING PLATFORM --
FOR DEALING WITH THE THE COURT
SYSTEM AND AND DEALING WITH
THOSE THAT ARE.
CONSIDERED GRAVELY DISABLED THAT
THE MAIL HELP FIGHT THAT THE
MIDDLE HEALTH SERVICES ACT WOULD
BE A GOOD FUNDING SOURCE TO
ADDRESS THIS CRITICAL NEED. SIX
THAT NO PLACE LIKE HOME IS ALSO
A COMPONENT IN THE HOUSING FOR
MENTALLY ILL HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS. SEVEN THAT THAT MY
JOURNEY IN ADDRESSING A
PROVIDING SOLUTIONS FOR MENTALLY
ILL HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS.
CONFIRM JUST HOW COMPLEX AND
FRIED OUR LAWS ARE IN ADDRESSING
THE LEAST IN OUR SOCIETY.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE THE WHERE
WITH ALL. TO DO SOMETHING BETTER
THAN ABANDONING MENTALLY ILL
PERSONS WHO ARE UNABLE TO MAKE
THE APPROPRIATE DECISIONS. TO
THE MAINSTREAM OUT ON THE
STREETS.
SB SIX FORTY IS A STEP IN THE
PROCESS THAT SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED NOW AND I HAVE TO
WITNESSES.
LISA ASHLEY AND DIANE XIN STOCK.
OKAY THANK YOU WELCOME AND THANK
CEREMONIAL ACCESS SIX MINUTES
TOTAL BETWEEN TO VIEW BACKS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- CHAIRMAN PAN AND
SENATORS OF THE HEALTH COMMITTEE.
I AM HERE IN SUPPORT OF SIX
FORTY THE MENTAL HEALTH BILL
REGARDING -- GRAVELY DISABLED MY
NAME IS LISA ASHLEY I'M A
PEDIATRIC NURSE PRACTITIONER.
BUT I'M HERE BECAUSE MY SON IS
PAT AS A IS PARANOID
SCHIZOPHRENIC.
HE HAS BEEN FOR TEN YEARS.
HE'S BEEN HOSPITALIZED FIVE
TIMES NOT BECAUSE HE IS VIOLENT
NOR IS HE A DANGER TO HIMSELF OR
OTHERS.
BECAUSE HE IS GRAVELY DISABLED.
HE HAS ALSO IN ADDITION TO
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS AND A
SOME NOKIA.
WHICH MEANS HIS DISEASE DOES NOT
ALLOW HIM TO KNOW.
THAT HE IS ILL AND IN NEED OF
MEDICATION AND TREATMENT.
HE IS ON NO MEDICATIONS RIGHT
NOW.
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T UNDERSTAND.
BUT HE'S ILL.
HE HAS BEEN HOMELESS.
IN SPITE OF HAVING SSI.
A DESIGNATED PAY E..
MEDI CAL.
IN ADDITION TO MY PRIVATE
INSURANCE.
HE REFUSES ALL CARE.
THE REASON I TELL YOU THIS IS TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THE GRAVELY
DISABLED NEEDS AS IT IS DEFINED
NOW UNDER THE LPS ACT.
DOES NOT SERVE INDIVIDUALS LIKE
MY SON WHO NEEDS TO BE FIFTY ONE
FIFTY TO BE EVALUATED FOR
FURTHER CARE AND TREATMENT.
I HAVE HAD THE POLICE AT MY HOME
A NUMBER OF TIMES TO HAVE HIM
TAKEN TO THE HOSPITAL.
ONLY TO HAVE THEM OFTEN SAY TO
ME HE DOESN'T MEET CRITERIA.
THEY BASE MOST OF THAT ON THE
FACT THAT HE'S NOT VIOLENT.
AND HE IS NOT -- AND NOT HURTING
OTHER PEOPLE OR IN OR HIMSELF.
HIS LAST HOSPITALIZATION UNDER
GRAVELY DISABLED WAS BECAUSE IN
ADDITION TO HIS DISSOLUTION HIS
DELUSIONS.
HE URINATED IN FRONT OF THE
OFFICERS AND THEY FINALLY TOOK
HIM INTO THE HOSPITAL WHERE HE
REMAINED FOR TWO WEEKS.
HAND CUFFED INPUT IN THE POLICE
CAR.
THIS IS NOT RIGHT PEOPLE WHO ARE
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS BECAUSE
THEY HAVE BEEN NEUROLOGIC BRAIN
DISEASE WHICH CAUSES THEM NOT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY ARE ILL AND
NEED OF HELP [inaudible]
NEED US.
EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM. TO STEP
IN AND HELP THEM GET THE HELP
THEY NEED.
THE LPS NEEDS TO BE REFORMED AND
BROUGHT UP TO DATE WITH THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT WE NOW HAVE ABOUT
THE GRAVELY DISABLED.
DISABLED.
FAMILY MEMBERS CAN GET THEIR
RELATIVES HELP.
IT OUGHT NOT TO TAKE.
THE EMOTIONAL PAIN AND TRAUMA
FOR FAMILIES TO GO THROUGH TO
GET THEIR LOVED ONES HELP.
WE NEED THE COMMUNITY SUPPORT
SERVICES TO HELP KEEP THEM IN
CARE.
AND WE NEED TO HAVE THESE
SERVICES ACCOUNTABLE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON A MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MISTER CHAIR MY NAME
IS DIANE XIN STOCK FROM
ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA -- I'VE
BEEN BEFORE YOU BEFORE LAST YEAR
ON THIS THE SIMILAR ISSUE -- I
WANTED TO SHARE WITH YOU A
LITTLE BIT THAT THE CATALYST FOR
THIS BILL ACTUALLY STARTED WITH
MYSELF AND TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
MY SON HAD BEEN CONSERVING HAD
MET THE CRITERIA FOR GRAVELY
DISABLED FOR SEVEN YEARS AND FOR
REASONS I COULDN'T UNDERSTAND
THE COUNTY DECIDED TO DROP.
THE CONSERVATORSHIP FOUR FOUR IN
THOSE FOUR YEARS MY SON SPIRALED
OUT OF CONTROL AND WAS HOMELESS
AND IN AND OUT OF THE JAILS AND
HOSPITALS.
I BEG THE COUNTY FOR HALL BUT
THEY PROVIDED TO ME THEIR
INTERPRETATION OF THE GRAVELY
DISABLED DEFINITION.
AND THEY SAID THINGS LIKE IF
THAN INDIVIDUALS UNABLE TO PER --
ADEQUATELY CONSUME FOOD AND
WATER WHILE ON THE UNIT MEANING
IN THE HOSPITAL THEY DIDN'T MEET
CRITERIA I ARGUED THAT DOESN'T.
TALK TO THE ISSUE OF PROVIDING
FOR ONE'S OWN.
APPARENTLY STEALING FOOD WHICH
MY SON FREQUENTLY DID OR DIGGING
IT OUT OF A DUMPSTER IS
ACCEPTABLE.
THE MENTION TO THE PUBLIC NUDITY
OR INADVERTENT EXHIBITIONISM
WOULD BECAUSE OF A DEFINING FOR
GRAVELY DISABLED.
BUT WEARING RIPPED CLOTHES
CLOTHING SOAKED IN URINE IS OKAY --
THEY SAID THAT OF FOR PERSON IS
UNABLE TO MAINTAIN ADEQUATE
SHELTER IN THE COMMUNITY DUE TO
BEHAVIORS AND SYMPTOMS OF A
MENTAL ILLNESS THEY WOULD THEN
MEET.
THE CRITERIA BUT LIVING IN A
CARDBOARD BOXES OKAY.
I WASN'T SURE WHAT TO DO.
I KNOW THAT THIS WAS NOT THE
INTENTION OF THE LAW SO I TURNED
TO MY LEGISLATOR OF MY A
LEGISLATOR -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
TEN AND TWO YEARS AGO HAS THEN
ALLEGE DIRECTOR.
BORROWED A BILL SUBMITTED IT WE
FELT HE GOT IT WRONG HE SIMPLY
ADDED THE WORDS MEDICAL CARE
AFTER FOOD CLOTHING AND SHELTER
AND DIDN'T REALLY CHANGE MUCH
ELSE TO THE DEFINITION.
WE FELT IT WAS WRONG AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TENDED NOT
PERCENT BILL FORWARD BUT IT DID
GET THE ATTENTION OF LA COUNTY.
AND LAST YEAR LA COUNTY THEN --
WORKED WITH FAMILY MEMBERS
SANTIAGO AND WE DEVELOPED AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE IF YOU
REMEMBER I WAS HERE LAST YEAR IN
SUPPORT OF AB -- NINETEEN
SEVENTY ONE THAT FAILED BECAUSE
EVERYONE GOT REALLY HYPER
FOCUSED ON WHAT IS THE
DEFINITION OF MEDICAL CARE.
AND THEY DETERMINED THAT AN
INDIVIDUAL HAD TO BE WITHIN SIX
MONTHS OF DIE OFF BEFORE THEY
WOULD REACH OUT AND HELP THEM OR
FIND AN ELIGIBLE UNDER THIS LAW.
SO THE BILL DIED THEN -- WE
FORGOT AT THAT POINT TO DEFINE
WHAT IS FOOD CLOTHING AND
SHELTER.
SO.
IN MY OPINION I WANT TO SHARE
WHY I THINK THAT SB SIX FORTY IS
AN IMPROVEMENT OVER AB --
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE FOR
STARTERS ADDING ANOTHER
QUALIFIER AT THE END OF FOOD
CLOTHING AND SHELTER SUCH AS
MEDICAL CARE OR ANY OTHER
QUALIFIER YOU MIGHT PUT DOESN'T.
AFFECT THE THE CHANGE THAT WE
ARE LOOKING -- FOR AB SIX SB SIX
FORTY ADDRESSES ADDRESSES WITH
MANAGEMENT PATTERSON SHORT
INTENDED DECADES AGO WHICH WAS
TO ADDRESS IN INDIVIDUALS
CAPACITY TO MAKE A DECISION.
IT DOESN'T CHANGE THE LAW IT
CLARIFIES IT AND ANYBODY.
WHO IS IN SUPPORT?
OR IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL IS
ESSENTIALLY STATING THAT IT'S
OKAY TO CONTINUE TO CRIMINALIZE
AND INCARCERATE WORK NOR PEOPLE
ON THE STREETS WITH AN ILLNESS
WE DON'T DO THAT WITH ANY OTHER
ILLNESS OR ANY OTHER SEGMENT OF
THE POPULATION.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANKS VERY
MUCH OTHER WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
THE BACK MICROPHONE A NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITIONS BUT
SHOULD BE SUPPORT AT THIS POINT
ACT.
HI MY NAME'S DAVID BAIN AYE WITH
MOMMY SACRAMENTO AND I'M SOMEONE
WHO LOSES TO BRAIN DISORDERS AND
I SUPPORT THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
PROSECUTORS HERE ON BEHALF OF
CITY OF SANTA MONICA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.%
CASEY NO OTHER.
SO IT'S GOING TO MAKE FUN OF
ELAINE PAN FOR LONDON -- BUT I
MEAN A COUNTY AND WE I MEAN --
CESSATION FOR CHINESE AND TENNIS
COMMUNITIES THAT WE SUPPORT THIS
FOR YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
CRISTINA ONE ELSE AT THE
MICROPHONE -- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
IF YOU CAN PLEASE A A MOVED
ASIDE SO THEY CAN SET.
THEIR EITHER THAT COR SIDE OR
THAT SIDE.
YEAH THAT'S FINE.
JUST NEED TO MAKE ROOM.
FOR COUPLE SEATS THERE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY SO AT THE WENT OVER A
LITTLE SO GIVE ELEVEN EXTRA TIME
IF YOU NEED IT BUT IF YOU DON'T
NEED IT DID I HAVE TO TAKE IT.
THANK YOU WELL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR KERR CHILD DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA -- WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL -- FOR MANY
OF THE SAME REASONS WE'VE BEEN
OPPOSED AND AND VARIOUS EFFORTS
THAT HAVE ATTEMPTED TO EXPAND
CONSERVATORSHIP WITHOUT ASSURING
THAT THERE ARE SERVICES AND
SUPPORT OF HOUSING TECH COMPANY --
THOSE EXPANDED CONSERVATORSHIP.
THIS BILL WAS REALLY I THINK IS
PREMISED ON THE ASSUMPTION THAT
THE CURRENT DEFINITION OF
GRAVELY DISABLED LACKS CLARITY.
BUT BUT WHAT IT DOES IS
SUBSTITUTES A NUMBER OF TERMS --
IN THERE WITHIN THE DEFINITION
OF GRAVELY DISABLED -- THAT I
THINK ARE.
ACTUALLY OVERLY BROAD AND MORE
CONFUSING TO THOSE WHO ON THE
STREET WHO WOULD BE LOOKING AT
ATTEMPTING TO APPLY THE
DEFINITION OF GRAVELY DISABLED.
SO YOU HAVE -- A NUMBER IN TERMS
IN THERE FOR EXAMPLE IN CAPABLE
OF MAKING INFORMED DECISIONS --
SIGNIFICANT PSYCHIATRIC
DEGRADATION -- EVEN ONE THAT'S
MISMANAGEMENT OF HIS OR HER
ESSENTIAL NEEDS THE COULD RESULT
IN BODILY HARM -- ALL I THINK
WHICH ARE OVERLY BROAD THIS IS A
DEFINITION THAT'S BEEN BROUGHT
IN FROM ANOTHER STATE THE
IMPORTANT POINT I THINK IS.
IT WITHIN LPS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT'S A DECADES OLD --
STATUTE WE'VE DEALT WITH THE
DEFINITION OF GRAVELY DISABLED
FOR MANY MANY YEARS IT'S BEEN
INTERPRETED BY THE COURTS OVER
AND OVER IT'S INTERPRETED BY --
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND SIMPLY
SUBSTITUTING ANOTHER DEFINITION
ANOTHER SET OF WORDS DOESN'T DO
WHAT I THINK -- THE THE
PROPONENTS OF THE BILL WOULD
HOPE THAT IT WOULD WOULD DO --
SO WE WOULD SGGEST.
THAT IN ADDITION TO THAT THE LPS
IS REALLY A COMPLEX BALLOTS IT'S
A COMPLEX BALANCE TO INSURE THAT
WE'RE PROTECTING INDIVIDUALS --
FROM DANGER TO THEMSELVES IN
DANGER TO OTHERS WHILE-RESPECTING THE AUTONOMY AND
RIGHTS OF OF INDIVIDUALS NOT TO
BE HELD AGAINST -- AGAINST THEIR
WILL AND IT'S IT'S NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO LOOK AT JUST ONE
LITTLE PIECE OF LPS WITHOUT
UNDERSTANDING THE ENTIRE BREADTH
OF THIS STATUTE.
AND THE BALANCE THAT IT HAS TO
MAKE IN PROTECTING RIGHTS
AGAINST PROTECTING --
INDIVIDUALS.
SO FOR THAT REASON.
MISTER CHAIR WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL UNDER NO VOTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN FLORI ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY WE'RE IN OPPOSITION
FOR MANY OF THE SAME REASONS
THAT DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IS AND IN ADDITION WE
ALSO BELIEVE THAT.
A LOT OF THE ISSUES THAT WERE
SEEN WITH CONSERVATORSHIP SIR
DUE TO THE LACK OF UPSTREAM
SERVICES THAT NEED TO BE
PROVIDED WE HAVE CONTINUED
FAILINGS OF PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING -- CONTINUED FAILINGS TO
PROVIDE THE FULL SENSE OF
WRAPAROUND SERVICES AN INTENSIVE
CASE MANAGEMENT TO INDIVIDUALS
NEED TO GET THEM BACK OFF THE
STREET AND INTO APPROPRIATE
HOUSING.
THANK YOU.
YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION CHECK BACK FOR HIS
RETURN MEMBERS MARK WINDOWS WITH
US HERE YOU CALIFORNIA I JUST
LIKE TO LINE MY COMMENTS I MADE
BY DRC THANK YOU [inaudible]
HE RESEARCHER MEMBERS ALICE
HAWTHORNE WITH A CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION --
WE APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION
IT'S AN IMPORTANT ISSUE TO OUR
MEMBERS -- AND WE THINK THE
MEMBER FOR BRINGING IT FOR TO
HAVE IT ON OUR CONCERN IS THAT --
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE BROADER
REFORMS TO THE LPS ACT BEFORE
MAKING A CHANGE LIKE THIS BUT IS
THE TOP PRIORITY FOR MEMBERS TO
ADDRESS -- THIS ISSUE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING A CONVERSATION
WITH THE SENATOR GOING FORWARD
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEN ON US AT THE MICROPHONE A
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
CENTER MITCHELL.
IS THE HEAD A MORE LOT I WAS IN
COMMITTEE OUT LAST YEAR WHEN WE
DEBATED AND AGREED ON SOME
AMENDMENTS ON AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY ONE THERE WAS AN
EXPECTATION THAT THAT LOOKS AND
CONTINUED WORK WOULD BE DONE --
I UNDERSTAND THAT BILL WAS NOT
AMENDED IN THE ADDITIONAL
COMMITTEES IT WAS HEARD IN AND
THEN IT.
IT DIED IN AN ACTIVE FILE -- YOU
KNOW I I WOULD JUST HAVE TO SAY
THAT THAT I HAVE TO WITH WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT DISAGREE WITH
ONE COMMENT YOU MAY.
AND THAT'S THE NOTION THAT
LANCEMENT PATRICK SHORT ACT IS
BROKEN.
AND I THINK THAT THAT WHILE WE
DO HAVE A OVERWHELMING -- ISSUE
IMPACTING ALL OF US ACROSS THE
STATE.
ON INTO REPRESENTED BY.
THE TWO WOMEN HERE WHO TALK
ABOUT THEIR OWN FAMILY MEMBERS.
BUT TO DENY THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
THAT ACTED AS FIFTY PLUS YEAR
NOW HISTORY RECOGNIZING THE
CULTURE WITHIN WHICH IT WAS
ESTABLISHED AND HOW FAR WE'VE
COME.
I JUST DON'T THINK IT'S FAIR TO
CAN SAY THAT IT'S BROKEN --
SHOULD IT.
REQUIRE -- AID A NEW LOOK.
PERHAPS -- I THINK I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT A PIECEMEAL
APPROACH. TO RE OPENING -- AT
ISSUE IS SENSITIVE AS HOW WE
ALLOW -- FOR THE PROTECTION OF
INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS FOR THOSE WITH
SEVERE DISABILITIES AVAIL
ILLNESS I WOULD ALSO CHALLENGE
THE OPPOSITION AS I DID LAST
YEAR -- THAT WE CAN'T DIGGER
HILLS IN THE SAND -- BASED ON
THAT FIFTY YEAR AGO HISTORY AND
MAKE AN ASSUMPTION THAT ANY
CONVERSATION ABOUT.
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE ACT'S MEANS
THAT WE OPEN THE FLOOD DOORS AND
WE TRAVEL BACK IN TIME I DON'T
BELIEVE WE'RE THERE EITHER.
BUT THE YEARS I'VE SPENT ON SUB
ONE IN SUB -- THREE IN DEALING
WITH -- FROM A FINANCE
PERSPECTIVE WAYS IN WHICH WE
SUPPORT -- THE SEVERELY DISABLED
AND THOSE SUFFERING FROM MENTAL
ILLNESS THROUGH THE LANCEMENT
PICTURE SHORT ACT YOU KNOW
SUGGESTS TO ME THAT THAT MY
PREFERENCE WOULD BE AS YOU SAID.
BECAUSE THE DEALER AUDIT HAS
BEEN COMMISSIONED.
THAT WE WAIT AND SEE.
I WANT TO BE VERY CURIOUS TO SEE
WHAT THE AUDIT AND FALLS IF IT
PRESENTS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO LOOK MORE BROADLY AT THE ACT --
BRINGING ALL OF THE VESTED
INTERESTS TO THE TABLE AND
HAVING A FAIR TWENTY NINETEEN
RELEVANT CONVERSATION.
NOT TO SUGGEST THAT WE OPEN THE
FLOODGATES TO TRAVEL BACK IN
TIME BUT ALSO TO ACKNOWLEDGE
VERY REAL ISSUES WE ARE
CONFRONTING.
IN OUR OWN HOMES AND COMMUNITIES
AND STREETS TODAY.
SO FOR ME TODAY WILL BE A NO --
BECAUSE I THINK THAT WE'RE
PUTTING THE CART BEFORE THE
HORSE J.LACK OF BEEN COMMISSION
AN AUDIT IS FORTHCOMING WE ARE
IN THE FIRST CALENDAR YEAR FOR
TWO YEAR SESSION.
I THINK THAT THERE IS TIME TO
SEE WHAT THE I'D IT WILL BRING
FORWARD AND THIS TIME FOR THE
LEGISLATURE.
WILL HAVE WOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO STEP UP AND TAKE
ACTION ACCORDINGLY.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU A CENTER
MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ON I WANT
TO THANK SENATOR MITCHELL.
FOR HER COMMENTS IN IN SATAN
AISLEYNE MONEY VIEWS SIMILARLY
BUT I DO WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR. FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND FOR THE FAMILIES WHO
ARE HERE TODAY -- I KNOW THE
PLIGHT OF FAMILIES DEALING WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS -- I KNOW THE
FRUSTRATION OF A SYSTEM THAT IS
TOO OFTEN ON RESPONSE OVER
UNABLE TO RESPOND OR RESPOND IN
THE WRONG WAY BY.
CRIMINALIZING CONDUCT.
THAT IS THE RESULT OF THE
ILLNESS -- SO I AM ALSO GOING TO
CAST A NOBLE TODAY BUT I THINK
[inaudible]
THE THE LIFELINE HERE THE HOPE
IS THAT WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
VERY THOROUGH -- LEGISLATIVE
AUDITOR'S REPORT -- THAT WILL
INFORM HOW WE MIGHT BEST GO
FORWARD IN CRAFTING REMEDIES --
FOR FAMILIES FOR INDIVIDUALS FOR
COMMUNITIES.
I WANT TO THINK THOSE WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS IN WESTERN
CENTER YES -- FOR FOR YOUR
CONTINUED WORK ON THESE EFFORTS
TO AND I I JUST WANT THE
FAMILIES TO KNOW THAT.
THE NO VOTE TODAY IS NOT.
THE VOTE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
CHALLENGE THE PLATE IN THE PAIN
AND SUFFERING IN ENDING IT
SHARED BY EVERYBODY.
UP HERE ON THIS DíAS IN WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
SENATOR.
TO FINDING THE PATHWAY THAT THEY
CAN WORK SELF THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
THANK YOU SENATOR ASA.
YES I ALSO WANT TO THANK CENTER --
MITCHELL FOR FRAME IN THIS.
IN THE MOST POSITIVE AND
CONSTRUCTIVE WAY POSSIBLE I
WOULD ADD AND I'M NOT HERE THE
NUMBER OF YEARS THAT.
OTHERS HAVE ARE.
OR HAVE BEEN BUT IT SEEMS TO ME
IN THE SHORT TIME I'VE BEEN HERE
THERE'S ENORMOUS CONCERN AND
COMMITMENT TO PUT RE START
PUTTING THE RESOURCES.
THAT ARE NEEDED TO ADDRESS
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDED TO ADDRESS
A LOT OF OTHER ISSUES THAT LEAD --
PEOPLE. TO END UP ON THE STREET
AND NOT KNOW HOW TO TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES NOT ABLE TO TAKE CARE
OF THEMSELVES SO.
I THINK THAT'S ANOTHER ELEMENT
THAT SHOULD BE TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT AS FAR AS WHEN WE GO WE
GO FORWARD BUT I TO COMMIT.
TO PUSHING FOR RESOLUTION WHICH
IS DUE. TO ARE WE PROVIDING.
THE SERVICES THAT ARE NEEDED AND
IF WE'RE NOT THERE WE'VE GOT TO
PUT MUCH MUCH MORE THAN THAT SO
I I ALSO THANK YOU.
AND FAMILIES FOR BEING HERE
TODAY [inaudible]
SENATE MITCHELL.
THANK YOU TO SOMETHING MY
COLLEAGUES TO THE TRIGGERED ME --
YOU KNOW.
AND THEN WE HAVE TO CHECK
OURSELVES SOMEONE MENTIONED YOU
KNOW THE CONSTRUCTION PERMIT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING WITH WITH
SUPPORT SERVICES.
AND I COME FROM THE CITY AND
COUNTY RIGHT NOW THAT IS
FIGHTING TO HAVE THEM BUILT.
AND FACE OPPOSITION.
YOU KNOW NOBODY WANTS IT IN
THEIR BACKYARD SO IT'S EASY TO
SIT HERE TO COMMITTEE AND SAY WE
HAVE TO BRING SERVICES FOR IT
UNTIL WE TALK ABOUT WHERE WE'RE
GOING TO LOCATE THEM.
HEY AND WHO'S GONNA PAY FORM AND
SO WE ARE STEPPING FORWARD
BETTER AND BETTER CITIES AND
COUNTIES ARE PASS INITIATIVES TO
TO TO COULDN'T BUILD.
AND VIENNA.
OUR FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS TALK
ABOUT WHERE IT SHOULD BE SOLD.
IF WE WILL HAVE A CONVERSATION
OF BEYONCE AND HAVE A COMPLETE
CONVERSATION.
ON THAT IF WE'RE GOING TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO OUR FAMILY
AND NEIGHBORS IN FRANCE WHO NEED-IT.
THEN WE HAVE TO HAVE THE
COMPREHENSIVE CONVERSATION ABOUT
FUNDING AND WHERE THEY WILL BE
LOCATED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IN THE COMMENTS --
SAUCER MARKET APPRECIATE YOU
LOOKING.
INTO THIS ISSUE WHICH OF COURSE
HAS BEEN NOW WE'VE BEEN.
TALKING ABOUT A LOT AND AND I
THINK WHAT YOU'RE PROBABLY
HEARING FROM PEOPLE AND I KNOW
YOU'VE WE'VE JUST TALKED VERY
BRIEFLY THAT MAYBE IT'S NOT
QUITE THERE YET AND BUT AT THAT
AND WE SHOULD CONTINUE THE
OPTION TO WORK ON IT SO I I
GUESS YOU CAN COMMENT.
LATER ABOUT MAYBE HOLDING THIS
AND MAKE YOUR TO YOUR BILL.
I DO JUST WANT IT -- SAY TO THE
PROPONENTS -- YELLED AS A
PHYSICIAN WHO TAKES CARE OF
CHILDREN WHO HAVE BEHAVIORAL
ISSUES -- NETWORKS PARENTS WHO
FACED -- SOME THE SAME STORIES
AND I THINK THAT ON ONE LEVEL
YES WE NEED MORE SUPPORT
SERVICES YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT
CONSUMERS AND THE CONSERVATIVES
IN A HOUSING ETCETERA -- BUT
EVEN BEYOND THAT AND I KNOW WE
HAVE TO STRIKE A VERY CAREFUL
BALANCE -- THAT EVEN SOMETIMES
WHEN THE SERVICES ARE AVAILABLE
IF THE PERSON ISN'T WILLING TO
PARTAKE OF IT.
WHAT WE DO AND AGAIN WE WANT TO
RESPECT AND WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT WE DON'T TAKE PEOPLE'S
ECONOMY AWAY?
YOU KNOW.
UP IN SOME SENSES WHAT HAPPENS
TO YOUR THàNH E. WHEN YOU'RE
DISEASE DOESN'T REALLY ALLOW YOU
TO SELECTIVELY EXERCISES THAT
INTEL'S YOU'RE TREATED THAT YOU
CAN ACTUALLY EXERCISE AUTONOMY
RIGHT.
AND WE ARE WITH THE VERY CAREFUL
HOW YOU DO THAT'S I'M VERY
SENSITIVE THAT SO AND I THINK
THAT WHAT'S IN THE BILL
CURRENTLY IS TOO BROAD OKAY BUT
I THINK THERE'S SOME WORK THAT
COULD BE DONE AND IT DOES NEED
TO ALSO LOOP BACK INTO.
MORE RESOURCES RIGHT AND DIE SIR
SHARE CENTER MITCHELL'S
EXPERIENCE BECAUSE I'VE.
SUCCEEDED HER ON BUDGETS OF
THREE AND YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT
NOW WHAT KIND OF RESOURCES AND
SO FOR THAT OUR BUDGET SO FORTH.
BUT BY SO WE DO NEED TO TACKLE
THAT.
BUT I ALSO THINK THERE IS AN
ELEMENT AS WELL THAT WE NEED TO
LOOK AT FIGURE OUT DO WE MAKE
SOME ADJUSTMENTS -- TO TO TO BE
SURE THAT WE STILL PROTECT WE
NEED TO PROTECT THE RIGHTS.
RIGHT THAT'S AND BUT TO ENSURE
THAT THEY HAVE THOSE RIGHTS AND
AT A TIME TO ME.
YOU NEED TO DATE THEY NEED TO BE
IN A PLACE WHERE.
THEY HAVE THE JUDGMENT DAY
THEY'RE ABLE TO DO THAT THAT
THAT MENTAL ILLNESS IS NOT
PREVENT THEM FROM DOING THAT AND
I THINK THAT'S WHY I'M HEARING
FROM THE PROPONENTS THAT THERE'S
FRUSTRATION ABOUT.
AND THAT'S WHAT I'VE HEARD
PREVIOUSLY NO THAT'S WHAT WE
HAVE LARA'S LAW AND PEOPLE
DIFFERENT OPINIONS ABOUT THAT
OTHER TYPES OF THINGS.
SO I'M HOPING SIR MOORLACH --
AND YOU COULD YOU TELL ME WHAT
YOUR DECISION IS TODAY -- THAT
CERTAINLY.
THE ONLY LAST YEAR FROM THE
AUDIT WE ALSO WANT TO SEE IF WE
CAN TRY.
TO GIVEN TOGETHER AND SEE
WHETHER WE CAN HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION BUT HOW WE SOLVE.
THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE THAT I
HEAR FRUSTRATION COMING FROM THE
THE THE PEOPLE PRESENTING TODAY
AND THE OTHER SUPPORTERS AS WELL --
SO I MEAN I THINK PEOPLE ARE ON
BOTH SIDES OF EXPRESS TREMENDOUS
GOOD WILL AND DESIRE TO HELP --
CAN WE FIGURE OUT HOW TO LAND
THAT BALANCE THERE AND AND AND
AND AND AND SLIGHTLY.
HOPEFULLY BETTER PLACE PEOPLE
MAY THINK THAT THE CURRENT
PLACES VIEWS BECAUSE WE ARE YET
BUT I I BUT I WHAT I'M HEARING
IS THAT THEIR FAMILIES ARE
FRUSTRATED EVEN WHEN THEY ARE
ABLE THAT ARE NOT ABLE TO HELP
SELL -- WITH THAT -- SIR MORE
LIKE WHICH USE LIKE.
TO THOSE ARE TELL US WHAT YOU
WISH TO DO WITH YOUR BILL THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR YOUR SAGE
COUNSEL LIGHT THAT'S WHAT I
ASKED FOR YOU GAVE IT AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE IT AND I WANT
TO THANK SENATOR.
MITCHELL AS WELL -- AS ONE OF
THE THINGS YOU KNOW WHEN YOU'RE.
THIS I'VE BEEN WORKING ON THE
HOMELESS ISSUE.
SINCE I BECAME A COUNTY
SUPERVISOR AND EVEN BEFORE THAN
TRYING TO DEAL WITH THE
POPULATION AROUND THE CITY
CENTER IN ORANGE COUNTY.
AND IT'S COMPLEX [inaudible]
AND WHY I DID THIS BILL IT WAS A
RESULT OF A OF A RADIO INTERVIEW.
AND IT WAS -- DR DREW.
I'VE KBC OUT OF LA AND HE SAID
OUT.
THIS IS LIKE MEDIEVAL TIMES WHAT
HE WE DOING WITH ALL THESE
PEOPLE.
ON OUR STREETS AND HE'S A I
THINK A TRAINED PSYCHIATRIST AND
HE SAID WHAT YOU NEED TO DO IS
[inaudible]
IMPROVE -- THIS DEFINITION OF
GRAVELY DISABLED SO THAT'S HOW
THIS LITTLE CHAPTER STARTED.
BUT IT OVER WE NEED SUPPORT
SERVICES THE OPPOSITION IS
CORRECT.
I THIS FRIDAY LAST FRIDAY I WAS.
TOURING FOR THREE HOURS OF
FACILITY.
IN ORANGE COUNTY TO SEE WHAT WE
CAN DO.
WE'VE ALREADY GOT -- IN THE CITY
OF ORANGE A SITE THAT WE FOUND.
AT CEDAR MITCHELL KNOWS IS A
DIFFICULT BUT WE WE CALL IT BE
WELL IN OB AS SERVICING -- THE
MENTALLY ILL AND SO WE'RE WE'RE
WORKING IN OUR REGION AND SO
BECAUSE I WAS INVOLVED WITH
PROPOSITION TWO AND CENTER
DELEON AND I GOT IT ON THE
BALLOT.
YOU KNOW BY THE JOINT AUTHORS
YOU KNOW WHERE YOU CAN GET SEE
WE ARE OUR CONCERN BUT THAT'S A
A FUNDING SOURCE SO SIGNATURE
TODAY.
I'D LIKE TO REQUEST NO MOTION
I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THIS
A TO YOUR BILL [inaudible]
AND A AND AND I I NEED TO WORK
ON NOT YOUR AMENDMENTS THAT YOU
PROPOSE BUT AMENDMENTS THAT
WOULD PROVIDE THE RESOURCES. TO
GET SOMETHING IN PLACE AND AND
MAYBE STROLL MODEL MAY BE ORANGE
COUNTY OR SOMEWHERE ELSE.
BUT OUR CONSTITUENTS WANT TO
COMPASSIONATE SOLUTION -- TO A
SEGMENT OF THE HOMELESS
POPULATION I WAS BORN ON
DECEMBER TWENTY FIRST AND I'VE
ALWAYS COMPLAIN THAT IT WAS THE
SHORTEST DAY.
BUT THE HOMES COMMUNITY OF SAID
IT'S THE LONGEST NIGHT.
AND THEY MAY DECEMBER TWENTY ONE
THE DAY WE MEMORIALIZE.
THE HOMELESS PEOPLE THAT HAVE
PASSED ON OUR STREETS IN AN
ORANGE COUNTY IT'S BEEN TWO
HUNDRED PEOPLE A YEAR.
YEAH I'D LIKE TO REDUCE THAT
STATISTIC.
BECAUSE PEOPLE THAT CANNOT
MANAGE THEMSELVES WHO CANNOT.
TAKE CARE OF THEIRSELVES.
YOU KNOW WE WE'VE GOT A STEP UP
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT MEDIEVAL
TIMES THIS IS. TWENTY NINETEEN
AND I I APPRECIATE VERY MUCH.
YOU'RE ALLOWED ME TO PRESENT THE
BILL AND AND FOR GIVING ME THE
GRACE TO MAKE IT TO YOUR BILL I
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
SO AT THE AUTHOR'S REQUEST WE
WILL HOLD THIS BILL IN COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU. FOR HOLDING THE BILL
COMMITTEE THAT.
OKAY -- NEXT UP THEN -- SIR
DORADO.
SO DO YOU -- IT MIGHT TAKE UP
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU ALSO PRESENTS
ARE JACKSON'S BILL DUMA'S SHOULD
WE TAKE IT UP AND FILE ORDER
THAN.
OKAY SO THEN WE'LL -- WE'RE
GONNA HEAR ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB
FOUR TWENTY FOUR BY CENTER
JACKSON BEING PRESENTED BY
SENATOR ALSO [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON [inaudible]
MISTER CHAIR.
BUT YOU HAVE TO DO MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
FOR TWO FOR ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
JACKSON WHO COULD NOT.
BE HERE TODAY.
FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR THOUGHTFUL
ANALYSIS ON THE BILL LET YOU
KNOW.
THAT SENATOR JACKSON HAS AGREED
TO TAKE THE TECHNICAL AMENDMENT
SUGGESTED ON PAGE EIGHT OF THE
ANALYSIS.
SB FOUR TWO FOUR WOULD ESTABLISH
A COMPREHENSIVE.
TOBACCO RELATED WASTE REDUCTION
PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA.
THROUGH A TWO PRONGED APPROACH
FIRST THE BILL BANS THE SALE OF
SINGLE USE FILTERS.
AND PLASTIC DEVICES USED WITH
TOBACCO PRODUCTS.
AND IT BANS THE SALE OF SINGLE
USE ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES AND
VAPORIZER DEVICES.
SECOND THIS BILL REQUIRES THAT
ALL MULTI USE TOBACCO PRODUCTS
BE ORDINARILY RECYCLABLE.
BY EITHER A LOCAL OR STATE
RECYCLING PROGRAM OR IF A
COMPONENT IS NOT ORDINARILY
RECYCLABLE.
THEN THE BILL REQUIRES THE
MANUFACTURER OF THE PRODUCT TO
SET UP EITHER COLLECTION OR MAIL
TAKE BACK PROGRAM FOR THAT
COMPONENT.
TOBACCO PRODUCT WASTE IS AMONG
THE MOST PROPELLANT AND VEXING
PROBLEMS FACED BY MUNICIPAL
AGENCIES.
IN THEIR EFFORTS TO KEEP OUR
COMMUNITIES CLEAN AND OUR
ENVIRONMENT PROTECTED.
CLEANING UP THIS WAYS COST
MILLIONS OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS
ANNUALLY.
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE DOCTOR JOE
AND BRASH.
SPECIAL PROJECTS MANAGER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL TO TESTIFY
ON BEHALF OF THIS OF THIS BILL.
THANK.
THANK YOU THIS IS A SPORT.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SIGN MY NAME IS DOCTOR
JOANNE BRASH.
I'M WITH THE NATIONAL
STEWARDSHIP ACTION COUNCIL A NON
PROFIT ADVOCATING FOR CIRCULAR
ECONOMY.
I ALSO LECTURE AT UC DAVIS IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF TEXTILES
COVERING TOPICS OF FIBER AND
POLYMER CHEMISTRY.
I'M HERE TODAY AS A SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SB.
FOR TWO FOR TOBACCO PRODUCT
REYES HAS CAUSED LONG TERM
DAMAGE TO OUR ECOSYSTEMS.
AND OUR COMMUNITIES.
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE BEARING
THE COST BURDEN TO REMOVE
TOBACCO WASTE FROM THE
ENVIRONMENT BUT CANNOT REMOVE
THE CHEMICALS AND MICRO PLASTICS
LEACHING INTO THE WATER.
KILLING THE ENVIRONMENT AND
ENDANGERING OUR COMMUNITIES.
REVIEWED RESEARCH INDICATES
RISING ALONG.
AND I DO HAVE A DELAY CARCINOMAS.
AS SINCE THE INTRODUCTION OF THE
ACETATE FILTERS.
THE ACETATE FILTERS ALTER THE
TOBACCO COMBUSTION INCREASING
SMOKE TOXICANTS AS CITED IN THE
JOURNAL OF NATIONAL CANCER
INSTITUTE JUST IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN CURRENTLY
THERE IS INSUFFICIENT END OF
LIFE MANAGEMENT IN PLACE FOR
PROPER HANDLING OF TOBACCO WASTE.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE SAN
FRANCISCO SPENT NEARLY TEN
MILLION DOLLARS ON CIGARETTE BUT
CLEAN UP ALONE.
IN MARCH TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO.
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY THE DOWNTOWN
STREET TEAM -- CLEANED UP.
A TWO MILE STRETCH OF THE
UNINCORPORATED COUNTY WHICH IS
ALREADY CLEANED THREE TIMES A
WEEK AND THEY STILL FOUND OVER
THOUSAND CIGARETTE BUT HARM.
A CALL FOR SIGNIFICANTLY GOING
TO INCREASE.
AS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS PHASE IN
THE DEPLOYMENT OF CAPTURE
DEVICES TO MEET THE TOTAL
MAXIMUM DAILY LOAD REQUIREMENTS
AS SET BY THE STATE WATER BOARD.
BOARDS.
THIS BILL BANS THE SALE OF
SINGLE USE PLASTIC IN TOBACCO
PRODUCTS THAT DO NOT NEED TO
STATE AND LOCAL RECYCLING SYSTEM
REQUIREMENTS.
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES
ELECTRONIC SMOKING DEVICES TO BE
REUSABLE.
AND THE PRODUCERS TO PROVIDE A
TAKE BACK PROGRAM FOR PROPER END
OF LIFE MANAGEMENT WE ASKED
PRODUCERS TO TAKE THEIR FAIR
SHARE OF RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THESE HARD TO MANAGE PRODUCTS.
AT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ALONE
CANNOT HANDLE THE COST BURDEN OF
TOXIC TOBACCO WASTE.
POSING SIGNIFICANT RISK TO HUMAN
AND ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR TESTIMONY.
NO SIR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
RESTRICTION SHELTER HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PRODUCTS YOU'RE TO COUNSEL
INSTRUCTS FOR THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE COME FORWARD.
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS RUNNING
AS CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
HELLO KILLER ROBINSON ON BEHALF
OF RETHINK WASTE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THREE SEPARATE VERGE
ON BEHALF OF HEAL THE BAY
SURFRIDER SEVENTH GENERATION
ADVISORS AND THE OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE CLEAN SEIZE LOBBYING
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
DINNER BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU SEEN NO OTHER
APPS BUT THE MICROPHONE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
CENA WITH THIS IS OPPOSITION
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THERE'S A MOTION BY CENTER LEYVA
SEEN NO THE QUESTION SIR THANK
YOU SENATOR OTHER FOR PRESENTING
THIS ON BEHALF OF CENTER JACKSON
APPRECIATE THAT WE NEED TO TRY
TO REDUCE THE WASTE THAT'S
COMING FROM THE SWITCHING WHICH
LIKE THE CLOTHES.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
EXCELLENT SO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY IT'S BEEN MOTION BY AT
CENTER LEYVA SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
PAN HI.
I STONE.
STONE NOW DORADO.
HI ROSE -- I'D GROWTH
[inaudible]
HER TADO.
LEYVA LEYVA AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING MONNING I
SO CURRENTLY THE VOTE IS -- FIVE
TO ONE THAT'S ENOUGH TO GET THE
BILL OUT THE WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT.
MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT NOW LET'S
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER -- NINE
SP FOUR FIFTY EIGHT BY CENTER
ALSO.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
AS OUR BUT WITNESSES -- CAN COME
UP.
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF
ALSO FOR ALL OF YOUR HARD WORK
ON THIS BILL -- I WOULD LIKE TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE --
COMMITTEE SUGGESTED AMENDMENT.
THAT KEEPS THE BAN OF CORPORATE
FILE CLERK PURIFY US.
IN EFFECT UNTIL THE DEPARTMENT
OF PESTICIDE REGULATION AND THE
OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
HAZARD ASSESSMENT.
DETERMINED BY CLEAR AND
CONVINCING EVIDENCE.
THAT THE CONTROL MEASURES
ADOPTED BY THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION. FOR CHLORPYRIFOS
WILL NOT RESULT IN NEAR
DEVELOPMENTAL HARM TO CHILDREN
AFTER TAKING INTO ACCOUNT
CONSUMPTION OF FOOD OR WATER.
THIS BILL IS VITAL TO PROTECTING
ALL CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN FROM EVERY WALK OF LIFE
AND EVERY RACE AND ETHNICITY.
EXPOSURE TO CHLORPYRIFOS BEGINS
IN THE WOMB AND CONTINUES WHEN
KIDS COSUME THE FRUITS NUTS AND
VEGETABLES.
THAT WE AS PARENTS AND
GRANDPARENTS ENCOURAGE THEM TO
EAT.
HERE IS WHAT THE RECOGNIZE
EXPERTS CONCLUDE IS IRREFUTABLE
SCIENTIFIC CONSENSUS ABOUT THE
NEARLY ONE MILLION POUNDS OF
CHLORPYRIFOS APPLIED EACH YEAR
ON CALIFORNIA CROPS.
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
CONCLUDES.
THERE IS A WEALTH OF EVIDENCE
DEMONSTRATING THE DETRIMENTAL
EFFECTS OF CHLORPYRIFOS EXPOSURE
TO DEVELOPING FETUSES INFANTS
CHILDREN AND PREGNANT WOMEN.
THE RISK TO INVENT AND
CHILDREN'S HEALTH AND
DEVELOPMENT IS UNAMBIGUOUS.
AT LEAST FOUR LANDMARK STUDIES
PROVIDE THE EVIDENCE THAT THIS
AGREEMENT DAMAGES.
INGREDIENT DAMAGES THE BRAINS OF
FETUSES BABIES AND YOUNG
CHILDREN.
YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU
DOCUMENTATION ON EACH OF THESE
EACH OF THEM.
SCIENTISTS IN ALL FOUR STUDIES
EXAMINED THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN EXPOSURE.
GIORDANO PHOSPHATE PESTICIDES
SUCH AS CLERK.
PREPARE FOR US COR PAIR FOR US
DURING PREGNANCY AND THE
SUBSEQUENT BRAIN DEVELOPMENT OF
EXPOSED CHILDREN.
AS A RESULT OF STUDIES RELATING
TO HOUSEHOLD PRODUCTS AND COMMON
RESIDENTIAL USE THE MAKER OF
RAID.
S. C. JOHNSON SONS WAS FORCED TO
REMOVE COR PARA FOSS FROM ITS
PRODUCT.
RAID STILL KILLS IN SEX.
IT JUST DOES SO WITHOUT THE
INGREDIENT THE DAMAGES THE
BRAINS OF FETUSES INFANTS AND
YOUNG CHILDREN.
IN THE COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY STUDY
SCIENTISTS AND RULED PREGNANT
WOMEN IN NEW YORK CITY WERE
EXPOSED IN THEIR HOMES.
THEY MEASURED CHLORPYRIFOS IN
UNDER UMBILICAL CORD BLOOD.
THEY FOUND EXPOSURE BECAUSE
DEVELOPMENTAL DELAYS AND
ATTENTION AND BEHAVIOR PROBLEMS
IN THEIR CHILDREN AT THREE YEARS.
REDUCTION IN AYE CUES AND
WORKING MEMORY AT SEVEN YEARS.
AND EVEN STRUCTURAL CHANGES IN
THE BRAIN AND LATE CHILDHOOD.
IN THE MOUNT SINAI SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE STUDY ALSO IN NEW YORK
CITY RESEARCHERS AND ROL
PREGNANT WOMEN AND REPORTED
EXPOSURE WAS ASSOCIATED WITH
DECREASES IN THEIR KIDS MENTAL
DEVELOPMENT AT ONE YEAR OF AGE.
THE OTHER TWO STUDIES SHOW
AGRICULTURAL USE OF THIS
INGREDIENT DAMAGES THE BRAINS OF
FETUSES BABIES AND YOUNG
CHILDREN.
IN THE UC BERKELEY STUDY
SCIENTISTS AND ROLL PREGNANT
WOMEN IN THE SALINAS VALLEY AND
FOUND EXPOSURE WAS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE TENSION PROBLEMS.
AND ATTENTION DEFICIT DISORDER
AMONG THE CHILDREN AT FIVE YEARS.
PLUS REDUCTIONS I CAN AYE CUES
AND WORKING MEMORY.
THE UC DAVIS STUDY SHOWS
RESEARCHERS COMPARED CHILDREN
WITH AUTISM.
SPECTRUM DISORDER TO SIMILAR
CHILDREN WITHOUT THE DISORDER.
THEY FOUND MOTHERS WHO HAD
CHILDREN WITH THE DISORDER WERE
MORE LIKELY TO HAVE LIVED IN
NEAR FEELS WERE CLEAR POOR FOSS
WAS APPLIED.
BASED ON PESTICIDE APPLICATION.
UP MAINTAINED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF PESTICIDE REGULATION THE U.
S. EPA UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA
RECOGNIZED THE IRREFUTABLE
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE.
INCLUDING THE CLEAR C<c.cyan>G</c>
CONCLUSIONS OF ITS OWN
SCIENTISTS.
BY PROVIDING BY PROPOSING TO BAN
[inaudible]
KARPOV [inaudible]
CLUB ROUGH.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS.
WHEN I SAY CLORE YOU KNOW WHAT
IT IS?
BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S EPA
ADMINISTRATOR SCOTT PRUETT
CONTRADICTED THE OVERWHELMING
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE AND THE
CLEAR CONCLUSIONS OF THE EPA'S
OWN SCIENTISTS.
BY REFUSING TO FINALIZE THAT BAN
IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THEREFORE THE
ONLY WAY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CAN RESPECT THEIR REPEATABLE
EVIDENCE ABOUT THIS INGREDIENT
IS BY ENACTING SB.
FOUR FIFTY EIGHT THIS YEAR
COLLEAGUES WE IN THE LEGISLATURE
ARE CONSIDERING GOVERNOR
GOVERNOR NUISANCE PLAN FOR
EXPANDING EARLY CHILDHOOD
DEVELOPMENT.
WHEN OUR GOVERNOR TALKS ABOUT
EARLY CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT HE
MAKES A CONVINCING CASE FOR THE
PHYSICAL DEVELOPMENT OF A
CHILD'S BRAIN?
SB FOUR FIVE EIGHT WILL AND
CALIFORNIA'S TOLERANCE OF THE
WIDESPREAD USE OF AN INGREDIENT
THAT DOES JUST THE OPPOSITE.
YOU HAVE YOUR IN YOUR PACKETS
TODAY A LETTER FROM THIRTY NINE
SCIENTISTS AND HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS.
THESE EXPERTS TELL US THERE IS
CLEAR EVIDENCE THAT THE
CONTINUED USE OF COLOR.
CLARK.
ISRAEL HARMFUL TO BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT.
THEY ALSO TELL IS THAT IN MANY
OF THE STUDIES THERE WAS NO
EVIDENCE OF A THRESHOLD OR SAFE
LEVEL OF EXPLODED EXPOSURE.
WITNESSES WITH ME TODAY OUR
DOCTOR IRVINE HURTS BUT G. P. G.
ALREADY BE CHAU.
GOOD CLOSE ENOUGH PRESS IS
PROFESSOR AND VICE CHAIR FOR
RESEARCH IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH SCIENCES AT UC
DAVIS.
TYLER SMITH STAFF SCIENTIST AT
JUSTICE AND GREG LAURIE STAFF
ATTORNEY AT EARTH JUSTICE TO
HELP ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO I
WILL MAKE NOTE THAT -- WE ALLOW
SIX MINUTES -- I'LL MAKE A
LITTLE SIGNAL IT TOO AND FOR
WITH MY HANDS BUT YOU YOU FIGURE
OUT BETWEEN THE THREE OF YOU
WHOEVER'S LAST MAY FIND
THEMSELVES WITH VERY LITTLE TIME
IF THE OTHER. TWO PEOPLE AHEAD
DON'T KEEP THAT IN MIND SO --
WELCOME AND LOOK FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY.
ACTUALLY YOU CAN JUST YEAH YOU
HAVE THE MICROPHONE IN FRONT OF
FIVE YOU THERE OKAY THANK YOU.
YEAH.
OKAY.
I'M OVER HER TEACHER.
TO PREVENT.
WE KNOW EACH OTHER A PROFESSOR
IN AT UC DAVIS AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH SCIENCES CENTER WHICH IS
FUNDED BY THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTES OF HEALTH.
AND I WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR
FOR ACTUALLY.
PRETTY MUCH LAYING OUT THE
SCIENCE -- AS IT IS AND YOU KNOW
JUST MAYBE I'LL ADD A FEW POINTS
HERE ONE IS THAT THE ORGANIC
PHOSPHATE PESTICIDES ACTUALLY
THEY WERE ORIGINALLY BEING
DEVELOPED -- AS NERVE AGENTS --
THEY WERE NEVER FORTUNATELY EVER
USE FOR THAT BUT WERE LATER
ADAPTED THEN TO BE USES
PESTICIDES AND THEY KILL.
INSECTS AND SPIDERS BASICALLY
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO NOW AT VERY
HIGH LEVELS THEY CAN BE ACUTELY
TOXIC AND CAN RESULT IN
CONVULSIONS AND AND EVEN.
DEATH WHEN A VERY HIGH LEVEL IS
TAKEN AND AS POLLS WHICH IS
REALLY POISONOUS.
BUT WHAT WE'RE REALLY TALKING
ABOUT TODAY'S THE LOW LEVEL
EXPOSURES.
THAT OCCUR THROUGH READING THE
AIR UP IF YOU LIVE IN AN
AGRICULTURAL AREA SAY WITHIN A
MILE OR SO -- WHERE APPLICATIONS
ARE BEING -- WHERE CLICK HERE
FOR US IS BEING A AND OTHER
ORGAN APOSTATES ARE BEING
APPLIED YOUR BREATHING AIR
YOU'RE TAKING AND THOSE
PESTICIDES AND THERE ARE --
THERE'S VERY STRONG STUDIES
SHOWING THAT THAT DRIFT
CORRESPONDS VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE APPLICATIONS AND BEEN MADE
BASED ON DEEP YARD -- DATA.
AND OF COURSE THE OTHER WAY AS
LAID OUT BY THE SENATOR IS
THROUGH RESIDUES THERE ON FOOD
IN THERE ON ON PARTICULARLY
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES SO THAT
AFFECTS EVERYBODY -- BY NOW
THERE ARE OVER THREE DOZEN
STUDIES.
THAT HAVE DEMONSTRATED THIS LINK
BETWEEN PRENATAL EXPOSURE --
OVERWHELMINGLY HAVE.
SHOWN THAT THE OUTCOMES OF OF
LOWER I. Q. AND IMPAIRMENTS IN.
MEMORY AND LEARNING AS WELL AS
SYMPTOMS OF AUTISM SPECTRUM
DISORDER -- OF ATTENTION DEFICIT
DISORDER.
ARE -- ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
PRENATAL EXPOSURE AND THAT THESE
OUTCOMES OCCUR.
STARTING SHORTLY AFTER BIRTH AND
ALL THE WAY INTO ADOLESCENCE --
THE THIS REFLECTS ALL
ALTERATIONS IN BRAIN DEVELOPMENT.
AND IN FACT A CORE PROPOSES THE
MOST COMMON OF THESE ORGAN OF
PHOSPHATES BUT NO STUDY HAS
IDENTIFIED A LEVEL BELOW WHICH
WE CAN SCAN SO THERE IT SAFE.
THE VERY LAST POINT I WANT TO
MAKE IS THAT THERE IS AN
ABUNDANT ANIMAL EXPERIMENTAL
LIVE THE LITERATURE -- MUCH OF
WHICH WAS DONE BACK IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS IT ALSO SHOWED.
IMPAIRMENTS IN LEARNING AND
MEMORY AND BEHAVIORS THE SAME
SYMPTOMS THAT WE SEE IN HUMAN
BEINGS -- WE SHOULD HAVE
EXPECTED THAT THAT WOULD HAPPEN
AND IN FACT THAT'S WHAT THE LAST
TEN TO FIFTEEN YEARS OF
EPIDEMIOLOGIC RESEARCH HAS NOW
SHOWN -- SO I THINK THE EVIDENCE
IS QUITE COMPELLING.
AND AS SENATORS -- YOU CAN
REALLY MOVE FORWARD HOW WE
REGULATE A CHEMICAL POLICY HERE --
AND REALLY MAKE THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
PROTECTING CHILDREN'S BRAINS
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GERMAN DOCTOR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY MY NAME IS TYLER SMITH
I'M A STAFF SCIENTIST AT EARTH
JUSTICE WE ARE THE NATION'S
LARGEST NONPROFIT ENVIRONMENTAL
LAW ORGANIZATION.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT SENATE BILL
FOUR FIVE EIGHT AND WE JOINED
THE UNITED FARM WORKERS AS WELL
AS THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS.
HAS CO SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN U. S. EPA
CONCLUDED THAT USING CORPORA
FALSE ON FOOD DOES NOT MEET THE
FEDERAL SAFETY STANDARD.
OF REASONABLE CERTAINTY OF NO
HARM.
AND THE AGENCY PROPOSED A BAN
THAT WOULD HAVE ELIMINATED
NEARLY ALL USES OF THIS
PESTICIDE ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN USEPA SCIENTISTS
REVIEWED THE STUDY CITED BY THE
OPPONENTS OF THIS BILL AND
EXAMINE THE HUNDREDS OF WAYS THE
CORPORATE COST MAY BE USED UNDER
CURRENT LAW.
THEY FOUND THAT ALL OF THESE
USES.
RESULT IN UNSAFE LEVELS OF
EXPOSURE.
WHEN HANDLERS FOLLOW ALL OF THE
DIRECTIONS ON PESTICIDE LABELS
AND EVEN WHEN THE WHERE PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT?
THEY ALSO FOUND THAT THE
CONTINUED USE OF CORPORATE FALLS
ON FOOD HARM TO THOSE WHO EAT
THE FOOD.
USES ON FOOD EXPOSE CHILDREN ONE
TO TWO YEARS OF AGE TO ONE
HUNDRED FORTY TIMES WHAT US EPA
CONSIDERS ACCEPTABLE.
MOREOVER THE AGENCY CONCLUDED
THERE IS NO SAFE LEVEL OF
QUICKER ACOSTA DRINKING WATER.
AND YET AN EARLY.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION ANNOUNCED THAT IT
WOULD NOT FINALIZED THE PROPOSED
BAN.
THE ADMINISTRATION DISREGARDED
THE BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE AND
LET MILLIONS OF PEOPLE EXPOSED
TO THIS TOXIC CHEMICAL.
NOW A COALITION OF HEALTH LABOR
AND CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATION TO
SUE THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
AT LAST YEAR A FEDERAL APPEALS
COURT ORDER THE EPA TO BAN ALL
USES A QUICKER FALLS WITHIN
SIXTY DAYS.
BUT THE AGENCY APPEAL FURTHER.
USEPA HAS NEVER DISPUTED THE
CONCLUSIONS REACHED BY ITS OWN
SCIENTISTS AND INSTEAD HAS BASED
HIS LEGAL ARGUMENTS ON ON
RELATED PROCEDURAL ISSUES.
NOW UNLESS THE LEGISLATURE TAKES
ACTION CORPORATE FALLS WILL
REMAIN ON THE MARKET.
THE CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA WILL
REMAIN EXPOSED WHILE THE FEDERAL
LITIGATION CONTINUES.
AND IT MAY TAKE YEARS TO RESOLVE
ALL OF THE LITIGATION EVEN IF
THE PLAINTIFFS ULTIMATELY
PREVAIL.
SENATE BILL FOUR FIVE EIGHT
WOULD MAKE THE STATE A SAFER
PLACE FOR KIDS TO GROW UP.
I HEARD YOUR SUPPORT AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS THANK
YOU.
YUP TWENTY FIVE SECONDS IT IS
THANK YOU SENATOR -- MY NAME IS
GREG LAURIE I'M AN ATTORNEY IT
OR IT'S JUST AS I'M HERE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
ACT MICROPHONE ELLERY NOBLE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH
COLLISION ADVOCACY AND POWER
FAMILY CALIFORNIA AND EDUCATE
ADVOCATE.
IN SUPPORT.
KELLY BE MY BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
THE ONE REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA
DIVISION FIVE THOUSAND BOARD
CERTIFIED PEDIATRICIANS AS WELL
AS SUB SPECIALISTS WE ARE PROUD
CO SPONSORS OF THIS BEFORE FIFTY
EIGHT AND IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
PAULINE A TAURUS WITH THE CENTER
ON RACE POVERTY THE ENVIRONMENT.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL AND
PRINT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS VEHICLES ON THE
OIL AND REPRESENTING COMMITTEE
FOR BETTER ARVIN AND COMMITTEE
FOR BETTER SHAFTER GROUPS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WHERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ME NUMBER SOLD RELEASE PRESIDENT
OF THE COMMUTER LOS HILLEN
AKSYON.
HE UP FOR YOUR REAL [inaudible]
ACCESS.
MY NAME IS ERICA RESERVE A
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE OF THE
HOSPITALS IN KERN ONE OF THE
MOST AFFECTED -- COUNTIES AND
THE WE ARE IN FAVOR OF THE BILL
IN PRINT.
THANK YOU.
TURN MEMBERS NIKITA CREDIT WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MY NAME CENTER HERE IN THE
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA BY MENTAL
JUSTICE NETWORK -- ORGANIZER IN
KERN COUNTY WITH DOZENS OF
SCHOOLS ARE NEXT AGRICULTURE
FEEL THERE SHOULD BE LIKE THIS
AND WE HAVE THE LOWEST TEST
SCORES IN THE STATE.
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME SAID
HIS HIS MENDOZA WITH THAT
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA BY MENTAL
JUSTICE NETWORK.
FROM FRESNO AND ALSO AS A FORMER
FARM WORKER MYSELF AND WE
UNDERSTAND THE EXPERIENCE OF HOW
OUR HEALTH IS A AT RISK AND
WHERE WE SUPPORT THE BILL IN
PRINT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GEN FLOOR IN BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON JENNIFER FEARING ON
BEHALF OF THE PESTICIDE ACTION
NETWORK IN THE CALIFORNIA FOOD
AND FARMING NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HAPPY DOORS WERE TODAY.
ROY WILSON ON BEHALF OF THE
DOORS WERE TO FOUNDATION OUR
RESEARCH OF THOUSANDS OF
FARMWORKERS AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND WE STRONGLY.
OPPOSE OUR BOB HOPE CLUB
PERFORMERS.
WAIT WE'RE GONNA WE AGREE WITH
THE BAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE CLARITY THERE
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DOCTOR
CAMPBELL KEY ALSO REPRESENTING
THAT THE LOTUS WENT THE
FOUNDATION TO LOTUS JUST SENT TO
TAXED -- AND ASKS APOLOGIES FOR
NOT BEING HERE DELORES AS TO
MENTION MELISSA THOUGHT THOUGH
RECOGNIZED A LOTUS THE SON IN
LAW A CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROLMAN DAVID COVERED AT A FOR
HIS SERVICE.
HIS FATHER IT WAS A FARM WORKER
AND DIED FROM PESTICIDES HE
LIVED AND WORKED IN MY IN
MCFARLAND CALIFORNIA THE LOTUS
WAS HOPING TO BE PRESENT AND
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE BAN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
DANIEL BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
IN KATTAN FOR CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LEE SAID VAN FLEET BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE DOCTOR CAME A TIE WILL
ENVIRONMENTAL EPIDEMIOLOGIST IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NICOLAS CHAVEZ I'LL BE OUT THE
UNITED FARM WORKERS IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAMES
STEPHANIE BLACK DAY I'M A
STUDENT AT BUSINESS CITY AND I'M
FROM TOYOTA COUNTY AND MY
PARENTS HAVE ALWAYS BEEN --
FARMWORKERS AND ARE GREATLY
AFFECTED BY PESTICIDES AND I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
CHRIS RESPONSES WHICH THE CALL
THIS REMAIN IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
DIRECTOR AT PRESENT IN FAMILIES
FROM THE ROLE CALIFORNIA AREA AS
WELL.
THANK YOU FOR SUPPORT.
BYRON CHAN WITH EARTH JUSTICE
THE SCIENCE IS CLEAR THAT CLIP
YOUR BOSS HARMS CHILDREN'S
BRAINS DEVELOPMENT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ELLEN CHAIRMAN REPRESENTING THE
MEMBERS OF INDIVISIBLE
SACRAMENTO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DOUG TROUBLED INDIVISIBLE
SACRAMENTO AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
JULIE JORDAN LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THE ANIMUS HAS
WITH CALIFORNIA ROOMS JUSTICE
ALLIANCE STRONG SUPPORT AND ALSO --
BRIDGE STREET SUPPORT FOR
MEMBERS TO WORKING.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT SPENCER AMERICAN CULTURE
OBGYN STARSHIP NINE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SIR HUTCHINSON WITH ACT FOR
WOMEN AND GIRLS IN STRONG
SUPPORT YOU.
SIR FLUX CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JIM LINDBERGH ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
A CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MICHAEL DIMMICK GROUPS OF CHANGE
IN STRONG SUPPORT YOU.
MATTHEW AWESOME PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE ON SCIENTISTS STUDIED
THE APPLICATION OF PESTICIDE
AROUND SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
GEN ROBINSON PLANT BLACK WOMEN
FOR WELLNESS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
SHANNON HOVIS NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALISON USE FOR
THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND OF
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OKAY SEEN OTHER PEOPLE THE
MICROPHONE -- WITH -- THE PHONE
INTO THE BILL WHEN SAID
APPOSITION AND IF YOU CAN PLEASE
MAKE ROOM FOR THEM IN THE FRONT.
GO SIDE OR THAT SIDE
[inaudible]
BY.
SIT AROUND THAT SIDE PERHAPS
VOTE THE BUTTONS OPPOSITION SIT
NEAR [inaudible]
OKAY. TWO WITNESSES HERE OKAY
AGAIN SIX MINUTES MAXIMUM THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LEARN ONLY PAGE ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN PLAN HEALTH
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA CITRUS
MUTUAL CALIFORNIA CONGENERS IN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION WESTERN OUR
PROCESSORS THIS PAST YEAR --
GROWERS AND VARIOUS OTHER AG
TRADE ASSOCIATIONS IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL -- THE CORPORATE
BOSSES A TOOL THAT AGRICULTURAL.
COMMODITIES IN CALIFORNIA USED
TO PROTECT OURSELVES FROM AN
BASIS A PASS -- WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
REGULATORY RESTRICTIONS ON THOSE
THOUGH WE ARE CONCERNED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE.
IN AN OUTRIGHT BAN IS TAKING
THAT OUT OF THE REGULATORY
PROCESS AND THAT'S TAKING A TOOL
OUT OF THAT TOOL BOX -- THERE
WAS SOME COMMENTS ABOUT WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DID I'M NOT
GONNA GET INTO THE SCIENCE
BUDGET CLARIFY SOME OF THE
TIMELINE ISSUES -- EPA HAD BEEN
TALKING ABOUT AND PROPOSED A BAN
ON FOR PEER FASTER THAN ITS OWN
SCIENTIFIC ADVISORY PANEL UNDER
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
SAID THAT MORE SCIENTIFIC
STUDIES NEEDED TO BE DONE AND SO
THERE WAS A HOLD ON THAT IN THAT
WAS STILL UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
THE THING ABOUT CALIFORNIA
THOUGH HE IS EVEN NO MATTER WHAT
HAPPENS IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WE IN CALIFORNIA IS
STILL DO OUR OWN THING WE ARE
THE ONLY STATE IN THE NATION
THAT HAS A DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION OR DPR.
AND BEFORE -- PESTICIDE CAN BE
REGISTERED HERE IN CALIFORNIA
CPR HAS TO DO ITS OWN
INDEPENDENT EVALUATION THAT
LOOKS AT THE HEALTH EFFECTS OF
PESTICIDES LOOK AT THE EFFECTS
ON THE ENVIRONMENT.
LOOKS AT THE TOXICITY AND
DETERMINES IF THAT PESTICIDE
SHOULD BE REGISTERED IF THEY
DETERMINE IT SHOULD BE
REGISTERED THEY CAN PLACE
RESTRICTIONS IN MITIGATION
MEASURES ON THAT PESTICIDE. TO
ENSURE THAT HUMAN HEALTH HEALTH
AND THE ENVIRONMENT ARE BEING
PROTECTED ONCE IT'S REGISTER
THERE'S A CAN FOR TEN YOU ALL
EVALUATION AND DATA COLLECTION.
BY DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION.
IF ANYTHING IN THAT CONTINUAL
EVALUATION LOOKS LIKE THAT IT
WOULD HAVE AN UNREASONABLE FACT
ON HUMAN HEALTH.
IT AUTOMATICALLY TRIGGERS RE
EVALUATION TO DETERMINE IF THAT
PESTICIDE SHOULD CONTINUE TO BE
REGISTERED HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
FEELS HAS BEEN IT READ HAS BEEN
REGISTERED AND STUDIED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SINCE -- NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR BUT MOST RECENTLY
I'M IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN IT
BECAME A RESTRICTED PESTICIDE
WHICH MEANS NO HOUSEHOLD USE.
AND AT THAT IT ALSO HAS TO BE
APPLIED BY A CERTIFIED PESTICIDE
APPLICATOR YOU JUST CAN'T BE
ANYONE IN USE THIS PESTICIDE
ALSO RIGHT NOW.
DPR IS WORKING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES BOARD IN
OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
HAZARD ASSESSMENT. TO RE
EVALUATE THIS PESTICIDE AND DO
ADDITIONAL MITIGATION MEASURES
AND RESTRICTIONS ON IT WE ARE
ANTICIPATING THAT -- BASED ON
THEIR TIME LINE IT WILL BE DONE
WITH THAT RE EVALUATION THIS
FALL.
SO DEEP HERE IS DOING ITS OWN
THING SEPARATE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT RIGHT NOW -- AS TO
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS TO THE
BILL FROM THE COMMITTEE MISTER
CHAIR WE APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATIONS WE HAD AND WE WE
APPRECIATE ALSO YOUR CONCERN
WITH CORPORATE FAST AND
UNDERSTAND WHERE THIS IS COMING
FROM UNFORTUNATELY WE STILL DO
HAVE TO STAY OPPOSED WITH THOSE
AMENDMENTS -- CALIFORNIA HAS
ACTUALLY BEEN DOING PESTICIDE
RESIDUE TESTING ON OUR
AGRICULTURAL COMMODITIES SENSE
NINETEEN TWENTY SIX SO WE'VE
BEEN DOING THIS IN CALIFORNIA
FOR A LONG TIME.
THAT HAS BECOME THE MOST ROBUST
PESTICIDE RESIDUE TESTING IN THE
ENTIRE NATION -- WHAT DO YOU
CARE DOES IS IT GOES OUT TO THE
FIELDS AND IT LOOKS IT COLLECTS
SAMPLES -- BECAUSE FARMERS
MARKETS -- PLACES OF DEPOT PORT
CENTER TO SEE IF A IN CDF.
FAA TESTS THOSE SUBJECTS FOR
OVER THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
PESTICIDES.
IF THERE IS ANY ILLEGAL
PESTICIDE RESIDUE ON THERE IT IS
IMMEDIATELY PULLED FROM THE
SHELVES SO WE ARE ALSO TESTING
THIS AND THE SPECIFICALLY LOOK
AT SAMPLES THAT IMPACT OR THAT
CHILDREN EAT FOOD THAT CHILDREN
TEND TO EAT AND ALSO THOSE.
COMMODITIES THAT MAY USE
CHEMICALS THAT -- WOULD HAVE
SOME TOXICITY TO THEM -- SO IN
CONCLUSION WE WOULD JUST
REQUESTED THAT THE COMMITTEE
LEAVE THIS TO THE REGULATORY
PROCESS LET THAT CONTINUE AND
NOT PANIC HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS CAROL BURNS
I'M A RETIRED EPIDEMIOLOGISTS
FROM THE DOW CHEMICAL COMPANY.
I OPPOSE THE PROPOSAL TO BAN
CHLORPYRIFOS.
ON A PERSONAL NOTE PLEASE DON'T
DISMISS MY COMMENTS BECAUSE I'M
A CONSULTANT FOR CAN CORTES.
I'M VERY INTERESTED IN THIS
CHEMICAL AND I HAVE BEEN FOR A
LONG TIME WHEN I STARTED WORKING
AT DOW I WAS PREGNANT WITH TWO
OF MY THREE TWELVE DIFFERENT
TIMES I WAS PREGNANT ONCE AND
BRING IT AGAIN START.
ANYWAY THE CLERK YOUR BUS PLAN
IS ACROSS THE STREET FROM MY
OFFICE.
SO I'M VERY INTERESTED IN THIS
AND LIVING IN A COMPANY TOWN.
THE PEOPLE THE MEN AND WOMEN TO
MAKE CLEAR PURIFY US ARE MY
FRIENDS MY NEIGHBORS MY KIDS
SOCCER COACHES.
MY VIEWS TODAY RESULT FROM
TWENTY YEARS OF CONDUCTING
RESEARCH AND REVIEWING THE
WEIGHT OF EVIDENCE OF
CHLORPYRIFOS NOT FROM MY
EMPLOYER.
FIRST IT'SIMPORTANT TO KEEP THE
SCIENTIFIC DISCUSSION FOCUSED ON
CORE PURIFY US.
CLIP YOUR PAST IS AN ORGANIC
PHOSPHATE BUT NOT ALL OUR GEAR
PHOSPHATES ARE CLICK HERE FOR US
THEY HAVE DIFFERENT TOXICOLOGY
PROFILES.
IF YOU'RE TAKING NOTES I APPEAL
TO YOU TO WRITE DOWN THESE THREE
ACRONYMS T. C. P..
D. E. P. E. N. D. A. P..
THERE IN INVERSE.
ORDER OF SPECIFICITY.
T. C. P. STANDS FOR TRICOR
APPEAREDIN ALL IS THE MOST
SPECIFIC METABOLITE OF
CHLORPYRIFOS.
D. ET DI APPLE BOSS FATE IS A
METABOLITE THAT REPRESENTS UP TO
TEN ORGAN PHOSPHATES.
AND DAB D. OUT DIE ALKA
PHOSPHATE REPRESENTS UP TO
TWENTY ONE DIFFERENT
INSECTICIDES.
IS THE BEST SCIENTIFIC PRACTICE
TO COMPARE LIKE FOR LIKE SO WHEN
YOU'RE LOOKING AT RESULTS PLEASE
LOOK FOR TCP OR D. E. P..
SECONDLY IN THE PAST TWENTY
YEARS IT'S BEEN MENTIONED.
THAT DPR REGULATION OF
CHLORPYRIFOS HAS RESULTED IN
CHANGED USES REDUCE DRIFT AND AS
A RESULT EXPOSURE POTENTIAL HAS
DECLINED IN CALIFORNIA. FOR THE
MOST PART THE STUDIES THAT ARE
BEING DISCUSSED ARE AND CHILDREN
BORN IN THE LATE NINETEEN
NINETIES IN THE FIRST DECADE OF
TWO THOUSAND THE TO NEW YORK
CITY STUDIES ARE ABOUT INDOOR
APPLICATIONS WHICH ARE NO LONGER
REGISTERED.
THERE ARE TWO AUTISM STUDIES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THAT RELIED
ON PROXIMITY ON AN APPLICATION
AND RESIDENTS.
AND THESE RECORDS WERE FROM THE
NINETEEN NINETIES TO TWO
THOUSAND TEN AND THAT THIS
ADDRESS WRAP UP UP AND COMING ON
WE REASSURINGLY THE AUTISM STUDY
OF CHILDREN BORN.
AFTERWARDS FOUND NO LINK OF
CHLORPYRIFOS.
FURTHER THE HOME STUDY IN OHIO
CAN DISPEL THE CONCERNS ABOUT
RESIDUE SINCE NO ADVERSE
ASSOCIATIONS WERE REPORTED.
I OF AND AGAINST THIS BILL.
THANK YOU OTHER -- IT IS IN
OPPOSITION GOOD AFTERNOON MR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MATTHEW
WELL WITH WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WE WOULD ASSOCIATE
COMMENTS MADE -- WITH THOSE MADE
BY AND THIS NON HATE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS MY CANNELLA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION WINE
GRAPE GROWERS RE -- RESPECT THE
OPPOSE THE BILL AND ALSO TODAY
IS OUR LOBBY DAY WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF GROWERS INDIA CAPITAL
TODAY ON THIS ISSUE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
BILL BERRYHILL COULD STAND
EVERYBODY UP THERE -- VERY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL LET YOUR
REGULATORS DO WHAT REGULATORS DO.
THANK YOU.
GOOD STUDENT CENTER.
HI JEFF OSTERMAN ALEGRE GROWERS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MY SLED BETTER VINO FARMS ONE
GRAPE GROWERS STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU.
KALRA LIMóN FOURTH GENERATION
FARMER STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
ANY BLACK A FARMER FROM WHAT I
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
HI OTHER BLACK FIRST GENERATION
GROW OR AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS TRICIA
GERINGER AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED.
THANK YOU.
TAYLOR OCEAN WITH A CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU DON CAP KIßM HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION ALSO
RESPECTFULLY POST THANK YOU.
THAT IS ALL BE ON A B. HAVE THE
ALLMAN ALLIANCE IN THE COMFORT
HERDERS OPPOSE THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
HI JULIE NOT ASK ABOUT THE HALF
OF THE AMERICAN CHEMISTRY
COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
DOUBLE A CALIFORNIA GROWERS SO
LET THE REGULATOR TO THE JOB.
I THINK THIS BILL.
THANK YOU RIGHT SEEN OTHER
PEOPLE MAKE PHONE QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
CENTER STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- MISS
BURN TO YOU SEEM TO HAVE WHERE
YOU GO.
THEY ARE OKAY -- YOU SEEM TO
HAVE A LOT OF EXPERIENCE WITH
THE CLERK -- FOSS -- CAN YOU
TALK ABOUT THE ASSERTION ABOUT
THE CORE PEER FAUCETS FOUND IN
THE HUMAN BODY.
WELL THE EVIDENCE FOR THAT
REALLY COMES FROM THE CDC
PROGRAM IN WHICH THERE BY
MANAGED COLLECTING URINE FROM.
A SAMPLE OF OF INDIVIDUALS
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES AND
INDEED WE DO SEE VERY LOW LEVELS
FAIRLY UBIQUITOUS SEE YOU
[inaudible]
ACROSS EVERYBODY.
BUT THERE'S A COUPLE THINGS TO
UNDERSTAND ABOUT THAT FIRST OF
ALL -- THEY'RE MEASURING
TRICOLOR APPEARED IN ALL AND
THAT'S REASSURING BECAUSE IT'S
TELLING US THAT IT'S BREAKING
DOWN IN THE BODY IT DOESN'T
PERSIST IT'S IT'S BEING CLEARED
RAPIDLY.
BUT WHAT WE ALSO KNOW IS THAT
CLEAR PURE BUS BREAKS DOWN IN
THE ENVIRONMENT ALSO TO TRY
CLEAR APPEARED IN ALL.
SO IT'S BEEN ESTIMATED BY -- A
GOVERNMENT SCIENTIST THAT UP
280% OF WHAT YOU'RE DETECTING IN
HUMAN URINE.
IS TRICOLOR APPEARED IN ALL THAT
WAS ON YOUR FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES NOT THE PARENT CLICK
HERE FOR US SO THIS A BURSTING
WHAT WERE MAJOR IN ISN'T CLERK
YOUR BOSS AT ALL.
SECONDLY FOR TRICOR APPEARED IN
ALL IS VERY NON TOXIC AS A VERY
DIFFERENT TOXICOLOGY PROFILE
BAND CHLORPYRIFOS.
THIRDS CDC ITSELF REMINDS US
THAT JUST DETECTING SOMETHING
DOESN'T IN FOR HARM.
AND BECAUSE OUR ANALYTICAL
CHEMISTRY IS SO -- ROBUST NOW WE
CAN DETECT VERY VERY SMALL
AMOUNTS THAT WE COULDN'T DO
TWENTY YEARS AGO [inaudible]
OKAY -- SO BASICALLY YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU'RE MONITORING THE
METABOLITES THAT'S RIGHT AND SO
THE THE HUMAN LIVER IS VERY --
GOOD AT CLEARING OUT -- TOXINS
WHICH IS SUPPOSED TO DO -- BUT
ONE THING IT DOESN'T DO AS IT
DOESN'T TALK ABOUT -- WHAT THE
THE ACTIVE INGREDIENT IS DOING
TO THE BODY PRIOR TO IT BEING
METABOLIZED RIGHT?
I MEAN IT'S IT DOES POTENTIALLY
HAVE SOME AFFECTS.
SO WE'VE HEARD SOME DISCUSSION --
BY THE OTHERS SPEAKERS TODAY
ABOUT -- THE EFFECTS THAT ARE
SEEN IN LABORATORY ANIMALS AND I
WOULD REMIND THEM THAT -- DOES
LABORATORY ANIMAL STUDIES ARE
DONE AT A MILLION TIMES HIGHER.
AND WHAT WE'RE SEEING IT AND THE
HUMAN BODIES IN THESE -- BY
MONITORING PROGRAMS AND THE FOOD
RESIDENTS A MILLION TIMES.
OKAY.
SO THE P. R. IS GONE INVOLVED
AND JUSTIFIABLY SO AND I AND I'M
NOT SURE I UNDERSTAND WHY WE'RE
PREEMPTING THEIR REVIEW.
BUT THE NOW CLASSIFIED AS A
RESTRICTED MATERIAL ONLY TRAINED
LICENSED PROFESSIONALS BUT THE
PERMIT -- FROM A LOCAL COUNTY
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONER MAY
USE THESE PRODUCTS CONTAINING
THE PESTICIDE.
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN IT
WAS ADDED TO CALIFORNIA'S PROP
SIXTY MY LIST OF CHEMICALS KNOWN
TO CAUSE REPRODUCTIVE HARM
[inaudible]
AND SO -- IT HAS ALSO BEEN SHOWN
THAT THE UTILIZATION OF THIS
PESTICIDE IS DOWN 50% FROM
200-052-2000 SIXTEEN ARE THERE
ANY.
MODERN EPIDEMIOLOGICAL STUDIES.
THAT SHOW WHAT'S HAPPENING -- IN
THE TWO WEEKS TO TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN TIME PERIOD
RIGHT SO MOST EPIDEMIOLOGY
STUDIES THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT -- OF OUR OWN CHILDREN
BORN LONG BEFORE THAT -- THERE
ARE SOME MORE RECENT STUDIES OF
NOT IN CALIFORNIA ONE IN THE
NETHERLANDS ALSO SHOWING NO
ADVERSE EFFECTS -- WITH RESPECT
HI Q. -- WE HAD THE RECENT
AUTISM STUDY FROM UC DAVIS
SHOWING NO -- ATTACKS WITH FOR
PURE BOSTON ARTISAN SO I THINK
THOSE KINDS OF STUDIES GIVE THIS
REASSURANCE THAT -- WE ARE THE
MODERN DAY METHODS OR THE MODERN
DAY STUDY METHODOLOGY AREN'T
SHOWING AN EFFECT.
OKAY AND AND SO -- WHAT IS YOUR
RESPONSE? TO THREE PROPONENTS.
LIST OF WHAT APPEARS TO BE SOME
VERY INTELLIGENT PEOPLE.
WITH MD DEGREES PH DIS -- THAT
ARE RAISING THE FLAGS ARE
CONCERNED WHAT BOOK WHAT WOULD
YOU TELL US THAT ARE READING
THESE [inaudible]
THESE WARNINGS.
RIGHT WELL AND AND MY COLLEAGUE
HERE I I YOU KNOW I RESPECT
THEIR THEIR OPINIONS AND SO
FORTH BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT.
TO COMPARE LIKE WITH LIKE THAT
WE CAN'T JUST COMPARE ALL
ORGANIC PHOSPHATES IN THIS
CONVERSATION TODAY ABOUT
CHLORPYRIFOS.
THE QUESTION IS IS IT CLICK HERE
FOR US THAT'S THE QUESTION ON
THE TABLE AND IT'S EASY TO LOOK
AT ALL OUR GAL FIVE SPEEDS AND
MANY DIFFERENT -- DISEASES IN
DIFFERENT STUDIES THE SCIENTIFIC
PROCESS DEMANDS THAT WE LOOK
LIKE FOR LIKE.
IF WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT I. Q.
LIST LOOK AT I. Q. -- THE
COLUMBIA STUDY LOOKED AT WORKING
MEMORY WELL THE TO MARCUS STUDY
DIDN'T FIND AT SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT.
TO FOCUS ON CLICK HERE FOR US
TODAY -- DESPITE -- APPEARANCES
THAT YOU KNOW THERE MAY BE A FAX
ALLEN A BROADER SCALE.
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT IN THE LETTER
DOES TALK ABOUT KEFIR FAUCET IT
DOES TALK ABOUT OTHER ORGAN
PHOSPHATE SO IT'S IT IS KINDA
LUMPING EVERYTHING TOGETHER.
BUT THERE ARE INTERMISSIONS
WHICH ICLUDES BANNING ALL
AERIAL APPLICATIONS OF CLICK
HERE FONT.
DISCONTINUED USE ON MOST CROPS
IT'LL BE RESTRICTED TO CRITICAL
CROPS SO WHAT I'D LIKE TO KNOW
IS OKAY IF THIS BAND WERE TO
BECOME LAW.
WHAT CROPS IN CALIFORNIA ARE WE
AT RISK OF?
NOT BEING ABLE TO APPROPRIATELY
GROW.
THANK YOU SENATOR OF OUR KNOWING
HE CHECK -- SO SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE DO HAVE LIKE IN
OUR CITRUS GROVES.
IS -- THEIR SUGAR RAMPS THESE
ALSO AFFECTS SOME OF OUR NOT
CROPS AND UNFORTUNATELY IT'S
JUST VERY VERY HARD TO KNOCK
DOWN SUGAR AND POPULATIONS --
THEY'RE VERY AGGRESSIVE
CHLORPYRIFOS IS ONE IS IS THE
ONLY THING THAT'S EFFECTIVE ON
THEM AND KNOCKING DOWN THEIR
POPULATIONS AND ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS WE SHOULD GRANT.
IS THAT THEY PROTECT OTHER
INVASIVE PESTS BECAUSE THEY LIKE
TO COLLECT THE HONEY DO YOU OFF
OF THOSE PASSED IN THE NAY
ACTUALLY HER HARM BENEFICIAL
INSECTS.
SO WHEN YOU GET THESE
INFESTATION OF SUGAR ANTS YOU
JUST NEED TO KNOCK HIM DOWN
BECAUSE THEY'RE HOARDING OTHER
PASS AND HURTING ARE BENEFICIAL
INSECTS -- ANOTHER ONE ON OUR ON
<c.green>OTTON -- THERE IS ANY IF IT</c>
DIED -- IS DETRIMENTAL TO COTTON
IT CAUSES IT IT'S CALLED STICKY
COTTON -- AND IT BASICALLY
BECOMES SO THAT YOU CAN'T SELL
YOUR COTTON -- CHLORPYRIFOS IN
THIS WAS DONE BY RESEARCH BY THE
UC'S IS THE ONLY.
TOOL THAT YOU CAN USE ON THIS
PAST AND IF THAT CAN'T BECOME
STICKY -- THE MILLS WILL REJECT
IT SO BASICALLY YOUR CROP IS
GONE SO THOSE ARE JUST SOME OF
THE EXAMPLES OF WHY WE NEED A
AND AGAIN LIKE I SAID THIS IS
JUST ONE TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX.
FARMERS TRY ALL DIFFERENT TYPES
OF METHODS BEFORE THEY GET TO
KIND OF THIS ORGANIC PHOSPHATE
AND USING CORPORA FOSS BUT
SOMETIMES WITH THESE INVASIVE
PESTS THERE'S REALLY NOTHING
ELSE.
OUT THERE THAT JUST KNOCKS THEM
DOWN AND GET THEM OUT OF THE WAY
OKAY SO SO THE THE SENATOR --
MADE REFERENCE TO TO RATE THAT --
WE USED TO BE IN RATE AND THEN
IT WAS RECLASSIFIED IF ANOTHER
CHEMICAL THAT COULD DO THE JOB
SO.
AFTER HEARING WHAT YOU JUST SAID
IS IT FAIR TO SAY THAT -- THIS
THIS PESTICIDE IS USES A LAST
RESULT RESORT TO SAVE A PRODUCT
THAT WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO
CULTIVATE A CALIFORNIA CORRECT
OKAY AND THEN -- ON THE PASSAGE
PESTICIDE RESIDUE ISSUE YOU KNOW
YOU YOU YOU EXPLAIN HOW IT THE
CROPS ARE TESTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS NO RESIDUE SO IS
IT UP TO THE FARMER TO ENSURE
THAT WHEN THOSE ARE DELIVERED
THEIR THEIR CROPS -- LET'S SEE
THE THE ORANGES OR OR WHATEVER
TO THE GROCERY STORE WHO'S
RESPONSIBLE TO CLEAN THOSE CROPS
TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS NO
RESIDUE.
AND THAT DOES COME UNDER FARMERS
AND PACKING SHEDS AND HOWEVER
THAT SUPPLY CHAIN GOES PART OF
NOT HAVING RESIDUE ON YOUR CROPS
THOUGH IS THOSE RESTRICTIONS
THAT DPR HAS PUT IN PLACE.
OF WHEN THINGS CAN BE APPLIED
ONE REENTRY IS HOW YOU HAVE TO
APPLY THEM BEFORE HARVEST SO
THERE'S A LOT OF RESTRICTIONS IN
PLACE ON ALL PESTICIDES.
ON WHEN AND HOW YOU APPLY THEM
TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS NOT
RESIDUE.
THEN THERE STEPS AFTER THAT AND
THEN THAT'S WHEN DPR STEPS IN
AND SAMPLES TO ENSURE THAT NO
ONE'S DOING ANYTHING ILLEGALLY --
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE WE REALLY
GET INTO THESE ISSUES BUT
THERE'S RESTRICTIONS ON THE
GROUND AND THEN FARMERS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING THAT
THOSE ARE BEING FOLLOWED SO
THERE IS NOT THIS RESIDUE ISSUE
SO IS IT FAIR TO SAY THAT IT IS
THE CONSUMER THIS MAN.
DOESN'T HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF ENSURING THAT THE RESIDUE IS
NOT ON THE FRUIT THAT IS UP TO
THE THE GROWER AT CENTER ACT AND
THAT'S WHY DEEP HERE AND SEE IF
THEY HAVE PARTNERED UP AND WHY
THERE IS SUCH A ROBUST.
PROGRAM TO ENSURE -- IN
20001796% OF THE SAMPLES HAD
EITHER NO DETECTION A RESIDUE OR
WAS FAR BELOW USEPA TOLERANCE
LEVELS THAT WERE REQUIRED.
OF THE 4% THAT DID HAVE LEGAL
RESIDUE 72% OF THAT WAS FROM OUT
OF COUNTRY SO THAT SOME OF THE
RESIDUE ISSUES THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH TO THESE ARE COMING
FROM.
OUT OF COUNTRY IN CALIFORNIA WE
ARE VERY RESTRICTIVE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ANSWERS.
THANK YOU CEREMONY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ON THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD IN [inaudible]
SOME.
APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY OF
SUPPORTERS AND OPPONENTS -- YOU
KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
PESTICIDES IN USE IN CALIFORNIA.
DURING MY WORK THAT INVOLVED
REPRESENTING VICTIMS OF
PESTICIDE EXPOSURE.
WE SAW A DD EIGHTEEN T. OKAY
MEDICINE STOCKS ARE VERY
DIFFERENT PESTICIDES YOU KNOW
THEY HAD IN COMMON.
THEY WERE ALL EVENTUALLY BANNED
BY THE EPA AFTER.
FARMWORKERS HAD SUFFERED ILLNESS.
A CHRONIC.
ILLNESS BIRTH DEFECTS IN
WRONGFUL DEATH AFTER EXPOSURE --
THE CHEMICALS THAT WERE APPROVED
BY THE EPA.
THE ONES THAT I MENTIONED ALL
USE SOMETHING CALLED ECONOMIC
NECESSITY.
SO THEY FOR STONE GOING THROUGH
THE PHONE ANIMAL STUDIES AND
ALLOWED EXPEDITED ACCESS OF THE
CHEMICALS INTO THE MARKET PLACE
BECAUSE THEY WERE SO IMPORTANT.
FOR USE IN AGRICULTURE.
THAT WAS IN AN ERA WHEN
FARMWORKERS.
WERE [inaudible]
REALLY -- DISCOUNTED.
IN THE CONCERN FOR EXPOSURE.
FAST FORWARD TO TODAY IN TWO
CONSTITUENTS OF MINE.
SCHOOL TEACHERS PARENTS STUDENTS
CONCERNED ABOUT APPLICATIONS
NEAR SCHOOLS.
SO DPR HAS CONVENED PUBLIC
HEARINGS.
DAVE.
CREATED GREATER CONTROLS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS.
NO APPLICATION DURING SCOOL
HOURS.
SO THAT THAT PROTECTS STUDENTS
IN SCHOOL DURING SCHOOL HOURS.
BUT THEN I CREATE SO A WINDOW ON
WEEKENDS.
THAT IF YOU CAN'T SPREE DURING
SCHOOL HOURS YOU'RE GONNA SPRING
ON THE WEEKEND.
SO THERE MAY NOT BE STUDENTS IN
CLASSES AT THE SCHOOL.
BUT IF THERE RESIDENTS IN
NEIGHBORHOODS NEAR THAT SCHOOL.
THEY ARE NOT EVACUATED THEY ARE
NOT WORN SO THEY ARE NOT
NECESSARILY PROTECTED.
AND THEY MAY ALSO BE THE HOMES
OF CHILDREN THAT ATTEND THAT
NEIGHBOR OR SCHOOL.
THE SCIENTIFIC INFORMATION.
WE ALWAYS GET TONED IT'S NOT
CONCLUSIVE WE DON'T KNOW ENOUGH
LET'S JUST STUDY A LITTLE BIT
LONGER.
WELL.
IF YOU ARE THE PARENT OF A CHILD
WHO HAS SUFFERED FROM EXPOSURE.
AND IF YOU LIVE IN THE SALINAS
VALLEY AND YOUR KIDS THAT LIVE
AROUND THE SPREE AREAS.
HAVE SHOWN PROVEN -- THE
DEFICIENCY IN I. Q. AND BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT -- YOU CAN'T WAIT.
FOR ANOTHER TWO YEARS.
ANOTHER TEN YEARS ANOTHER TWENTY
YEARS -- THIS LEGISLATURE HAS
NOT PRACTICED [inaudible]
PICKING CHEMICALS IN BANNING
THEM.
VERY FREQUENTLY THE LAST TIME I
REMEMBER WAS WITH THE CHEMICAL
CALLED METHYL AYE AND DIED.
IN IT WAS SEEN AS A GOOD
ALTERNATIVE TO METHYL BROMIDE
WHICH IS AN OZONE DEPLETING.
SO WAS LESS TOXIC TO THE
ENVIRONMENT.
INTERESTINGLY IT WAS OF MUCH
GREATER TOXICITY.
IN HUMAN EXPOSURE.
IT COULD BE LETHAL IN VERY VERY
SMALL AMOUNTS.
THE MANUFACTURE ON THAT ONE
EVENTUALLY WITHDREW ITS REQUEST
FOR PERMANENT FOR USE IN
CALIFORNIA.
IN ALL THE CROPS THAT SAID DEAN
DEPENDED ON THE USE OF MATH
ONLINE DIED TO SURVIVE.
THEY'RE STILL BEING GROWN IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO I THINK ULTIMATELY.
IT IS A BALANCING TEST.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE WORK OF
DPR TO EXPAND THE BUFFER ZONES.
TO MAYBE DO SOME MORE MONITORING
AND TO TRY TO PROTECT SCHOOL
SITES.
THERE'S ALWAYS THE EXCEPTIONS OF
WHO DOES GET EXPOSED AYE AYE.
THAT'S A BIT OF A STATEMENT I
NOW I DO WANT TO ASK THE
PROPONENT WITNESSES EITHER ONE
OF YOU.
THE SCIENTISTS.
WE READ ABOUT.
TOLERANCE LEVELS RESIDUE LEVELS --
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT A LOT
OF THE EPA TOLERANCE LEVELS ARE
BASED ON SOME OF THEM GO BACK TO
WORLD WAR.
TWO SOLDIERS MAN A HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE POUNDS OR HEAVIER.
DOES THAT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT AN
INFANT OR A CHILD WHO MAY BE --
A QUARTER OF THAT NGUYEN.
AN EIGHTH OF THAT LINK
[inaudible]
SENATOR THE EPA DOES LOOK AT
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF EXPOSURE FOR
DIFFERENT AGE GROUPS.
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS THAT WHEN
THEY LOOKED AT D. EXPOSURE
LEVELS TO CORPORATE COSTS ON
FOOD IN THEIR LAST RISK
ASSESSMENT UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY FOUND THAT INFANTS WERE
EXPOSED TO NINETY TIMES WHAT THE
AGENCY CONSIDERED SAFE -- EXPOSE
THE CHILDREN WANTED TO YEARS OF
AGE ARE EXPOSED TO ONE HUNDRED
AND FORTY TIMES.
BUT THE AGENCY CONSIDERS SAFE.
AND SO EPA.
BASED ON THEIR METHODOLOGY.
THIS FINDING THAT -- CORPORATE
FALLS ON FOOD DOES POSE RISKS TO
INFANTS AND CHILDREN.
AND HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AS PART OF A DVRS REVIEW.
OF CORPORATE COSTS THE
DEPARTMENT DID CONDUCT A TOXIC
AIR CONTAMINANT EVALUATION AND
THEY LIKE WHAT IT'S LIKE USEPA.
FOUND THAT THE LEVELS OF
EXPOSURE TO PREPARE A FALSE ON
FOOD AND THE DRINKING WATER --
WERE UNSAFE FOR INFANTS FOR
YOUNG CHILDREN FOR OLDER
CHILDREN AND FOR WOMEN OF
REPRODUCTIVE AGE.
SO WE HAVE THIS CONSISTENCY
ACROSSTHE AGENCIES THAT LOOKED
AT THIS ISSUE.
AND THEY FOUND THAT CHILDREN ARE
EXPOSED TO TOO MUCH QUICKER
FALLS ON FOOD.
IS THAT A FAIR STATEMENT TO SAY
I THINK IN YOUR STATEMENT.
THAT THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION
EPA HAD REACHED A CONCLUSION.
TO DISALLOW THE CONTINUED USE OF
CORE PAIR FOR US.
YES THEY CONCLUDED BASED ON
THEIR RISK ASSESSMENTS THAT
CORPORATE BOSS DOES NOT MEET THE
SAFETY STANDARD AND THEY DID
PROPOSED A BAN ON ALL FOOD USES
OF CORPORATE OFFICE.
IN THE RESTORATION OF THE FROM.
THE GREEN LIGHT IF YOU WILL BY
THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION
THAT'S CURRENTLY BEING
CHALLENGED IN THE COURTS.
BUT YES IT IS SENATOR AND THAT'S
WHY LAST YEAR A FEDERAL APPEALS
COURT.
ORDER THE EPA TO PANEL USES A
CORPORATE BOSS AND WHAT'S THE
STATUS OF THAT LITIGATION SAID
ON APPEAL NOW.
IT HAS BEEN APPEALED FURTHER BY
USEPA AN ORAL ARGUMENT IN THAT
APPEAL WAS HEARD LAST MONTH --
THE PROCESS IS LIKELY TO
CONTINUE FOR A GREAT DEAL OF
TIME.
IN PENDING THE CONCLUSION OF THE
LITIGATION IS SEEN.
SOME.
THE PRIOR DETERMINATION TO
DISCONTINUE THE USE STATE.
IN OTHER WORDS THEY CAN CONTINUE
TO USE IT PENDING.
THE OUTLANDER FOSTER'S CONTINUE
TO BE USED ON FOOD DESPITE US
CPS CONCLUSIONS AND DESPITE THE
PRS CONCLUSIONS THANK YOU -- IF
I COULD MISTER CHAIR JUST A
FINAL QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR --
WE WERE PROVIDED -- A DRAFT OF
PROPOSED SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS -- YOU MIGHT HAVE
MENTIONED THIS BUT ARE ARE YOU
ACCEPTING THESE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
IN THIS I READ THIS -- THERE ARE.
TWO SEPARATE CRITERIA THAT WOULD
HAVE TO BE MET. TO ALLOW FOR THE
RESTORATION OF THE USE AND IT'S
BASED ON SCIENCE AND IT'S BASED
ON LOOKING AT THE EFFICACY OF
CONTROL MEASURES ADOPTED BY T.
P. R..
IN A INDEPENDENT DETERMINATION
THAT THOSE WOULD NOT RESULT IN
RURAL DEVELOPMENT HARM TO
CHILDREN SECRETARY -- SO.
THOSE WOULD BE THE AMENDMENT SO
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR HER WORK ON THIS FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE TRAVELED -- I DO
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS OF
AGRICULTURE I THINK ONE THING
THAT MARKS THE HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE IS
ADAPTATION.
ADAPTATION THE WEATHER
ADAPTATION TO WATER TO DROUGHT --
ADAPTATION TO CHANGING SOIL
CONDITIONS AND IT'S HAD TO
INCLUDE THE ADAPTATION TO
DIFFERENT CHEMICALS THAT HAVE
COME ON THE MARKET IN CHEMICALS
THAT HAVE BEEN.
REQUIRED TO LEAVE THE MARKET SO --
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS TODAY
I AM -- APPRECIATE.
THAT WE PUT THE FOCUS TODAY ON
THE PREVENTIVE IN PRECAUTIONARY
APPROACH TO PROTECTING.
THE CHILDREN OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHER ETCETERA I THOUGHT IT.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THINK THAT THE
FAMILIES FOR A MEETING WITH ME
AND MY STAFF OVER THE LAST TWO
WEEKS AT THIS.
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE AND HOW
IMPORTANT THIS BILL IS TO
FAMILIES AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
AND ARE.
YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE BOTH
SUPPORTERS AND OPPONENTS OF THIS
BILL FOR MEETING WITH US I STILL
HAVE SEVERAL QUESTIONS THAT HAVE
NOT.
BEEN ANSWERED ON BOTH SIDES AND
I'M JUST I'M TRIP I'M DEEPLY
TROUBLED I CAN'T SLEEP -- THIS
IS THAT THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTS
SPECIFICALLY MY DISTRICT.
AND I THINK THAT IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE A DECISION ONE WAY
OR ANOTHER I NEED THESE ANSWERS
QUESTIONS.
ANSWERED THESE QUESTIONS
ANSWERED FOR THE SAKE OF THE
PEOPLE THAT I REPRESENT BECAUSE
I NEED TO BE ABLE TO JUSTIFY
THEM WHY I WENT YES OR WHY I
WENT NO.
AND NEITHER SIDE HAS BEEN ABLE
TO PROVIDE ME WITH THE FACTS ON
THE YOU KNOW BASIC OF QUESTIONS
THAT I HAVE PASSED.
AND YOU KNOW EXCUSE MY YOU KNOW
MY IGNORANCE ON THIS ISSUE BUT
IT I FEEL THAT THESE ARE JUST
KEY QUESTIONS THAT I NEED TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE.
A DECISION EITHER YES OR NO AND
SO YOU KNOW MONTH SO QUESTIONS
LIKE THE NUMBER OF PERMITS.
THAT ARE IN DISTRICT FORT SENATE
DISTRICT FOURTEEN THAT HAVE THAT
HAVE BEEN GIVEN OUT -- AND IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- ALSO
WHEN IT COMES TO RESIDUE AND
THEN.
STILL TRY TO GET AN
UNDERSTANDING I KNOW THAT WHEN
IT COMES TO CITRUS A LOT OF IT
IS BEING EXPORTED I KNOW YOU
MENTIONED -- HOW ARE?
ARE YOU KNOW.
A LOT OF THE FOOD THAT WE EAT
AND AND IT'S FOUND IN THE YOU
KNOW AS AS RESIDUE AND WHAT'S
FOUND IN OUR BODY -- IS BEING
IMPORTED SO WHAT -- WHAT IS B.
E. YOU KNOW AT THE PERCENTAGE OF
THE AMOUNT THAT WE WERE
PURCHASING AT THE STORES WHAT --
YOU KNOW HOW MUCH OF IT.
THAT WORK IS SIX CONSUMING IS IT
FROM -- IMPORTER PRODUCTS VERSUS
UP YOU KNOW -- YOU KNOW LOCALLY
GROWN PRODUCTS.
I DON'T KNOW IF ANY OF YOU HAVE
ANY ANSWERS FOR ANY OF THOSE
QUESTIONS BUT I DON'T HAVE THE
EXACT NUMBER ON THAT BY BE HAPPY
TO LOOK INTO.
IMPORTS FORCES EXPORTS ON A LOT
OF THESE COMMODITIES.
SO -- AGAIN IT ONE THING THAT I
FIND REASSURING IT BACK TO THE
QUESTION ABOUT -- THE LEVELS IN
URINE BECAUSE THAT THAT IS THE
FUNCTION ONE OF THE THE VALUES
OF THE CDC BIO MONITORING
PROGRAM BECAUSE IT ESSENTIALLY
IS THAT NEXT LEVEL OF TESTING SO.
WE HAVE PROGRAMS ALL AROUND THE
COUNTRY TO TEST RESIDUES IMPORTS
AND AND OTHERWISE IN OUR MARKET
BASKET SURVEYS RESIDUE CENTER
FOOD AT STEP.
ONE THE QUESTION IS WHAT WHAT'S
GETTING INTO OUR BODIES THAT'S
WHAT WE REALLY WANT TO KNOW
BECAUSE BY THE TIME YOU BRING IT
HOME FROM THE GROCERY STORE.
AND YOU WATCH IT YOU PREPARE IT.
THAT RESIDUE MAY BE GONE ANYWAY.
SO WHAT WE'RE FINDING IS WHAT
WE'RE NOT FINDING IS THAT THE
LEVELS IN CHILDREN.
WOMEN AND MEN IN AMERICA ACROSS
THE SAMPLE.
IS VERY VERY LOW AND CERTAINLY
THAT'S A QUESTION FOR THIS PANEL
AND FOR THE U. S. EPA FOR DPR IS
IS WHAT IS LOW MAINTENANCE THAT
LOW ENOUGH.
I MEAN THAT'S A THAT'S A WHOLE
NOTHER DAY'S TOPIC BUT BUT THAT
IS THE REASSURANCE TO ME AS A AS
A MOTHER.
THAT THE RESIDUES ARE NOT
[inaudible]
UNDULY PROBLEMATIC.
SO I'LL GO AHEAD AND AND FINISH
THE QUESTIONS AND IF YOU HAVE A
THE ANSWERS TWENTY OF THEM
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO SPEAK UP --
YOU KNOW BUT I I WILL SAY THAT I
MIXED YOU KNOW EXTREMELY
CONCERNED WITH -- DPR NOT BEING
ABLE TO RESOLVE THIS -- WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO BE HERE WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO WAIT THE
SHOULD BE ALREADY RESOLVED SO --
YOU KNOW WILL BE UPSTANDING FROM
THIS BILL TODAY BUT I WANT TO GO
AHEAD AND CHALLENGE.
BOTH TO BOTH SIDES TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE ME WITH THE ANSWERS TO
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS I'LL BE
ASKING.
SO MONTHS THOSE ARE -- WHEN
THERE APPEARS TO BE COMPETING
SCIENCE ANY PARTICULAR PESTICIDE
AND ITS IMPACT ON MY
CONSTITUENTS AND ALL
CALIFORNIANS WHAT STATE AGENCY
IS CALLED UPON TO VALIDATE
FINDINGS?
NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO DO WE HAVE
HEALTH DATA FROM THE STATE THAT
ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE.
WHY WHY HAS IT TAKEN SO LONG FOR
THE STATE? TO REACT TO THIS
ISSUE.
DO WE NEED TO REVIEW THE PROCESS
CURRENTLY BEING USED TO ANALYZE
ANALYZE DATA ON PESTICIDE USE IN
IMPACTS TO HAVE CONFIDENCE IN
THE POLICIES BEING APPLIED.
HOW MANY FARMWORKERS DO WE HAVE
IN CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIA
THAT ARE IMPACTED BY THIS
PESTICIDE?
WHAT TYPE OF JOB FOR ME
POSITIONS ARE IMPACTED BY THIS
LEGISLATION?
WHAT JOBS ARE IMPACTED OUTSIDE
FARMS LIKE?
TRUCKERS ARE PACKING HOUSES.
KIND OF BACK TO CHEAT ON THE
RESIDUE -- ISSUES WHILE WILL
THERE BE.
A LOSS OF FARM WORKING JOBS IF
THIS PASSES.
IF SO HOW MANY.
BY AND DO WE HAVE OTHER JOB
OPPORTUNITIES LINED UP FOR THEM
IF SO.
AND ACCORDING TO THE STUDY
RESIDUE EXPOSURE CAN CAUSE US
HARM TO CHILL AND DO WE KNOW
THAT. TO THE EXTENT OF THE
IMPACT OF RESIDUE EXPOSURE
VISITS VERSUS APPLICATION
EXPOSURE.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF CALIFORNIA
GROWN PRODUCTS ARE FOUND IN
CALIFORNIA GROCERY STORES AS A
TOUCHED ON EARLIER?
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF NON
CALIFORNIA GROWN PRODUCTS ARE
FOUND IN CALIFORNIA GROCERY
STORES?
ARE THESE PRODUCTS GROANING
CALIFORNIA MOSTLY EXPORTED HOW
MUCH OF THESE PRODUCTS TO
CURRENT DUKE CURRENTLY WE IMPORT.
AND HOW IS THAT EXPOSURE
MEASURED SO.
IF YOU HAVE ANY OF THOSE.
YOU KNOW ASK QUESTIONS.
THE ANSWERS TO THE ANY OF THOSE
QUESTIONS PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
ANSWER THEM NOW BUT I'D BE HAPPY.
TO CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS AS WE
MOVE ALONG.
YEAH I'M ALL TO SAY A FEW WORDS --
ABOUT -- THIS ISSUE OF
DISCREPANCIES A ACROSS STUDIES --
ONE OF THE WAYS IN WHICH AS
SCIENTISTS WHEN WE'LL EVALUATING
A BODY OF EVIDENCE -- IS THAT.
WE EXPECT TO BE SOME
INCONSISTENCY FROM ONE
POPULATION TO THE NEXT BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE DIFFERENT DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES MAY HAVE OTHER CO
EXPOSURES OTHER.
HEALTH ISSUES -- BUT HERE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT BRAIN DEVELOPMENT
AND WHETHER ONE SAID THE HAPPENS
TO FIND I. Q. AND OTHER ONE
FINDS AUTISM ANOTHER ONE FINDS
ADHD ALL OF THESE ARE SERIOUS.
DEFICITS IN PEOPLE'S ABILITY TO
FUNCTION AND TO LEAD FULL
PRODUCTIVE LIVES AND REACH THEIR
POTENTIAL.
SO I THINK -- WE DON'T NEED TO
MAKE THOSE DISTINCTIONS IN OTHER
WORDS THIS IS BEYOND IF ONE
STUDY IS SEEING A LITTLE MORE
SOMETHING ELSE -- AS FAR AS
APPLICATIONS VERSUS WHAT -- YOU
KNOW AND WHAT'S IN THE FOOD.
THERE HAVE BEEN ACTUALLY SEVERAL
VERY STRONG STUDIES SHOWING THAT
IF YOU TAKE IT A FAMILY AND YOU
REPLACE THEIR CONVENTIONAL
CONVENTIONALLY GROWN PRODUCE.
WITH ORGANICALLY GROWN PRODUCE.
WITHIN A WEEK ALL OF THOSE
RESIDUES IN THE URINE ARE GONE.
IN OTHER WORDS.
THEY ARE NOT ABSORBING IT.
FROM THIS IS IN CHILDREN THIS IS
IN YOUNG CHILDREN -- SEVERAL
STUDIES THAT HAVE HAVE ACTUALLY
DONE THAT EXPERIMENT.
AND REMOVED THE CONVENTIONAL
PRODUCE THAT HAD IT WOULD HAVE
HAD PESTICIDE RESIDUES AND
THEY'RE NOT FINDING THESE THESE
CHEMICALS SO -- THAT SEEMS TO BE
A MAJOR ROUTE OF EXPOSURE IS
THROUGH THE FOOD RESIDUES.
ARE BASED ON THE SCIENCE THAT'S
BEEN DONE ON THOSE.
ARE AND AND THEN IN TERMS OF
APPLICATIONS AND REALLY WHETHER
PEOPLE EXPOSED TO AND I'M GONNA
REFER TO THE AUTISM STUDY THAT --
I I ACTUALLY IN THE SENIOR
AUTHOR ON THE CAME OUT OF UC
DAVIS.
AND IN THAT CITY WE USE THE THE
THE AMOUNT OF POUNDS THAT HAVE
BEEN APPLIED.
AROUND THE HOME WITHIN A MILE OR
SO.
AND THAT WAS THE MEASURE THAT WE
USE TO DETERMINE WHO IS EXPOSING
WHO WASN'T.
WE FOUND THAT THE MOTHERS WHO
WERE EXPOSED TO THE CLERK HERE
PH<c.cyan>PECIFICALLY FOR PARA</c>
FIRST APPLICATIONS NOT ARE THERE
ORGAN OF PHOSPHATE TEST SITES --
WERE THE ONES THAT HAD THE
HIGHEST CHRIS FOR AUTISM AND IF
IT WAS IN THE SECOND TRIMESTER
WE SAW A THREEFOLD HIGHER RISK
FOR AUTISM IN THOSE CHILDREN.
THERE'S ALSO A STUDY THAT GOES
BACK OUT OF A WILD EARLIER THAN
THAT CITY BY THE WAY MOST OF
THOSE CHILDREN WERE AFTER THE
BAND -- THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THEM WERE BORN AFTER THE BAND ON
THE HOUSEHOLD USE OF PESTICIDES
TO THE REALLY IT'S IT WAS THE
AGRICULTURAL -- APPLICATIONS
THAT WERE.
THAT WE WERE LOOKING AT IN THAT
STUDY.
AND I THINK MAYBE THAT WAS IT I
HAD ANOTHER POINT THAT I'VE
GOTTEN ITSELF.
HAPPY TO PROVIDE AT THE
QUESTIONS TO YOU -- AS WELL
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU YOU'RE RAISING THE
QUESTIONS AND WE'LL BE GLAD TO A
FOLLOW UP AS WELL AND PROVIDE
YOU WITH ANSWERS.
CENTER STONE.
THANKS AGAIN -- MISTER CHAIR --
I WANTED TO STACK COMMAND CENTER
CUT -- I THINK YOU HAVE SOME
VERY GOOD QUESTIONS AND WHEN YOU
WHEN YOU GET THE ANSWERS THOSE
QUESTIONS I I WOULD LIKE.
TO THE WEAPON MIND SHARING THAT
WITH ME I WOULD I WOULD GREATLY
APPRECIATED.
I'M ALSO -- A LITTLE BIT
CONCERNED IN THAT -- YOU KNOW WE
HAVE A LOT OF AGENCIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE HAVE
A SPECIFIC AGENCY THIS SUPPOSED
TO BE GIVING US.
OBJECTIVE -- ADVICE ON THESE
CHEMICALS SOME OF WHICH ARE VERY
DANGEROUS TO SENATOR MONNING HAS
ALLUDED TO THEY'RE NO LONGER ON
THE MARKET -- I'M ACTUALLY
DISMAYED AND A LITTLE BIT
ALARMED AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION DOESN'T
HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE HERE.
AND TO TELL US WHERE THEY ARE IN
THE EVALUATION OF THIS PESTICIDE.
THAT -- IS BEING ALLEGED BY
COMPETING INTERESTS OF HAVING
SOME SIGNIFICANT HEALTH CARE
ISSUES AND YET HAVE SOME.
VERY IMPORTANT AGRICULTURAL
ISSUES WHICH ARE VERY IMPORTANT
YOUR DISTRICT AND FRANKLY OUR
CULTURE IS VERY IMPORTANT MY
DISTRICT AS WELL [inaudible]
SO -- IT'S ALWAYS ARE EXPRESSED
MY FRUSTRATION AND YOU'LL GET
DOOLING PROFESSIONALS THAT TO
YOU.
THEY EACH GET A VERY COMPELLING
ARGUMENTS ON EITHER SIDE.
BUT YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT
SOMETIMES THEY WILL POINT TO
STUDIES AT OR NOT -- REVIEWED --
AND WE DON'T GET ALL THOSE
DETAILS AS WE HEAR ONE SIDE
VERSUS ANOTHER -- SO -- I SHARE
YOUR CONCERN I HOPE YOU SURE
YOUR ANSWERS WITH THE BUT WE
SHOULD.
BE ABLE TO LEAN ON OUR OWN
DEPARTMENT THE SPECIALIZES IN
LOOKING AFTER THE BEST INTERESTS
OF OUR CONSTITUENTS TO MAKE SURE
THE PESTICIDES ARE SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE.
RIGHT -- SO I JUST WANT -- TO
SERVICE FIRST OF ALL I WANT
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE IN WORKING WITH ME AND
AND TAKING THE AMENDMENT -- AND
I THINK ONE OF THE CONCERNS I
HAD IS -- AND I THINK YOU HEAR
EXPRESSED HERE IS THAT -- YOU
KNOW WE'RE A AS A LEGISLATIVE
BODY OF COURSE IT'S OUR JOB TO
PASS LAWS AND WE NEED TO KEEP
PEOPLE SAFE AND I KNOW THAT'S
WHAT'S BEHIND.
YOUR BILL -- ON THE QUESTIONS OF
SCIENCE -- WE MIGHT HAVE A BIT
MORE.
THE VARIANCE IN TERMS OF OUR
ABILITY.
TO LOOK ACROSS THE SCIENTIFIC
LUGER SO FOR SOMEONE AND IN MANY
WAYS YOU THINK ABOUT IT WE DID --
YOU KNOW SIX METAPHOR SIX MEN
AGAINST WE DID A JOURNAL CLUB AT
AND AT UC DAVIS IT WOULD BE AN
HOUR YOU KNOW GOING OVER A PAPER
SO -- THE THE ABILITY TO
ACTUALLY DELVE INTO AND WE'RE
HERE TO HER IDEA IF DIFFERENT
TESTIMONY AND I I DO APPRECIATE
BOTH THE PROPONENTS AND
OPPONENTS SHARING WITH ME PAPERS --
THAT -- I'VE DONE IT AND ADD UP
TO YOU TO LOOK AT AND ANALYZE
AND AND AND AND I WOULD SAY IS
THAT -- IN IN LOOKING AT THOSE
AGAIN YOU KNOW I'M THERE OTHER
PEOPLE OR SMARMY WHO KNOWS THAT
THERE'S EVEN BETTER INCLUDING AS
SOMEONE SITTING IN HIS ROOM
MIGHT.
DISCLOSE I WORKED WITH --
AVERAGE PER CHILD -- AND SOME
OTHERS FIELDS AROUND
EPIDEMIOLOGY AND AND HOW THEIR
SPECTER -- WORK IS THAT -- WHAT
I SEE IN THE PAPERS THAT YOU
KNOW IS IT IS IT DEFINITIVELY
THE ABSOLUTELY THE RIGHT BECAUSE
THESE ARE METABOLIZED VERSUS --
WELL YEAH I THINK THERE'S SOME
WIGGLE ROOM THERE BUT I WOULD
ALSO SAY THAT EVEN THE PAPER'S
WHO SUPPOSEDLY SAID WELL.
WE DON'T WE DIDN'T SEE ANYTHING
WE DON'T THINK BUT THERE'S A
POSSIBILITY I MEAN THAT THERE
WERE SOME LITTLE HINTS OF STUFF
AND MORE TALKING ABOUT NOR DID
ON A CHILDREN'S.
RIGHT SO THE THE OUTCOME IS A
VERY SERIOUS.
ONE AND SO EVEN THOUGH THE
PAPERS THAT'S BECAUSE HE DIDN'T
SHOW ANYTHING AT ALL WHEN USED
TO USE COUNT REALLY DELVE INTO
THE NUMBERS THEY SAID WELL.
WHAT'S WITH THE TO HAVE SUCH A
IT'S THE DISCO CIGARETTES BUT
THERE'S SOME THERE WERE SOME
WEARING SIGNALS IN THAT RATE AND
THEN THE PAPERS THAT WERE SAYING
IS A PROBLEM YOU KNOW WE CAN SAY
THAT WELL IT'S ACTUALLY THE
SENATE IS.
BUT THE IT WAS PRETTY STRONG
STRONG SO IT'S I THINK GIVEN.
THE TYPICALLY THE OUTCOME WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IN THE FACT THAT.
EVERYONE SEEMS TO BE TAKING SOME
SORT OF SIGNAL THAT SOMETHING
MIGHT BE HAPPENING.
IT CERTAINLY MAKES ME PRETTY
WORRIED RIGHT AND AND SO YEAH
BUT WHY DO YOU WANT TO DO IS SAY
YOU KNOW.
I I I HAVE ANAND I APPRECIATE --
SANDRO'S WORKING AND US AND
SPONSORED BILL IS THAT ON ONE
LEVEL OF COURSE YOU KNOW I THINK
WE DO NEED THE REGULATORY
PROCESS TO GO AND WAY AND WHERE
WE HAVE MORE OF THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE SCIENCE BE ANALYZE AND
AND THEN THE SCIENTIST AWAY AND
AND AND THAT.
PROCESS AND THAT'S WHY I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
AMENDMENT AT THAT SAME TIME.
YEAH I A I HEAR WHAT PEOPLE ARE
SAYING THAT THE EVIDENCE THAT WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW AND FOR WHATEVER
REASON -- THERE MAY BE THAT THE
REGULATORY PROCESS AND WE CAN
ARGUE LIKE OKAY WELL DVRS
LOOKING AT IT RIGHT NOW ALRIGHT
AND THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE DONE
WHAT.
IT DIDN'T NEED A YEAR AND A HALF
TWO YEARS RIGHT THAT WHILE WERE
AND I'M NOT SAYING THAT THEY
HAVEN'T LOOKED AT IT BEFORE BUT
THERE'S NEW HEALTH THERE'S
ONGOING EVIDENCE RESEARCH
CONTINUES THERE'S A REASON WE
CONTINUE TO RESEARCH BECAUSE WE
STILL HAVE QUESTIONS THAT ARE
ANSWERED.
AND AND IT TAKES TIME AND MONEY
TO DO THAT THE ANSWERS ON JUST
COME IMMEDIATELY -- THAT -- THAT
GIVEN THE OUTCOME OF THE
SERIOUSNESS OF THIS AND ALSO
SOME CONCLUSIONS.
THAT'S WHAT IS A SIMPLE ANY
CONCLUSIONS REACHED BY SOME
PREVIOUS REGULATORY SOMETHING
REGULATORY AGENCIES THAT.
IT MAKES SENSE TO SAY WELL LET'S
HOLD BACK ON THIS AND LESS WE
CAN.
YOU KNOW UNLESS WE CAN PROVE
WEEK THAT THERE ARE SOME
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT AND WHICH IT
COULD BE YOU MIGHT BE IS SAFE
AND IT DOESN'T THEN.
DON'T USE IT PERIOD RIGHT AND
THAT'S OF THAT WHAT COMES OUT
THAT MAYBE THE CONCLUSIONS WHAT
WE DON'T KNOW NINE A PRE JUDGE
CONCLUSION.
AND SO I APPRECIATE THAT WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO IS WE'RE
PROPOSING TO SAY LET'S.
DO A HOTEL BACK ON USING IT.
AND LET THE REGULATOR DO THE
WORK BUT THEN SAY THAT.
WE'RE GONNA LET THE REGULATORS --
HAVETHE OPPORTUNITY TO SAVE ARE
THERE CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH WE
CAN DO IT.
IN A WAY THAT DOESN'T HARM OUR
MAIN OUTCOME WHICH IS NO
DEVELOPMENT OF CHILDREN AND SO
THAT WE'RE NOT THE LAST WORD IS
A LEGISLATURE -- BUT WE CREATE A
FRAMEWORK IN WHICH TO REGULATORS
CAN THEN LOOK AT THE DATA AND SO
FORTH.
AND BRING IT BACK TO THE RIGHT
SORT BRING INTELLECTUALLY THE
REGULATORY PROCESS BACK TOGETHER --
SO AND OF COURSE WE DON'T LIKE
THAT WE THINK THE REGULATORY
PROCESS IS A RIGOROUS OR
SOMETHING WE CERTAINLY CAN PASS
LAWS TO CHANGE THAT PROCESS AND
IT AS WELL BUT I DON'T THINK
THAT'S WHAT HE WANTS.
THINKING THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE SO WITH THAT --
CERTAINLY I I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY AND WHAT THOSE
AMENDMENTS AND I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR OF WORKING WITH --
COMMITTEE ON THIS.
SO IS THERE A MOTION ON THE BILL
THERE'S A MOVE MOTION ON THE
BILL -- SENATOR HOUSE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE OF THE ONLY SIDE
I'M ON TODAY IS TO PROTECT
CHILDREN FROM BRAIN DAMAGING.
CHLORPYRIFOS THAT'S THE SIDE
THAT I AM ON AND I APPRECIATE --
THE GUIDANCE AND THE SUPPORT AND
THE PARTICIPATION OF EVERYONE --
TO GET TO THE AMENDMENTS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SOME OF THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CEREMONY
SECRETARIES CALL THE ROLL.
PAN AND I STONE.
STONE NOW DRAWS SO I DROVE SO I
GROWTH [inaudible]
HER TANTO.
LEYVA LEYVA AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
MORNING I RUBIO.
THE BILL CURRENTLY IS FIVE ONE
HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT TO
HOLD IT OPEN -- FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND ALL MEMBERS.
OKAY -- NEXT UP -- CENTER
MITCHELL PREPARED ITEM NUMBER.
WE OKAY SO THAT'S ITEM NUMBER --
TEN SP FOUR SIXTY FOUR I
UNDERSTAND THERE IS -- THERE'S
BIPARTISAN -- LOVE FOR THIS BILL.
WITH THE CARE.
MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL FOUR SIX
FOUR WHICH WILL ADDRESS MATERNAL
MORTALITY DISPARITY IN THE STATE
AND LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE.
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIX CALIFORNIA
RECOGNIZE AT THE RATE OF WOMEN
WHO WERE DYING IN CHILDBIRTH DUE
TO PREGNANCY RELATED CAUSES WAS
DISTURBINGLY HIGH AMONG AND
AMONG THE HIGHEST IN THE NATION.
AS EXPECTED CALIFORNIA TOOK
SWIFT ACTION AND AGGRESSIVELY
TARGET THESE HIGHWAYS WHICH
FINALLY TALLY.
THE LEGISLATIVE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
AND STAKEHOLDERS HAVE INVESTED
FUNDS MAN AND WOMAN POWERING
COUNTLESS HOURS OF RESEARCH TO
UPGRADE UNSUCCESSFUL METHODS AND
CREATE INNOVATIVE TOOL KITS THAT
SAVE LIVES.
AND SO ALL THE U. S. REMAINS THE
MOST DANGEROUS OF ALL DEVELOPED
NATIONS FOR PREGNANT WOMEN TODAY
CALIFORNIA LEADS THE NATION'S AT
LEAST THE NATION AS A STATE WHAT
THE LAW WAS SMART.
MATERNAL MORTALITY RATES.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT DOES NOT
APPLY TO BLACK WOMEN.
DESPITE THE 55% DECLINE IN
MATERNAL MORTALITY RATES BLACK
MATERNAL MORTALITY IN CALIFORNIA
REMAINS THREE TO FOUR TIMES
HIGHER THAN THOSE OF OTHER
RACIAL AND ETHNIC GROUPS.
UNLIKE MANY OTHER DISPARITIES
THIS CANNOT BE EXPLAINED AWAY BY
SOCIAL ECONOMIC STATUS LEVEL OF
EDUCATION ACCESS TO CARE RISKY
HEALTH BEHAVIORS ARE OTHERS ALSO
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH.
IN FACT IN MY HOME COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES BLACK WOMEN WITH A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE OR HIGHER HAVE
A WORSE BIRTH OUTCOMES IN WHITE
WOMEN WHO HOLD LESS THAN A HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA.
INSTEAD THE EVIDENCE POINTS TO
IMPLICIT BIAS AS ONE OF THE
CAUSES FOR THESE WIDE
DISPARITIES.
A TWENTY SIXTEEN STUDY BY THE
UNIVERSITY OF VIRGINIA FOUND
THAT IN A SURVEY OF WHITE
MEDICAL STUDENTS AND RESIDENTS.
ABOUT HALF BELIEVED.
BIOLOGICAL MYTHS ABOUT RACIAL
DIFFERENCES IN PATIENTS
INCLUDING A BLACK PATIENTS HAVE
LESS SENSITIVE NERVE ENDINGS ARE
ABLE TO TOLERATE MORE PAIN AND
HAVE THICKER SKIN THAN THEIR
WHITE COUNTERPARTS.
THAT WAS IT IN EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN
COLLEAGUES THAT WAS IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN BLACK WOMEN ARE
IN GRAVE DANGER BECAUSE WHEN
THEY SAY THEY'RE IN PAINTING
KRAUT PRETENSION.
SOME PROVIDERS DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT.
AND LACK THE CULTURAL COMPETENCY
TO RESPOND APPROPRIATELY.
SB FOUR SIX FOUR TARGET THIS IS
BARELY BY REQUIRING EVERY
HEALTHCARE PROVIDER INVOLVED
WITH PERINEAL SERVICES IN
HOSPITALS AND ALTERNATIVE BIRTH
CENTERS TO UNDERGO EVIDENCE
BASED IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING.
SOME OF THESE BELIEVES AND
DIFFERENCES OF STANDARDS OF CARE
ARE SO SUBCONSCIOUS BUT THE
PROVIDERS MAY NOT EVEN BE AWARE
OF THEIR IMPLICIT BIAS.
THESE TRAININGS WILL CALL
ATTENTION TO INTERPERSONAL
IMPLICIT BIAS SEES IN ORDER TO
CATALYZE A CULTURE IN HOSPITAL.
WHERE PROVIDERS CAN DELIVER THE
BEST CARE TO ALL THEIR PATIENTS?
SB FOUR SIX FOUR WILL ALSO
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO TRACK AND PUBLISH
MATERNAL MORTALITY AND SEVERE.
MORBIDITY RATES TO BETTER
MONITOR THESE ISSUES AND
HIGHLIGHT THE AREAS AND
DEMOGRAPHICS THAT NEED FURTHER
INTERVENTION.
LET ME GO BACK AND SAY THAT
AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK ON THIS EFFORT.
THE ANALYSIS -- WE'VE BEEN
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH SOME
OF THE HOLES IN THE HEALTHCARE
INDUSTRY BOTH CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION.
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO ENGAGE
IN CONVERSATION THE ANALYSIS
REVIEWS THE BILL LAST PROPOSED
TO BE AMENDED THOSE MINUTES
HOPEFULLY WERE DISTRIBUTED
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OF THE RESULT THE FEEDBACK
PROVIDED BY THE HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION.
THE FIRST AMENDMENT CLARIFIES
THAT THE IMPLICIT BIAS TRINI
IMPLEMENTED BY THE HOSPITALS AND
BIRTH CENTERS MUST BE EVIDENCE
BASED IN ORDER TO ENSURE QUALITY
PROGRAM.
THE SECOND MEMBER REQUIRES THAT
THE DATA PUBLISHED ON MATERNAL
DEATH IS RISK ADJUSTED AND
DISAGGREGATED INTO REGIONS OF
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND IN ORDER TO PROTECT
SMALLER AREAS THAT MAY ONLY BE
ONE HOSPITALS WE CAN IDENTIFY.
THE EXACT SOURCE OF THE NEGATIVE
DATA SO IT'S AN EFFORT TO
PROTECT -- PRIVACY.
WITH ME TODAY AND WE HEARD YOU
LOUD AND CLEAR MISTER CHAIRMAN
THAT WE HEALTH SUPPORT IN BOTH
SIDES MOVED UP THE AISLE THANK
YOU WE WILL HEAR VERY BRIEFLY.
FROM -- TONYA COMMIT TEE WHILE
WHO HOLDS A PHD IN EPIDEMIOLOGY
AS A PRACTICING LICENSED MIDWIFE
HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
GEN ROBINSON FLIT EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR THE BLACK ONE FOR
WELLNESS -- AND OTHERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS CRITICAL TIMELY
MEASURE.
A THANK YOU US SIXTY MINUTES ALL
OF YOU WANT TAKE LESS FEEL FREE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL AND AND THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN AND AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- AND I AM AS SHE
SAID A LICENSED MIDWIFE I HAVE
BEEN WORKING IN COMMUNITY
CLINICS FOR TO TWENTY YEARS --
STARTING WITH THE BIRTHING
PROJECT CLINIC WHICH BROUGHT ME
TO SACRAMENTO.
AND BUT I'M ALSO A MOTHER OF
THREE DAUGHTERS.
AND AND THEY RIP STATE MY
DAUGHTER'S FACE THE RISK OF
DYING FOUR TIMES THAT OF THEIR
COWORKERS AND FRIENDS THEIR
ADVANCED DEGREES DON'T PROTECT
THEM.
THIS IS NOT A TRAGEDY THAT I
WANT TO FACE.
BUT HOW CAN WE ADDRESS THE ROOT
CAUSES OF THE TRAGEDY WE DON'T
EVEN KNOW WHEN IT HAPPENS.
SO IN THE U. S. B. THE ADDITION
OF THE PREGNANCY RELATED
INFORMATION TO THE DEATH
CERTIFICATE IN MANY STATES.
HAS IMPROVED THIS IDENTIFICATION.
SO LIKE STARTING IN -- TWO
THOUSAND THREE A MAJORITY OF
STATES REVISED THEIR DEATH
CERTIFICATES AND MOST INCLUDED.
A PREGNANCY QUESTION COMPATIBLE
WITH THE W. H. O. STANDARDS
EXCEPT FOR CALIFORNIA AT THAT
TIME.
AND WITH THAT NEW DATA NATIONAL
DATA COLLECTION THE REPORTED U.
S. MATURE MATERNAL MORTALITY
RATE MORE THAN DOUBLED.
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY
FOURTEEN BUT MOST OF THAT
REPORTED INCREASE WAS ACTUALLY
AN DUE TO IMPROVE ASCERTAINMENT.
OF MATERNAL MORTALITY AS A
CRITICAL FIRST STEP IN
PREVENTION EFFORTS.
AS IT CAN IDENTIFY AT RISK
POPULATIONS AND MEASURE THE
PROGRESS OF PREVENTION PROGRAMS.
NOW THESE FINDINGS IN THE US OF
INCREASING MATERNAL MORTALITY
OCCURRED -- WHEN THE WHO
REPORTED -- THAT A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SEVEN OF THE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THREE STE COUNTRIES HAD
DECREASING.
BETWEEN THIS TIME PERIOD EXCEPT
FOR THE US.
THE CALIFORNIA MATERNAL QUALITY
CARE COLLABORATIVE REPORTS A
DECLINE IN MATERNAL MORTALITY
HOWEVER THIS IS USING THE
LIMITED BIRTH CERTIFICATE DATA.
THEY DO REPORT THAT 4270% OF THE
DEATHS ARE PREVENTABLE WORK
LARGELY PREVENTABLE AND LARGELY
DUE TO PROVIDE A FACTORS -- SO
THIS IS WHY IMPLICIT BIAS
TRAINING IS NECESSARY MY
RESEARCH ALSO INCLUDES A CROSS
SECTIONAL SURVEY DISTRIBUTED TO
A DIVERSE GROUP OF CHILDBEARING
WOMEN TO CAPTURE THEIR LIVED
EXPERIENCE AS A MATERNITY CARE.
INCLUDING DISRESPECT
DISCRIMINATION.
AND PATIENT DESIGNED ITEMS
MEASURED ALL SEVEN DIMENSIONS OF
THE WHO TYPE W. H. O. TYPOLOGY
FOR MISTREATMENT PRUNING VERBAL
AND PHYSICAL ABUSE
DISCRIMINATION.
FAILURE TO MEET PROFESSIONAL
STANDARDS OF CARE.
POR REPORT BETWEEN WOMEN AND
PROVIDERS.
AND POOR CONDITIONS PREVENTED BY
THE HEALTH SYSTEM.
OUR ANALYSIS FOUND DIFFERENCE IN
MISTREATMENT BY RACE.
SO STUDENT DEMOGRAPHICS AND
CONTEXT OF CARE IN OUR SURVEY
ONE IN SIX WOMEN SEVENTEEN POINT
3% IN THE U. S..
REPORTED EXPERIENCING ONE OR
MORE TYPES OF MISTREATMENT SUCH
AS BEING SHOUTED AT OR SCOLDED
BY HEALTH CARE PROVIDER.
BEING IGNORED REFUSE RECEIVING
NO RESPONSE TO REQUEST OF HELP.
AND OF COURSE RATES OF
MISTREATMENT WERE HIGHER AMONG
BLACK WOMEN.
FOLLOWED BY INDIGENOUS LATINO
AND ASIAN REYES.
YOUNGER WOMEN HAVING THEIR FIRST
BABY LOW SOCIO ECONOMIC STATUS
AND ELEVATED PREGNANCY AND
SOCIAL RISK WERE ALSO RISK
FACTORS FOR MISTREATMENT --
ADDITIONALLY REGARDLESS OF THEIR
OWN RACE.
HAVING A PARTNER WHO WAS BLACK
INCREASED A WOMAN'S RISK OF
MISTREATMENT [inaudible]
SO.
WHAT DIDN'T INCREASE YOUR RISK
WAS BEING WHITE?
NOT HAVING YOUR FIRST CHILD AND
BEING OLDER THAN.
THIRTY OUR FINDINGS SUGGEST THAT
MISTREATMENT IS WIDESPREAD
DURING CHILDBIRTH IN THE US AND
MORE EXPERIENCED BY PEOPLE OF
COLOR PARTICULARLY BLACK WOMEN.
AND ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO FACE
SOCIAL ECONOMIC OR HEALTH
CHALLENGES.
PROVIDERS MUST BE CHALLENGED TO
CONFRONT THEIR BIAS AND NO WOMEN
IN THIS COUNTRY NO ONE IN THE
STATE SHOULD BE SUBJECTED TO
MISTREATMENT AT THIS PRECIOUS
AND VULNERABLE TIME.
SO PLEASE WELL YES WITH SENATOR
MITCHELL OKAY THE REMAINING
WITNESSES OF LESS THAN TWO
MINUTES -- OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS JAN ROBINSON FLINT
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
BLACK WOMEN ALONE IS WE ARE A
TWENTY ONE YEAR OLD ORGANIZATION.
WORKING MOSTLY A SOUTH LOS
ANGELES AND I'M.
OUR PROGRAM STARTED WITH THE
BIRTHING PROJECT WHICH WAS A
MODEL PHONE TEAR OUT TO MENTOR
PREGNANT WOMEN.
SO TODAY I WANT TO REMIND YOU OF
THE HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY IN
THE HEALTH STATUS OF BLACK WOMEN
IN.
CHARGE TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE GREAT
STRIDES IN REDUCING MATERNAL
MORTALITY HOWEVER BLACK WOMEN
HAVE BEEN LEFT BEHIND.
BLACK WOMEN ARE TWO HUNDRED AND
43% MORE LIKELY TO DIE FROM
CHILDBIRTH AND COMPRISED 21% A
PREGNANCY RELATED DEATHS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. FOUR HUNDRED YEARS
AGO THE GOOD SHIP JESUS BROUGHT
IN SLATE AFRICANS TO THE SHORES
OF JAMESTOWN VIRGINIA AND SINCE
THEN BLACK WOMEN HAVE
SYSTEMATICALLY BEEN DEHUMANIZED.
MARION J. SIMS WHO SOME OF YOU
IS THE FATHEROF GYNECOLOGY
EXPLOITED AND ABUSED HIS SLAVE
BLACK WOMEN.
THE BILL THIS FIELD OF STUDY.
AND THE REMAINS OF THIS
TREATMENT ARE STILL PRESENT
TODAY.
THE NATIONAL MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
PART A BITTER BATTLE TO KEEP
HOSPITAL'S SEGREGATED ANTI TUMOR
MEDICAID BECAUSE OF RACISM AND
BIAS IN JOHN HOPKINS UNIVERSITY
CALLED THE CELLS OF HIM WE HAD A
LACKS -- WHO DIED OF NATURAL WHO
DIED FROM CHILDBIRTH?
SO MY MY JOB HERE TODAY'S ALSO
TO BRING YOU THE STORY OF WOMEN
WHO I SEE AN LOS ANGELES ONE IS
MISS ENTLEY.
SHE WAS VERBALLY ABUSED AFL
FEARFUL TO GIVE BIRTH ARE IN.
99% OF BLACK WOMEN GIVE BIRTH IN
HOSPITALS BUT SHE WANTED TO DO
IT IN THE BIRTHING CENTER.
WHICH SHE WENT TO THE BURKE THE
CENTER AN AXE FOR STRESS TESTS.
ARE THEY AVE A TOUR THEN THEY
TOLD HER SHE WAS TOO FAT.
AND TOLD HER THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE TO DO IS SEE SECTION AND
THEY WOULD NEED TO DO IT RIGHT
NOW BUT LUCKILY FOR HER SHE HAD
A MID WIVES.
WHO CAN INTERVENE AND HELP HER
WORKER BIRTH PLAN I ALSO HAVE
THE STORY MY LEXS WHO WENT TO
THE EMERGENCY ROOM?
AND ACTS FOR ULTRASOUND MY LEXUS
ENDED UP GOING TO THREE
EMERGENCY RULES BECAUSE THEY ALL
CONTACTED HER DOCTOR HE TOLD HER
SHE WAS GROWN.
AND HAVE TO FACE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF BEING PREGNANT
THIS WAS A NINETEEN YEAR OLD --
YOUNG WOMEN.
IN MY FAMILY STORY IS THAT OF
CARE A JOHNSON IN MANY OF US
KNOW HER STORY.
SHE WAS LEFT FOR SEVEN HOURS
WITHOUT CARE AND WHEN SHE WAS
FINALLY ATTENDED TO THEY FOUND
THREE LITERS OF BLOOD IN HER
ABDOMEN AND SHE DIED LEAVING HER
TWO YOUNG CHILDREN AND HOLES
BEING BEHIND.
IMPLICIT BIAS AND DISCRIMINATION
IN THE BIRTHING PROCESS
MANIFESTED A NUMBER OF WAYS
BLACK WOMEN ARE PERCEIVED TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE MORE PAIN WE ARE
IGNORED WE ARE TREATED WITH
DISDAIN.
WE ARE THOUGHT ANGRY ARE SIZES
USE AGAINST US WERE TOO THIN OR
TOO FAT OR TOO ANGRY.
AND OUR PARTNERS ARE IGNORED
WHEN THEY COME INTO THE ROOM OR
SOMETIMES GIVEN THE FINAL
AUTHORITY OVER US.
THIS SYSTEM HAS BEEN SET UP FOR
SO FOR FROM FOUR HUNDRED YEARS
AGO AND IS REINFORCED EVERY DAY
WITH A BIAS MEAL STEREO TYPES
AND DANGEROUS IGNORANCE.
BLACK WOMEN'S WELLNESS SEES THE
CONSEQUENCES EACH TIME WE LOOK
AT THE DATA ARE THE HIGH
MATERNAL DEATH RATES ARE INFANT
DEATH RATES.
AND THERE IS NO CORRELATION TO
ECONOMIC STATUS EDUCATIONAL
ACHIEVEMENTS OR GEOGRAPHIC
LOCATION.
THAT'S A WRAP UP AND MESSING
ACTUALLY THE VOTE FOR THIS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU -- SO WE'VE
MORE THAN THE VERY MUCH EXCEEDED
TIME TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL DOORS A STORY --
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY PROUD CO SPONSORED HERE
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AND THANK
YOU.
CHRISTY WITH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL TODAY -- THIS IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION THAT SENATOR MITCHELL
HAS BROUGHT FORWARD AND WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO WORK WITH US ON THE
AMENDMENTS -- THAT SHE MENTIONED
THAT ARE OUTLINED IN ALSO SO
THANK YOU THANK YOU OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NAME
WORKSTATION POSITION.
THIS MAN PALIN HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINDA TENER WHAT'S ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA BLACKOUTS NETWORK IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THEIR HUTCHINSON WITHOUT FOR
WOMEN AND GIRLS APART CO SPONSOR
ON THIS BILL AND IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JIM LIMBURG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE SET VAN FLEET BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND SUPPORT.
YOU.
CHEN AND HAVE AS NARAL PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA WE ARE CO
SPONSORING THE BILL AND VERY
PROUD TO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
RESIDENTS SALAS ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT IF YOU.
ALISON USE FOR THE CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE ON A CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MICHELLE GIVENS OF THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING LOCAL
DEPARTMENTS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
I SEE NO ONE ELSE AT THE
MICROPHONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SAYING NONE QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THERE MOTIONS.
UP THAT MAKE UP.
IT'S OKAY MOVE THAT'S RIGHT
CENTER SOUNDED MOVE IT OKAY ANY
OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
I WOULD START THANK YOU SIR YES
AS A RUBIO.
START ARGUMENTS IN A BUSY DAY A
LOT OF COMMITTEES I JUST WANT TO
THANK US SENATOR.
METRO FOR BRINGING THIS UP I
NOTICES ON VERY CLEAR EVIDENCE
THAT THIS IS HAPPENING SO I'M
GLAD THAT YOU'RE BRINGING THIS
UP AND I AM SO HAPPY THAT WE'RE
ADDRESSING A SO THANK YOU ALL OF
YOU FOR FOR COMING AND GIVING
YOUR TESTIMONY.
I WANTED TO CONVEY THAT THANK
YOU THANK YOU MA'AM PROJECTION.
THANK MALES BUT YES UNDER ASA.
WHEN I FIRST CAME TO LOS ANGELES
I WAS -- I MET A WOMAN UNTIL YOU
HERNANDEZ.
WHO FILED THE LAWSUIT AT?
USC COUNTY HOSPITAL. FOR THE FOR
STERILIZATION OF LATINA WOMEN --
I WAS QUITE SHOCKED BECAUSE I
THOUGHT.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
HOW HOW COULD WE BE DOING THAT --
TO WOMEN OF COLOR SO I I TO
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR THIS WORK
[inaudible]
THAT -- OKAY SO IT'S THANK YOU
US SENATE MITCHELL FOR BRING
THIS FOR OUR THANK THE WITNESSES
I APOLOGIZE YOU KNOW TRY TO BE
CONSISTENT ACROSS EVERYONE SO.
IT WAS A TIME LIMIT OF THE
PRAIRIE OFFICE SO -- SO -- BUT
WHAT YOU HAD.
WHAT YOU DID SAVE IT IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT I JUST DON'T
WANT? TO RECOGNIZE THAT TENDS
AND CERTAINLY -- I KNOW THAT --
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY IN THE YOU
KNOW AND MEDICAL COMMUNITY
DISAGREE RECOGNITION WE NEED TO
ADDRESS IMPLICIT BIAS -- IS A
PEDIATRICIAN I'D LOOK AT INFANT
MORTALITY AND THE PERSISTENT
PERSISTENT.
DISPARITIES THAT IF THE
MORTALITY CERTAINLY KNOWS --
BEEN SEEN TO DATE ALSO AND AND
MATERNAL MORTALITY APPRECIATE
CENTER MITCHELL YOUR LEADERSHIP
IN THIS -- SO WITH THAT WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER STONE SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
PAN HI AND I STONE.
STONE I'D DORADO.
DRUGS -- I'D GROWTH HER TADO A
TOTAL AYE LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MITCHELL AYE MITCHELL
AYE MONNING.
MONNING AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE.
OKAY -- SO THAT THAT IS EIGHT
ZERO AND I THINK THAT THE BILLS
OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COMMITTEE
APPRECIATE [inaudible]
THREE OKAY.
OKAY THANKS. TO THE AUDIENCE FOR
HANGING IN.
WITH US WE HAVE A COUPLE MORE
BILLS BY OUR CHAIRMAN.
I ASSUME CENTER AND YOU WANNA GO
AND FILE ORDER.
YES SB SIXTY FIVE WILL BEGIN
WITH A C. -- SIXTY FIVE TRY
CHAIR A MEMBERS -- WE KNOW THAT
HEALTH INSURANCE IS EXPENSIVE
AND MY A. WITNESSES WILL GO INTO
MORE DETAIL ABOUT THE STRUGGLES
CALIFORNIANS FACE.
AFFORDING TO PREMIUMS AND COST
SHARING -- EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT
PEOPLE WHO HAVE HEALTH INSURANCE
HAVE IMPROVED FINANCIAL SECURITY
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE ACCESS TO
CARE GREATER USE OF PREVENTIVE
SERVICES.
PRIMARY CARE CHRONIC ILLNESS
TREATMENT MEDICATIONS AND
SURGERY.
MORE CAN AND SHOULD BE DONE TO
TRY TO REDUCE THE COST OF HEALTH
COVERAGE FOR CALIFORNIANS AND
ONE THING THAT CAN BE DONE TO
HELP KEEP COSTS DOWN.
ENCOURAGE ROMAN AND HELP
CALIFORNIANS IS INCREASE THE
SUBSIDIES THAT WE PROVIDE TO
HELP PEOPLE FOR THE PREMIUMS ON
PLANS AND I COVERED CALIFORNIA.
SO SB SIXTY FIVE WILL CREATE A
STATE SUBSIDY PROGRAM TO HELP
PEOPLE BUY HEALTH INSURANCE
THROUGH COVERED CALIFORNIA.
SB SIXTY FIVE PROVIDE STATE
FUNDED SUBSIDIES FOR PEOPLE WITH
INCOME UP 26100% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL SO UNDER THE
FEDERAL -- ACE UNDER THE ACA.
YOU HAVE TAX CREDITS UP 24100%
AND PEOPLE HIT THE CLIFF SO
WE'RE GOING.
TO EXPAND UP 26100% AND I WOULD
MAKE NOTE THAT -- SB SIXTY FIVE
ALSO GIVES COVER CALIFORNIA
AUTHORITY TO ADOPT THE PROGRAM
DESIGNED BUT REQUIRES COVERED
CALIFORNIA TO PAY THE SUBSIDY TO
THE PLANTS IN THE PLANS WILL
COLLECT THE REST OF THE PREMIUM
FROM THE CONSUMER.
BASED ON THE AB EIGHTEEN TEN
REPORT SB -- SIXTY FIVE WITHOUT
A INDIVIDUAL MANDATE WOULD BRING
IN A HUNDRED TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
NEW ENROLLMENTS INTO COVERAGE.
IT WOULD REDUCE PREMIUMS BY
TWENTY ONE DOLLARS PER MONTH FOR
AN AVERAGE OF ONE POINT THREE
MILLION EXISTING COVERED
CALIFORNIA ENROLLEES.
AND REDUCE PREMIUMS I FORTY
DOLLARS PER MONTH FOR AN AVERAGE
OF SIX HUNDRED SIXTY TWO
THOUSAND OFF EXCHANGE -- BECAUSE
IMPROVEMENT IN THE RISK MIX SO
THIS IS GOING TO HAVE AFFECTS
NOT ONLY ON PEOPLE WITHIN
COVERED CALIFORNIA BUT EVEN OUT
OF THE EXCHANGE.
NOW IF WE PAIRED THIS WITH THE
REQUIREMENT FOR MINIMUM
ESSENTIAL COVERAGE IN A PENALTY
WHICH WILL BE HEARING NEXT AND
AN SP ONE SEVENTY FIVE IF YOU
CHOOSE TO PASS THAT AS WELL THE
NEW ROMAN ACTUALLY INCREASED BY
FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND SO ALMOST HALF A
MILLION.
PREMIUMS REDUCED BY THIRTY ONE
DOLLARS PER MONTH FOR AN AVERAGE
OF SIX HUNDRED SIXTY TWO
THOUSAND OFF EXCHANGE.
AND THERE WILL BE FIVE HUNDRED
AND NINETY MILLION MORE FEDERAL
SUBSIDIES FOR CALIFORNIA THAT
WILL BE AVAILABLE THROUGH THE
DRAW DOWN MORE FEDERAL FUNDS IN
AS A DONOR STATE I HOPE YOU LIKE
THAT IDEA BRING BACK MORE MONEY
BACK TO CALIFORNIA THAT WE'VE
BEEN PAYING.
OUT -- OTHER DIFFERENCES.
JUST IN THOSE FIGHT AT THAT
NOTICE THAT THE GOVERNOR DOESN'T
HAVE A PROPOSAL WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENCES WITH SB.
SIXTY FIVE WE THERE.
NO ANNUAL PROGRAM DESIGN CHANGES
NO RECONCILIATION PROCESS -- BUT
WITHOUT THOSE REPORT
MODIFICATIONS AS OF TODAY NOW IS
THE TIME TO DO THIS WE NEED TO
STABILIZE THE CALIFORNIA
INSURANCE MARKET -- WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TRYING TO
UNDER MY INSURANCE MARKET MAKE
NOTE THEIR INSURANCE PREMIUMS AT
LEAST 5% OF THE INCREASE IN
PREMIUMS THIS PAST YEAR HAS BEEN
RESULT OF THOSE THAT THE
STABILIZATION.
AND SO I WITNESSES HERE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR WITNESSES
JUST LETTING YOU KNOW WE DO HAVE --
UNANIMOUS CONSENT I THINK ON THE
ON THE DAY IS HERE.
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS PLEASE.
BEST HEALTH FOR HEALTH TEXAS
CALIFORNIA LET ME GIVE YOU FOR A
FEW REASONS WHY IT SHOULDBE
UNANIMOUS -- SO.
ALL WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICAL
OR MORE LIKELY TO ENROLL IN
MEDICARE ALL THAT PEOPLE ARE IN
THE INDIVIDUAL MARKET TO BUY
INSURANCE.
OVER 90% OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE -- OR AND
ROLLED WHICH IS A GOOD THING A
THIRD TO A HALF OF THOSE WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE TO BUY INDIVIDUAL
COVERAGE HAVE NOT BOUGHT IT AND
THAT'S BECAUSE OF AFFORDABILITY.
WE ASK CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
BELOW 4100% OF POVERTY SPENT
ALMOST 10% OF THEIR INCOME ON
PREMIUMS.
AND MORE ON COPAYS AND
DEDUCTIBLES FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
OVER 4100% OF POVERTY.
IF YOU'RE A COUPLE IN YOUR
FIFTIES OR EARLY SIXTIES DURING
MEDICARE YOU CAN SPEND AS MUCH
AS 40% OF YOUR INCOME ON THE
STANDARD BENEFIT DESIGN.
WHICH HAS A TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR DEDUCTIBLE FOR
YOUR HOSPITAL.
I DON'T KNOW HOW ANYBODY AFFORD
SAID AND IF YOU TRADE DOWN TO
BUY A CHEAPER PRODUCT AND I
WE'VE BEEN IN THIS ROOM OFTEN
SAYING THIS.
THAT HAS A SIX THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED DOLLAR DEDUCTIBLE FOR
EACH. ONE IN THE COUPLE YOU'RE
GONNA SPEND FIFTEEN OR TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND THEN YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO SPEND ANOTHER.
TWELVE THIRTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
ON YOUR DEDUCTIBLE SO THAT'S NOT
AFFORDABLE PEOPLE ARE NOT BUYING
IT PEOPLE WHO BUY C HAVE
BOUGHT COVERAGE AND CAL COVERED
CALIFORNIA.
A THIRD OF THEM SAY THEY HAVE
DIFFICULTY AFFORDING FOOD AND
RENT A THIRD OF THEM SAY THEY
HAVE DIFFICULTY AFFORDING
PREMIUMS AND A THIRD OF THEM
HAVE DIFFICULTY AFFORDING THEIR
CO PAYS.
PEOPLE NEED THIS HELP WERE
ENGAGE IN A LIVELY DISCUSSION IN
THE BUDGET CONTEXT ABOUT HOW
MUCH HELP HOW SOON WE CAN GET
FOLKS.
THIS BILL IS PART OF THAT
PROCESS TO MOVE IT FORWARD AND
WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO BE IN
SUPPORT OF IT AND THAT
RECOGNIZES PEOPLE.
PULL ALL PEOPLE BELOW 6100%
POVERTY IS NEEDING HELP THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR TESTIMONY.
GOOD EVENING JAN FOURTH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY --
ALIGN MYSELF WITH EVERYTHING
COMPELLED TO SEVEN HEALTH ACCESS
AND THIS DOES BUILD ON A PROCESS
THAT.
HAPPENED BETWEEN THESELAST TWO
LEGISLATIVE SESSIONS WITH AB
EIGHTEEN TEN AFFORDABILITY
WORKGROUP AND I AM BY NO MEANS
AN ECONOMICS GEEK BUT ITWAS
REALLY HEARTENING TO SEE WHERE
YOU CAN TAKE AN AMOUNT OF MONEY
AND WHAT THAT DOES TO THE UPTAKE
OF INSURANCE RATES ACROSS
POPULATIONS.
AND WHAT THAT WILL DO TO RE DIRT
REDUCING OUR OWN INSURANCE RATES --
SO THIS IS BASED ON THE WORK
THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN DONE IT'S
BUILDING OFF THAT IT WILL MAKE
COVERAGE AFFORDABLE FOR MORE
PEOPLE BOTH AT THE VERY LOW END
AND ALL THE WAY UP 26100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
SO WE JUST ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU FOR JUST A MINUTE
FURTHER IN SUPPORT PLEASE
SUPPORT MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THERESA STARK WITH
KAISER PERMANENTE A PLEASED TO
BE HERE IN SUPPORT TODAY WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE ASSEMBLY VERSION.
OF THE BILL AS WELL AS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH ALL PARTIES TO
BRING IT ALL TOGETHER FOR TWENTY
TWENTY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALISON USE FOR THE CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND ON BEHALF OF
OURSELVES AND ALL THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE CHILDREN'S --
COVERAGE COALITION IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING AT CALIFORNIA COVERAGE
AND HEALTH INITIATIVES UNITED
WAYS -- TCP IN AND AT CHILDREN
NOW.
WE RESET ISSUE OF THE FAMILY
GLITCH IN PREVIOUS HEARINGS AND
WE'VE BEEN DEEPLY APPRECIATIVE
OF SENATOR PANS INTEREST IN THE
ISSUE -- THIS VERSION DOES NOT
ACTUALLY INCLUDE -- THE CHILDREN
WHO ARE FALL INTO THE FAMILY
WHICH THESE FOLKS ARE ALREADY
EXCLUDED FROM FEDERAL SUBSIDIES.
AND WE JUST AT YOUR GUIDANCE
SENATOR PAN WE'VE SPOKEN A
DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
AND DINNER APPEARING TOGETHER
INFORMATION ON THE COST OF THE
TAKE OPERATE -- SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH YOU ON IN EQUITY --
SOLUTION FOR THESE FOLKS THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR COULD JUST
BECAUSE SAGE THE DREAM
ORGANIZATION WITH THE SUPPORTER
DARBARI GLAZER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
VICTOR CHRISTY WITH CALIFORNIA
HELPLESS ADVOCATES ADVOCATING ON
BEHALF OF COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
VIDEO BORN AMERICAN GET AND
PEDIATRICS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LOUISE WAS CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BECAUSE SUPPORTER BLUE SHIELD OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JOHN WITH MAKE YOU CAPTAIN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
AND THE WORK.
MORE COVER WITH SMALL BUSINESS
MAJORITY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
KELLY BE MY BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINDA DINNER WITH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN I THINK HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SECOND QUARTER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
RESIDENTS ALSO BE HALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE COME FORWARD
SEEN AND ARE THERE ANY OPPONENTS
SB.
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
SEEING NONE OF RETURN TO THE
DAIS.
SENATORS WITCHER WILL.
SENATE AND I JUST WANT TO
APPLAUD YOU AND IN AND TAKING
LEADERSHIP FOR THIS OF THIS BILL
SO THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO
SUPPORT I'M OF THE BILL THE
MOTION CENTER OUT OF THANK YOU.
CENTER TOWERS MADE A MOTION IS
ANY OTHER FURTHER COMMENTS.
IF NOT WE'LL GO TO THE ROLE THIS
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
A CLOSING STATEMENT.
RESPECT THAT'S WHEN I BUT THANK
YOU CENTER.
CAN I AN ICE STONE BY STONE AYE
DRAWS -- DRUGS OR AYE GROVE HER
TADO HI FOR TITLE I LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MITCHELL MITCHELL AYE
MONNING MONNING AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO HI. EIGHT ZERO AS OPPOSED
TO GET UP.
SENDER -- SB.
ONE SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU AND I
AM STRUCTURE AND NUMBERS -- AS
WE JUST THAT I JUST DISCUSSED
WITH SB SIXTY FIVE THAT'S THE
ONE SEVENTY FIVE IS A SERVER IN
MANY WAYS A COMPANION BILL
THAT'S NECESSARY TO KEEP
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH INSURANCE
MARKETS STABLE AND OUR PREMIUMS
DOWN -- SAID MENTIONED EARLIER
THE BENEFITS OF INSURANCE -- AND
WE TALKED ABOUT THE WHAT THE
MANDATE WILL DO IN TERMS OF ARE
ACTUALLY DO RESTORATION OF THE
PENALTY AND THE MANDATE WILL DO
TO ACTUALLY INCREASE ENROLLMENT
AND ALSO -- REDUCE PREMIUMS AS
WELL SO -- WITH THAT I HAVE
THOUGHT THREE WITNESSES WHO
SPEAK FOR THE NEED FOR BILL I'VE
ANY CLARK THE NATIONAL MULTIPLE
SCLEROSIS SOCIETY BETH CAPELL
FROM HALIFAX CALIFORNIA AND
BRICK RAILROAD.
A SEA OF THE INSECT MANY
AMERICAN HEALTH CENTER THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND WELCOME.
GOOD EVENING.
THE MANY CLARK.
APPROVING SB.
ONE SEVENTY FIVE IS IMPORTANT TO
THOSE WHO LIVE WITH EN MASSE
OTHER CHRONIC DISEASES BECAUSE
IT WILL MAKE COVERED CALIFORNIA
HEALTH PLANS FAR MORE AFFORDABLE.
I'VE BEEN LIVING WITH RELAPSING
REMITTING MS SINCE TWO THOUSAND
TWO I TAKE A DISEASE MODIFYING
THERAPY EVERY SIX WEEKS THAT
COSTS ABOUT EIGHTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR.
AND IT SUCCESSFULLY CONTROLS MY
AMASS NO DISEASE PROGRESSION NO
NO I MASS ATTACKS I USE MY
HEALTH INSURANCE COVERAGE
REGULARLY.
I HAD COVER CALIFORNIAN TWENTY
FOURTEEN WAS ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLARS A MONTH PRICES
ROSE IN TWENTY FIFTEEN TO ABOUT
SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH.
AND BY TWENTY SIXTEEN THE COST
WOULD HAVE BEEN SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY DOLLARS PER MONTH AND
WAS NO LONGER AFFORDABLE.
AND THAT WAS BEFORE THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE WAS REPEALED.
WITH APPEALS OF INTO.
OF INDIVIDUAL MANDATE PREMIUM
PRICES ROSE AGAIN WHICH CAUGHT
THE 24% REDUCTION AND ROLL MEANT.
PREMIUMS JUST TOO EXPENSIVE
PREMIUMS ARE JUST TOO EXPENSIVE
AND CALIFORNIANS LIKE ME WERE
PRICED OUT OF THE MARKET.
REINSTATING THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE WOULD STABILIZE THE
COVERED CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
EXCHANGE MARKET AND DECREASE
PREMIUM PRICES MAKING THE MORE
AFFORDABLE.
PEOPLE LIVING WITH A MASS NEED
THEIR HEALTHCARE PREMIUMS TO BE
AFFORDABLE.
THE AVERAGE PRICE OF A DISEASE
MODIFYING THERAPY FOR MS WITHOUT
INSURANCE IS ABOUT NINETY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
LIVING WITH A CHRONIC DISEASE IS
VERY EXPENSIVE.
ON TOP OF PAYING FOR PREMIUMS
PATIENTS MUST ALSO PAY FOR
DEDUCTIBLES.
COPAYS FOR DOCTORS OFFICE VISITS
AND DRUG COPAYS AND CO INSURANCE
SO IN OTHER WORDS THEY MUST PAY
TO USE THEIR INSURANCE.
THE NATIONAL MS SOCIETY ASKS FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON SB ONE SEVENTY
FIVE BECAUSE EVERYONE NEEDS HELP
INSURANCE NO ONE IS EXEMPT FROM
UNEXPECTED ILLNESS OR INJURY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. FOR HAVING US
HERE TODAY MY NAME IS PREDICT
AROSE I'M THE CEO OF THE
SACRAMENTO NATIVE AMERICAN
HEALTH CENTER -- WE ARE HEALTH
CENTER IN SACRAMENTO MID TOWN --
SERVICE LOW INCOME UNINSURED.
AND UNDERINSURED MEMBERS OF THE
SACRAMENTO COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HEAR FROM HEALTH CENTER
REPRESENTATIVES ON SB ONE
SEVENTY FIVE REQUIRING MINIMUM
ESSENTIAL HEALTH COVERAGE
AUTHORED BY SENATOR RICHARD PAN.
ALL CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY NOW 1-400-
ORGANIZATION ORGANIZATIONS
SERVING TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
PEOPLE HAVE FOUGHT LONG AND HARD
AND ADVOCATED FOR COVERAGE AND
ACCESS FOR ALL.
WE WERE TOP SUPPORTERS OF THE
ACA AND KNOW FROM EXPERIENCE.
THAT THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE WAS
A LYNCH PIN IN THIS HISTORIC
LEGISLATION.
LOSING THE TAX PENALTY WITH THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE IN A CA HAS
MEANT THAT THE UNINSURED RATE
HAS INCREASED.
I'VE HEARD FROM MANY OF MY
HEALTH CENTER COLLEAGUES THAT
THERE AND ENSURE CREEK WAS
AROUND 5% AFTER THE ACA.
AND HAS NOW SIGNIFICANTLY
CLIMBED UP ABOVE 15%.
WE BELIEVE THIS IS TO THAT DUE
TO THE ZEROING OUT OF THE TAX
PENALTY.
AT OUR HEALTH CENTER ALONE WE'VE
SEEN A 6% INCREASE IN THE LAST
SIX MONTHS.
BOB THAT EQUALS ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED THIRTEEN PATIENTS A
MONTH -- WE KNOW THAT TO ENSURE
THE YOUNG AND HEALTHY WE KNOW
THAT TO ENSURE THEM [inaudible]
THE COSTS.
BUT THE YOUNG AND HEALTHY IN OUR
SOCIETY MUST PARTICIPATE IN A
BROADER POOL OF HEALTH INSURANCE
AND THE MANDATE AS A CENTRAL.
WHEN EVERYONE HAS COVERAGE WE
CAN INSURE COSTUME PREMIUMS ARE
MODERATED?
AS A PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER ONCE
EVERYONE IS FULLY COVERED WE CAN
COMMENCE THE PREVENTATIVE HEALTH
CARE THAT WE KNOW KEEPS
COMMUNITIES HEALTHY.
AND WILL REALLY LOWER THE COSTS
OF HEALTH CARE ACROSS THE STATE.
FOR THESE REASONS COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT SB ONE SEVENTY FIVE AND
WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO VOTE I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
BETH COMPEL HEALTHAXIS
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
CALIFORNIA'S EFFECTIVE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT CUT IN HALF THE NUMBER
OF UNINSURED IN CALIFORNIA.
WE CAN DO IT AGAIN IF WE BUT IF
WE DON'T TAKE STEPS LIKE SB ONE
SEVENTY FIVE WE'RE GOING TO GO
IN THE WRONG DIRECTION PROJECT
PROJECTION SHOW BUT THE BY
TWENTY TWENTY THREE ALMOST A
MILLION CALVET MORE CALIFORNIANS.
WILL BE UNINSURED BECAUSE OF THE
DAMAGE DONE TO THE ACA AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL SO THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE IT COMES TO
YOU.
TIED TO INCREASED AFFORDABILITY
HELP AND INCREASED AFFORDABILITY
HELP THAT GOES BEYOND SIMPLY THE
PENALTY REVENUE THAT'S RAISED BY
THE MANDATE.
AND SO THIS IS NO THESE TWO
BILLS TOGETHER ARE AN IMPORTANT
PART OF GETTING TO UNIVERSAL
COVERAGE ALONG WITH SB TWENTY
NINE SENATOR DRAWS SAYS BILL.
ON HEALTH FOR ALL AND OTHER
MEASURES TO EXPAND MEDIC CAL TO
SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
AS A PACKAGE AT TAKEN TOGETHER
WE CAN GET TO UNIVERSAL COVERAGE
IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU THANKS
REQUEST AMONG THOSE IN FAVOR
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
LASER BARBER GLAZER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CONNIE DELGADO BE HAVE A COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
MICHELLE GIVEN TO THE COUNTY
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THERESA START KAISER PERMANENT
TAKEN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NICK LOUISA'S CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
BECAUSE SUPPORT OF BLUE SHIELD
OF CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
NEARLY THE JOHN WITH MAKE YOU
CAPTION ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANY THANK YOU.
STEVEN SCHULTZ WITH ARTHRITIS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TO CHRISTY CALIFORNIA OPUS
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BRENT SPENCER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PUT AFTER TO MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
AT THE MOST PRIVILEGED HEALTH
PLAN TO CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU YOU BORN AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS AND
SUPPORT.
MORE SECONDS ALSO ME HALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
CHECK A CORAL CALIFORNIA GENESIS
ASIAN I SUPPORT THANK YOU LAST
CALL FOR SUPPORTERS OF SB.
ONE SEVENTY FIVE SING ANOTHER
KNEE PONENS SB ONE SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SING ON A RETURN TO THE DAIS.
CENTERS.
IS OUR MOTION [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
SENATE.
I'M SORRY I HEARD YOU.
SENATOR LEYVA HAS MOVED THE BILL
SENATOR PAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE
CLOSING STATE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR EITHER.
OKAY WITH WE CAN OF THE ROLL
CALL THIS IS WHO PASSED TO
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE.
PAN HI CAN I STONE.
STONE NOW TORONTO.
DRAWS A AYE GROVE HER TADO.
LEYVA LEYVA AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING AYE AYE
MONNING AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
RUBIO I SIX ONE SENATOR PAN THAT
BILL IS OUT -- WE'RE NOW IT SB
SIX ONE TWO THANK YOU THANKS
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
THREATS CHAIR -- MEMBERS -- WE
WE JUST SPENT SOME TIME TALKING
ABOUT THE IN THIS COMMITTEE
ABOUT THE NEED TO EXPAND
ENROLLMENT TO HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE AND WE ALSO HAD HER HER
HEARING EARLIER THIS YEAR.
BUT WHAT HAPPENS ONCE ALL
CALIFORNIA'S HAVE COVERAGE WITH
A FOCUS ON THE 40% OF
INDIVIDUALS IN CALIFORNIA WHO
HAVE ONE OR MORE CHRONIC
CONDITIONS -- WE EXAMINE MODELS
OF CARE THAT CAN IMPROVE PATIENT
OUTCOMES WE DISCUSSED HOW IT IF
WE SHOULD SEND IT SHOULD
INCENTIVIZE A STANDARDIZED THESE
MODELS ACROSS PROGRAMS.
IT WAS ENCOURAGING TO HEAR THAT
PROVIDERS PLANS AND STATE
DEPARTMENT AGENCIES ARE WORKING
TOWARDS IMPROVING THE DELIVERY
OF CARE FOR PATIENTS BUT WE ALSO
REALIZE THAT IF THERE'S LITTLE
COORDINATION TO SHARE
INFORMATION THE BEST OUTCOMES
IMPROVED EFFICIENCIES IN PATIENT.
BETTER PATIENT CARE WE ARE NOT
GOING TO REALIZE THE BENEFITS OF
THAT AND FORTUNATELY FACTOR EVEN
EVEN NOW THERE'S NOT A
COMPREHENSIVE LIST OF CURRENT
EFFORTS WE NEED MORE INFORMATION
SO WE THAT WE CAN BRING PROJECTS
OF HIGH QUALITY OUTCOMES THE
SCALE.
STATE WIDE THIS BILL PROVIDES
BASELINE DATA ON ACTIVITIES TO
PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY CARE
IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH CHRONIC
DISEASES.
AND AGAIN YEAH WE TO WE TALKED
ABOUT FORD ABILITY AND HELP THIS
IS THE FIRST STEP TO GET THIS
KIND OF DATA TO LINE INCENTIVES
SO THAT WE CAN FINALLY -- BEND
THAT COST CURVE AND PARTICULARLY
FOR THE PEOPLE CHRONIC DISEASE
THAT'S ACTUALLY CUT SPEND 7280%
THE HEALTHCARE DOLLAR I STRICTLY
ASPEN AYE VOTE NO WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
KELLY BEING HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
pSIX ONE TWO PATIENTS SUFFERING
FROM MULTIPLE OR SEVERE CHRONIC
CONDITIONS OFTEN RECEIVE HEALTH
CARE THAT IS FRAGMENTED IN
EPISODIC.
THAT IS WHY CMA SUPPORTS
IMPROVING CARE DELIVERY FOR
THESE PATIENTS THAT THE CARE
THEY RECEIVE IS COMPREHENSIVE
COORDINATED.
PATIENT CENTRIC CENTERED AND
ACCESSIBLE SB SIX ONE TWO WOULD
BACK THESE EFFORTS BY COMPILING
THE DATA TO HELP PAVE THE WAY TO
IMPROVE HEALTH OUTCOMES AND
REDUCED HEALTH CARE SPENDING WE
ARE DRIVE OUT.
THANK YOU FOR TESTIMONY.
GOOD EVENING AND JDS HERE ON
BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA PLEASES SUPPORT SB
SIX TWELVE WHICH WOULD ACTUALLY.
COMPLEMENT WHAT COVER CALIFORNIA
FORTY DOES AND IT'S AN
ATTACHMENT SEVEN REPORTING --
ATTACHMENT SEVEN REQUIRES
COVERED CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLANS
SO OR DO YOU REPORT ON COST
QUALITY AND HEALTH DISPARITIES
DATA.
AS WELL AS THEIR PARTICIPATION
IN THE COLLABORATIVE AND QUALITY
INITIATIVES THAT THE ENGAGEMENT
IN ORDER TO REDUCE --
DISPARITIES AN INSURER POSITIVE
HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR THESE
REASONS WE SUPPORT -- SB SIX
TWELVE AND AS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE
STEP FORWARD.
SAYING THAT NEITHER ANY
OPPOSITION SB SIX ONE TO PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS NICK LOUISE
US ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS ARE ALL
BE BRIEF -- BUT WE WE DO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB.
SIX TWELVE ON AND WE DO
APPRECIATE THE INTENT OF THE BUT
WE DON'T HAVE A QUARREL.
ANY QUARREL WITH YOU'LL TO MY
GOAL IN OF COURSE A COUPLE OF
OUR MEMBER HEALTH PLANS
PARTICIPATED IN RECENT HEARING
OF THIS COMMITTEE ABOUT.
ALIGNING INCENTIVES IN A
COMMERCIAL -- IN PUBLIC COVERAGE
WHERE THEY SHARE THEIR THOUGHTS
AND RECOMMENDATION -- OUR OUR
OPPOSITION IS BASED ON THE FACT
THAT THIS IS A NEW REPORTING
REQUIREMENT ON HEALTH PLANS THAT
WE BELIEVE DRIVES UP THE
ADMINISTRATIVE LOAD
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS FROM OUR
MEMBERS -- A NUMBER OF HEALTH
PLANS ALSO USE DELEGATED MODEL --
WHERE THEY DON'T GET A LOT OF
RESPONSIBILITY TO THEIR MEDICAL
GROUPS AND SO OBTAINING YES A
LOT OF THE INFORMATION REQUIRED
BY THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE A
SURVEY OUR PROVIDER GROUPS --
AND THIS WOULD BE A HEAVY BURDEN
ON PHYSICIANS -- WE ARE
SENSITIVE TO THE FACT THAT --
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF BILLS THAT
HAVE BEEN INTRODUCED IN THIS --
SESSION THAT ARE REQUIRED NEW --
REPORTING AND DATA --
SUBMISSIONS BY THE PLANS -- WE
KNOW WE'RE WERE UNDER CONSTANT
PRESSURE BY POLICYMAKERS AND
OTHERS TO KEEP OUR
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS DOWN SO FOR
THAT REASON.
WE NEED TO OPPOSE THIS BILL BUT
AGAIN -- YOU KNOW IF THIS IS A
STARTING POINT FOR THE
DISCUSSIONS WE LIKE TO BE A PART
OF THOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY OF
ANY OTHERS IN OPPOSITION TO SB
ONE SIX ONE TO PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
SEEING NONE COME BACK TO THE
DAIS.
TURNING COMMENTS OR IS THERE A
MOTION.
THE MOVE BY A CENTER TADO --
CENTER PAN WHICH I COMMITTEE
CLOSING COMMENTS I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT IT IS A STARTING POINT
FOR FOR IMPORT DISCUSSION AND I
APPRECIATE WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE HEALTH PLANS
ON THIS BECAUSE THE IDEA IS THAT
WE ALL LINE UP -- COME TOGETHER
AND LINE INCENTIVES AND WE ARE
HEARING WE TALKED ABOUT PLANS
MEDICAL GROUPS DELEGATED MODELS
AND IN DOWN TO THE FIGHTER BUT
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU'RE A ON
THIS YOU KNOW YOUR DOCTOR AND
PRACTICE AND YOU HAVE ONE NO ONE
PLAN ONCE THIS ANOTHER PLAN ONCE
THAT.
AND THEN WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT IT.
YOU'RE NOT MAKING THAT YOU'RE
NOT BEING A CURVE SO WE NEED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE THE PLATFORM
FOR PEOPLE WORK TOGETHER AND
TREAT THOSE OPPORTUNITIES AND
LOOK FOR TO WORK WITH THE HEALTH
PLANS ON THAT AS WELL OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER AND I WAS GOING
TO VOTE NO ON THE BILL BUT I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
WORK DILIGENTLY WITH HEALTH
PLANS I'M GONNA LAY OFF TODAY
AND HOPEFULLY YOU GUYS WILL COME
TOGETHER BECAUSE I THINK.
THE GOAL IS A IS A GOOD ONE SO --
BUT THAT THAT WILL CALL THE ROLL.
FAN HI AND I STONE.
DORADO.
DRUGS -- I GROWTH.
HER TADO.
HER TOTAL AYE LEYVA LEYVA AYE
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING MONNING I
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE.
THAT IS TO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
IN THE VOTE IS. SEVEN ZERO THANK
YOU.
AND I WILL MOVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WATER.
WE HAVE ONE ITEM ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR -- THAT'S ITEM NUMBER
SIX SB THREE EIGHTY NINE TO THE
MOVE BY CENTER STONE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AND STONE.
STONE I'D DORADO.
DRESSEL I GROW [inaudible]
HER TITLE.
OUR TOTAL AYE LEYVA LIVE AYE
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING MONNING AYE
RUBIO [inaudible]
REVIEW BY.
SAID CALLAN THE VOTE IS EIGHT
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR OUT.
OKAY LET'S GO BACK WE'LL JUST GO
AND THE FILE ORDER -- SO WE WE
HAVE.
A ONE OUNCE. TO WITHOUT TEN OKAY
ALL RIGHT SO LET'S MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER THREE SB -- TWO SEVEN
SEVEN BY SIR LEYVA SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT
MEMBERS RAZA.
DRAWS -- I GROW UP SORRY SHE WAS
HERE HER TACO. FOR TITLE I
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
AYE MONNING AYE RUBIO
[inaudible]
IBM. SIXTEEN THAT BILLS OUT.
SIX TO OUR NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER FOUR SB THREE OH FIVE BY
CENTER HUESO SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THAT SOME MEMBERS.
ARE TADO.
HER TITLE I MITCHELL.
I MONNING.
MONNING AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO HI.
THAT BILLS OUT NINE IS ZERO NEXT
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB
THREE TWENTY FIVE BY CENTER TO
HELL SIXTY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THAT SOME MEMBERS ARE TADO. FOR
TITLE II MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING MONNING AYE
RUBIO.
RUBIO I NINE THE BILL IS OUT --
NINE ZERO NEXT ITEMS I AND
NUMBER SIX SB.
THREE EIGHTY NINE WE DID IT
CONSENT SORRY I NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SEVEN SB FOUR
TWENTY FOUR BY SENATOR JACKSON'S
PRESENTED BY SIR DORADO SIXTY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS.
GROVE HER TADO.
TITLE I RUBIO.
RUBIO I NUMBER.
SEVEN THAT BILLS OUT SEVEN ONE
SIX BILLS THE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
AS BEFORE FORTY FIVE BY CENTER
PORTANTINO SURGERY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THAT SOME NUMBERS --
TADO.
HER TITLE BY MITCHELL MITCHELL
AYE MONNING.
MONNING I NINE THE BILL IS OUT
NINE ZERO EXT ITEMS I AM NUMBER
NINE SP FOUR FIFTY EIGHT BY
CENTER DRAWS A SIX THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS.
GROVE HER TADO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
RUBIO I THAT BILLS OUT. SIX ONE
TWO A FINISHED NUMBER.
TEN NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER --
ELEVEN SP FIVE FIVE SEVENTY FOUR
BY SIR LEYVA SECTOR IF THESE
CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS.
FURTADO [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
RUBIO A MONNING THANK MONNING
AYE RUBIO.
SO THAT BILL.
OKAY KEEP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGAIN.
YES OKAY OKAY SO AGAIN THIS IS
SB FIVE SEVENTY FOUR BY CENTER
LEYVA -- AND THE TACTIC
FRAGRANCE CHEMICAL RIGHTS TO NO
ACTIVE.
TWENTY NINETEEN PLEASE.
CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS.
FOR TITLE II.
MITCHELL [inaudible]
SO.
FIVE THAT BILLS OUT.
FIVE TWO IT'S WEIRD TO TWELVE
RIGHT DOWN THE TWELFTH OKAY DID
FIND AN ACTION ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN WAS HELD IN COMMITTEE
SO -- THAT CONCLUDES THE AGENDA
OF THIS HEARING OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH I THINK
EVERYONE WHO PRESENTED TODAY.
AND WITH THAT WE ARE ADJOURNED